PLEASE. ALLEN ARCHULETA. BATES
BILL OR JUST. COPY AT ALL
CHIANG. SALLY DOT DORADO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ GROVE
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO TADO
JACKSON JONES LEYVA MCGUIRE
MITCHELL MONNING MORLOCK REAL
NIELSEN. PAN PORTANTINO ROTH
RUBIO SKINNER STERN STONE BURKE
Y. CASKEY WINNER WILK. A QUORUM
IS PRESENT WITH THE MEMORY
MEMBERS AND OUR GUEST BE ON THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IMPAIR THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN AFTER
WHICH PLEASE REMAIN STANDING
AND WILL BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. LET US CENTER
OURSELVES IN GOD'S PRESENCE
AGAIN. DIVINE CREATOR WE THANK
YOU FOR THE PRIVILEGE OF
PARTICIPATING IN YOUR CREATION.
LIKE ARTISANS BUILDING A
CATHEDRAL WE ARE ENGAGED IN
WORK THAT OUT LIVES US. THE
BUILDING OF JUSTICE TAKES
GENERATIONS KNOWING THIS WE DO
NOT GROW WEARY OR LOSE HEART.
SUSTAINED BY THOSE WHO HAVE
COME BEFORE WE CARRY ON AGAINST
ALL ODDS AGAINST ALL OPPOSITION.
WE'RE NOT INTIMIDATED BY THE
THOUGHTS THOSE WE WILL NOT
ACHIEVE OUR GOALS IN ONE
LIFETIME. THIS IS NOT FOR US.
BUT FOR OUR CHILDREN'S
CHILDREN'S CHILDREN. OUR LITTLE
TRIUMPHS AND FAILURES ARE IN NO
BILLS NOT BY OUR SUCCESSES BUT
BY THE IMMENSE GRACE OF THE
WORK TO WHICH WE DEVOTE
OURSELVES. THAT IS SERVING THE
COMMON GOOD. MAINTAINING THE
FABRIC OF OUR WORLDS. AND
SEEKING THAT JUSTICE WHERE ALL
MEASURE THE BLESSINGS OF YOUR
EXISTENCE A MAN. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE. AND. THIS IS
A LITTLE YEAH
. GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO GET
STARTED. I JUST WANT TO LET
EVERYONE KNOW THAT WE HAVE
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
BILLS TO GET THROUGH THIS WEEK
SO JUST KEEP THAT IN MIND AS
WE'RE ALL ON THE FLOOR AND
PRESENT VOTING. MORE BILLS THAT
WE HAVE TO PUT ON CALL THE
LONGER IT TAKES US TO GET THE
BILLS OUT FIRST JUST A LITTLE
HOUSEKEEPING FOR YOU THERE ARE
NO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED WE ARE
MOVING TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
TWELVE NINETY ITEM FIFTY SEVEN
AB NINE THIRTEEN ITEM EIGHTY
NINE AB NINE TWENTY AND ITEM
ONE ELEVEN AB FIFTEEN SIXTY ONE.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN BE THE FOLLOWING BILLS
ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM THIRTY EIGHT AB
FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOUR ITEM
SEVENTY ONE AB NINE A ONE. ITEM
SEVENTY FIVE AB EIGHTEEN TEN
ITEM EIGHTY FIVE AB SEVEN FIFTY
FOUR I'D OF NINETY SEVEN AB
SEVEN TWENTY THREE. ITEM ONE OH
FOUR AB TEN EIGHTY ITEM ONE OH
SIX AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY THREE
ITEM ONE EIGHTEEN AB NINE
THIRTY SIX. ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO
A. B. FIFTEEN THIRTEEN AND ITEM
ONE THIRTY TWO AB THIRTEEN
SIXTY SIX. THE LITTLE OUT AT
THE BACK OF CHAMBERS MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ATTENTION.
WE ARE MOVING TO CONSIDERATION
OF THE DAILY FILE WE ARE GOING
TO START WITH THE SECOND
READING MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL.
1-482-182-5740 FOURTH.
1-133-136-5590 EIGHT TWELVE
FORTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE YOU
MISTER SECRETARY THE SECOND
READING WILL BE DEEMED READ. WE
ARE NOW MOVING ON TO SENATE
THIRD READING WE HAVE TWO ITEMS
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT
SENATOR SKINNER. NOT AT HER
DESK FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY NINE
SENATOR ALLEN NOT AT HIS DESK
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING. AND WE'RE
STARTING WITH FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY SENATOR WIENER. NOT AT
HIS DESK MEMBERS OF WE CAN GET
EVERYONE ON THE FLOOR WE CAN
GET STARTED. PASS ON FILE WELL
ITEM ONE FORTY FIVE SENATOR
MCGUIRE. TEMPORARY PASS ON FILE
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SENATOR
SKINNER ONE ASSEMBLY THIRD
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE THAT UP. OKAY VERY
GOOD MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE
NINETY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CART MCCARTY AND ACT REALLY TO
FARMS. SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU MADAM MEMBER AT MADAME
PRESIDENT MEMBERS APOLOGIES
THERE I'M AB TWELVE NINETY
SEVEN. ALLOWS FOR COUNTIES IN
OUR OUR SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENTS
TO. SET REASONABLE FEES TO
COVER THE COST OF ISSUING
CONCEALED CARRY WEAPONS PERMITS
OUR STATE AUDITOR DID A REPORT
ON THIS ISSUE AND REPORTED BACK
TO US THAT HE CURRENT CAP ON
FEES IS NOT ADEQUATE FOR TO
COVER THE COUNTIES IN THE
SHERIFF'S PROCESSING COSTS. SO
WHAT THE BILL DOES IS ALLOW FOR
THAT AND ALLOWS FOR THEM TO BE
ABLE TO COVER THEIR COSTS TO
OBTAIN AND ENFORCE THE PERMITS
AND WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
SKINNER MEMBERS TO HAVE A
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
MISTER SECRETARY WOMAN MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLE ONE TIME AND WE'RE PLACING
MEASURES ON CALL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA. I ATKINS BATES NO
BILL. HI OKAY. CORD GORGEOUS NO
BRADFORD. I COME HERE ALL.
CHIANG NO DALY NO DOT. I DORADO
I GALGIANI. GLAZER. GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO HIGHER TADO NO JACKSON HI
JONES. NO LEYVA HI I'M ACQUIRE
BY MITCHELL. MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH.
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER FIVE A CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK NO. THE US
SECRETARY SENATOR MOVES THE
CALL CENTERS SKINNER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO GO BACK TO YOUR FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT. ONE
MOMENT. KEEP IT GOING. ONE
FORTY EIGHT SHE HAS ON FILE AT
SOME POINT A VERY GOOD ALL
RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE STILL ON
ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY
ONE SENATOR BRADFORD. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION NINETY
ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER RELATIVE TO SECOND
CHANCES MONTH. CENTER BRADFORD
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT ACR
NINETY ONE SIMPLY RECOGNIZES
JUNE AS SECOND CHANCES MONTH
THIS REALLY RESOLUTION
EMPHASIZES THE NEED FOR SUPPORT
OF SERVICES IN HELPING THE
SUCCESSFUL RE ENTRY OF FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS HOW MANY
CRIMINAL RECORD HAS CREATED
ADDITIONAL BARRIERS FOR
SECURING HOUSING. EMPLOYMENT
AND EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES
WHEN PEOPLE CAN'T PROVIDE FOR
THEIR FAMILIES OR FEEL A SENSE
OF COMMUNITY YOUR CHANCES THE
RESET OF AIDING INCREASES. THIS
EXPERIENCE OF BEING BLOCKED
FROM JOB OPPORTUNITIES HOUSING
OPTIONS FOR EVEN ACCESS TO
EDUCATION IS OFTEN CALL SECOND
PRESENT THEREFORE RATHER THAN
CONTINUE TO PUNISH PEOPLE OF
SERVE THEIR TIME WE NEED TO
SUPPORT THEM IN REHABILITATING
AND OP PREVENTION OUT OF
EFFORTS ACR NINETY ONE
DEMONSTRATES. THE LEGISLATURE'S
COMMITMENT FOR SUCCESSFUL
REINTEGRATION AND MAINTAINS A
GOAL TO BUILD STRONGER SAFER
COMMUNITIES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. NOBEL BY BURGESS
BRADFORD I COUNTY AT ALL.
CHIANG NO DALLY DODD. BY DORADO
I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TITLE HI JACKSON. BY JONES
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONNING BY MORE
LOCK. REAL NO NIELSEN NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. I
RUBIO I SKINNER BY STERN AYE
STONE NO BURKE HI Y. CASKEY BY
WIENER AYE WILK. SENATOR MOVES
A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO IF I
CAN ASK EVERYONE JUST TO QUIET
DOWN A LITTLE BIT IT'S VERY
HARD TO HEAR UP HERE AND
EVERYONE'S WORKING THERE BILLS
BUT WE HAVE A LOT TO GET
THROUGH BOB FOLLOWED ONE FIFTY
TWO. SENATOR TO RUSSELL. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. PASS ON
FILE FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY THREE
SENATOR HUESO. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AN ACT RELATED
VEHICLES CENTER HUESO. THIS IS
A BILL SHOULD BE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR BUT. SIXTEEN OF
FOURTEEN WILL EXTEND THE SUNSET
DATE FOR THE CURRENT DMB
REGISTRATION TECHNOLOGY PILOT
PROGRAM TO JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS IS A
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT A MEASURE
THAT WAS SO ON CONSENT THROUGH
TRANSPORTATION COMMITTEE AS
WELL AS PREPARATION SO. AS FOR
NOW VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
HUESO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS EIGHT HI BILL. HI
GORGEOUS HI BRADFORD. I
CABALLERO. CHIANG. HI DOLLY HI
DODD. I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TOTO HI. IT'S HARD. JACKSON
HI JONES. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
BY MITCHELL HI MONNING I'M MORE
LUCK I'M REAL BY NIELSEN AYE
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. BY BURKE HI MY COUNTY BY
WIENER AYE WILK. HI SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. I'M SORRY
CAN YOU CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON ONE FIFTY THREE ONE MORE
TIME. ATKINS. ZERO CABALLERO.
OKAY SENATOR MOVES A FILE
MOVING TO FILE A MUSICAL MOVIE
TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SIX
SENATOR HERTZBERG BY ONE FIFTY
SIX. PASS ON FILE FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SEVEN SENATOR PAN IS
READY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AND ACTUALLY TO HEALTH
CARE COVERAGE SENATOR PAN THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT'S
DECISION TO ZERO OUT TH
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE PENALTY IS
PROJECTED TO RESULT IN A.
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND TO FOUR
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
ADDITIONAL CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT
HEALTH COVERAGE BY TWENTY
TWENTY. IN THE RECENT BUDGET
PROPOSAL IN SB SEVENTY EIGHT
RECOGNIZES THIS CONCERN AND
INCLUDES THE STATE INDIVIDUAL
MANDATE PENALTY WHICH PROVIDES
IMMEDIATE RELIEF TO
CALIFORNIANS TO PREVENT FURTHER
DESTABILIZATION OF THE
INSURANCE MARKET AND RISING
PREMIUMS. EIGHTY FOUR FOURTEEN
ONE SURE TO THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD HAS DATA TO INFORM THE
LEGISLATURE REGARDING THE
INDIVIDUAL MANDATE INCLUDING
THE NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS
PAYING THE PENALTY THE TOTAL
AMOUNT OF STATE COUNTY BEING
OPPOSED. AND THE NUMBER OF
EXEMPTIONS APPLY. THIS IS
IMPORTANT DATA FOR US TO INFORM
OUR FUTURE DECISIONS ARE
STRICTLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. HI ATKINS
BATES BELL FIVE LARGEST
BRADFORD I CABALLERO. I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO.
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROW I HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
WITH SO. I TITLE I JACKSON BY
JONES EVERYTHING I LEYVA. HI FI
MCGUIRE MITCHELL. HI MONNING
I'M MORE LOCK I'M REAL. NIELSEN
AYE PAN BY PORTANTINO. I ROTH
AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE. NO NUMBER. HI WHAT
COUNTY HI WINNER. HI WILK HI
THANK YOU SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY FOUR SENATOR DORADO.
NOT AT HER DESK FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY SIX SENATOR RUBIO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY AND NOT
GOING TO INSURANCE INCLUDING
THEIR TO THEIR OF TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU PRESIDENTE
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN UP RELATED
TO INSURANCE OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES HAVE COSTS TRAGIC
LOSS OF LIFE. RECORD BREAKING
PROPERTY LOSSES AND AN
INSURANCE COMPANY AND SOLVENCY
HOT SO TODAY I'M HERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR OUR CONSTITUENTS
HOMEOWNERS WHO HAVE HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME OBTAINING
COVERAGE FOR NON RENEWALS. IN
HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS OF THE
STATE AB EIGHTEEN SIXTEEN DOES
THREE THINGS TO STRENGTH IN THE
INSURANCE MARKET AND HELP
STRUGGLING HOMEOWNERS. FIRST
THIS BILL PROVIDES GREATER
PROTECTION FOR POLICY HOLDERS
OF THEIR INSURANCE GOALS
INSOLVENT SECOND THE BILL
INCENTIVIZE AS INSURERS TO
WRITE ON ON HIGH FIRE RISK
AREAS BY EXPANDING THE AREAS
THAT QUALIFY FOR A RIGHT OUT
CREDIT. AGAINST FUTURE
ASSESSMENTS BY THE CALIFORNIA
FAIR PLAN. THIRD THE BILL GIVES
POLICY HOLDERS AN ADDITIONAL
MONTH OVER THE EXISTING FORTY
FIVE DAY PERIOD TO FIND YOU
INSURANCE IF THEIR CURRENT
INSURER NON RENEWS THEIR POLICY
THIS BILL WITH CAREFULLY
NEGOTIATED HAS NO OPPOSITION
AND HAS RECEIVED UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
CENTER BORDERS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST WANT TO LET MY
SUPPORT TO THIS BILL I THINK
THIS IS HUGELY IMPORTANT TWO
WEEKS AGO OR THEREABOUTS I HAD
DAY COMMUNITY MEETING WITH THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER RICARDO
LARA. IN MY NECK OF THE WOODS
IN TWELVE ME COUNTY. I GOT TO
TELL YOU I'VE NEVER SEEN. IT
IMPACTED AREA OF FILLED WITH
PEOPLE WHO ARE SCARED CONCERNS
I MEAN THEY'RE ABSOLUTELY
DESPERATE. AND WE TOLD THEM
ABOUT THIS BILL HE WAS OR AT
LEAST A RAY OF HOPE. THE IDEA
OF EXTENDING THE TIME LIMIT IN
HAND SEEING THE COVERAGE
AMOUNTS THIS IS A STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I ABSOLUTE
COURAGE EVERYONE IN THIS
CHAMBER TO BE SUPPORTIVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR BORDERS THIRD DOLLY.
THIRTY BETTER PRESENT I ALSO
STAND IN SUPPORT THIS BILL OF
IN MY DISTRICT WE AS YOU ALL
KNOW WE LONG HAD THEIR LAST
YEAR WE HAD THE CAMPFIRE BUT
THE CAR FIRE WHICH IS IN
REDDING WE LOST AND I
REPRESENTED MIGUEL YOU AND YOU
COUNTY WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY. WE HAVE A LOT OF
FOLKS WHO WERE IN IT IN.
THERE'S A LOT OF VEGETATION AND
THEY'RE NOT THEY'RE BEING NON
RENEWED SO. THIS BILL IS A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION TO HELP
THEM. GIVE A LITTLE MORE TIME
TO. SEARCH THE MARKETS. AND BE
ABLE TO RETAIN INSURANCE IT'S
BEEN A REALLY DIFFICULT. LAST
COUPLE MONTHS BECAUSE WE'RE
JUST ON A LOT OPTIONS THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF RISK IN
CALIFORNIA. YOU TO CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRE IN THE IN THE
COMPANIES ARE. MOVING OUT AND
SO EVEN AS A LEGISLATORS THIS
IS ONLY ONE. ONE OF THE ONLY
THINGS WE REALLY CAN DO BECAUSE
IT'S ABOUT RISK. BUT WE'LL BE
LOOKING CLOSER NEXT YEAR. THE
BILL TO COME BACK WITH SOME
MORE SOLUTIONS SO PEOPLE CAN
GET THEIR- HOMES INSURED SO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATE DOLLY MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
NG IN HEARING MANSON TO REVEAL
WHICH LIKE TO CLOSE. JUST THANK
YOU I WOULD JUST LIKE TO ECHO
THE COMMENTS OF. MY COLLEAGUE
SAYS YOU KNOW IT IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT BILL IT'S JUST ONE
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION AND
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
POLICY. IN THE FOLLOWING YEARS
TO ENSURE THAT DOT. IT'S WE
STRENGTH AND- PROTECTIONS FOR
HOMEOWNERS THINK IT WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR A RIVAL. THANK YOU
SENATOR RUBIO MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. BY
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS. BATES HI
BILL. HI BURGESS. I BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO. BY CHIANG AYE
DALY AYE DODD. EITHER ALSO.
GALGIANI. HI GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROWTH HI HERTZBERG.
HILL. WITH SO HIGHER TOTAL I
JACKSON I JONES. BY LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M
MORE LOCK BY MERRELL BY NELSON.
PAN HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY STERN.
STONE. BUY AMERICAN OUR CASKEY
I WINNER BY WILK. HI SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
SEVEN SENATOR SKINNER. FOLLOWED
ONE SIXTY SEVEN. PASS ON FILE
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY SENATOR
BRADFORD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE AN ACT RELATNG TO
INMATES CENTER BRADFORD THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AB FORTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMAN STONE WOULD
PROHIBIT CALIFORNIA PRISONS AND
JAILS FROM CHARGING COPAYMENTS
FOR MEDICAL AND DENTAL HEALTH
VISITS A FIVE DOLLAR FEE MAY
SEE SMALL TO MANY OF US HERE.
AND FOR THOSE OUTSIDE THE
PRISON SYSTEM BUT AND
INCARCERATED PERSON WORKING FOR
EIGHT CENTS AN HOUR WOULD NEED%
TO WORK OVER SIXTY HOURS JUST
AFFORD ONE MEDICAL VISIT. IN
SURVEYS OF INCARCERATED PEOPLE
MORE THAN 50% REPORT THE DAY
AVOID HEALTH CARE TO THE COSTLY
COPAYMENTS. LIMITING HEALTHCARE
ACCESS. IN THIS WAY CAUSES
UNNECESSARY SUFFERING AND
WORSENS MEDICAL CONDITIONS IN
ADDITION ON MARCH FIRST OF THIS
YEAR CDC ARE ANNOUNCED THAT
THEY WOULD NO LONGER CHARGE
COPAYS BY LIMóN A CO PAYMENTS
WITH THIS BILL WE CAN EXTEND
COMMONSENSE POLICIES. ARE IN
OUR COUNTIES IN CITY JAILS ARE
RISK BERKELEY ESCRIBO. THANK
YOU SENATOR READ FOR MEMBERS
ANY DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES.
NO BILL BY BURGESS NO BRADFORD
I CAMBIADO NO CHIANG. NO DALY
NO DODD. DROUGHT SO. GALGIANI
GLAZER. GONZALEZ BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO BY
OUR TITLE NO JACKSON I JONES.
NO LEYVA BY MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. HI MORE
LACKEY. HI MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER HI STERN. STONE
NOVEMBER. BY KATHY HI WINNER BY
WILK NO. CENTER MOVES A FILE
BUT IS REMINDED THOSE IN THE
BACK OF CHANGER CHAMBERS YOUR
LITTLE LOUDER MAKES A LITTLE
HARD FOR US TO HEAR FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY THREE CENTER
MCGUIRE ARE YOU PREPARED. PASS
ON FILE FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY
FOUR SENATOR JACKSON'S. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FOUR THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AN ACT REALLY INTO
EMPLOYMENT SENATE JACKSON THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THIS MEASURE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KALRA INCREASES THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS FOR FILING A WORKER
RETALIATION CLAIM FROM SIX
MONTHS TO TWO YEARS AND ADDS
THE ABILITY TO SYNC ATTORNEY'S
FEES FOR PREVAILING EMPLOYEES.
WE KNOW WORKPLACE RETALIATION
OCCURS WHEN EMPLOYERS DOES
CHARGE THREATEN TO DISCHARGE TO
MODE SUSPEND OR SUBJECT
EMPLOYEES TO AN ADVERSE
EMPLOYMENT ACTION FOR
EXERCISING THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THE LABOR CODE FORMS OF
RETALIATION CAN RANGE FROM
SUBTLE WORKPLACE INTIMIDATION.
OUTRIGHT THREATS SUCH AS
THREATENING DEPORTATION.
RETALIATION IS NOT ONLY
PERVASIVE BUT ALSO A GROWING
PROBLEM DUE TO THE CURRENT
POLITICAL CLIMATE SURROUNDING
IMMIGRATION. IN FACT IN ITS
TWENTY SEVENTEEN RETALIATION
COMPLAINT REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER REPORTED A
DOUBLING OF THE NUMBER OF
RETALIATION COMPLAINT BASED
UPON SEX RACE OR ETHNICITY FROM
THE PREVIOUS YEAR. IMMIGRATION
RELATED WORKPLACE RETALIATION
ESPECIALLY SAW A SIGNIFICANT
UPTAKE FROM TWENTY CASES IN
TWENTY SIXTEEN TO NINETY FIVE
CASES IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. IF
AN EMPLOYEE HAS A STRONG CLAIM.
OFTENTIMES THE BURDEN OF PAYING
ATTORNEYS FEES CAN BE A
DETERRENT FOR AN AGGRIEVED
WORKER. ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
ARE IN LOW WAGE POSITIONS.
THREE YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED IN THE GOVERNOR SIGNED
AS BEING THAT NINETY SIX INTO
LAW WHICH AUTHORIZES THE COURT
TO AWARD REASONABLE ATTORNEY'S
FEES FROM THE EMPLOYER IF THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER PREVAILS
THIS BILL SIMPLY BUILDS UPON
THAT MEASURE BY PROVIDING THE
SAME RIGHT TO PRIVATE
ATTORNEYS. WHO TAKE THESE
RETALIATION CASES OFTEN ON A
PRO BONO BASIS ON BEHALF OF
WORKERS WITH MORE TME TO FILE
AB FOUR OH THREE STRENGTHENS
THE LEGAL RIGHTS OF WHISTLE
BLOWERS WHO FACE RETALIATION.
AND ESPECIALLY HELPS LOWER WAGE
WORKERS ATTAIN LEGAL
REPRESENTATION WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER STONE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE AND
OPPOSE AB FOUR OH THREE. I HAD
THE PLEASURE OF BEING AT THE
REPUBLICAN CONVENTION OF THE
WEEKEND AND HEARD FROM THE
FORMER GOVERNOR OF TEXAS RICK
PERRY. WHO TALK ABOUT HOW EASY
PICKINGS CALIFORNIA WAS TO TAKE
BUSINESSES OUT OF CALIFORNIA.
AND BRING ON THE TAXES OF ONE
OF THOSE ISSUES WAS BECAUSE OUR
TOWARD SITUATION IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. INSTEAD OF
REQUESTING AND HAVING THOSE AT
THE BEEN AGGRIEVED BY THEIR
EMPLOYERS TO QUICKLY STAND UP
AND MAKE ISSUE WHETHER BE LEGAL
OR OTHERWISE ABOUT A- JOB
RELATED ISSUE. THIS IS GOING TO
FURTHER EXACERBATE ARE TOWARD
SITUATION INSTEAD CALIFORNIA
BUT REALLY IS WHAT I WOULD CALL
ON BALANCE. ON BALANCE JUSTICE
BECAUSE OF YOUR PLAINTIFF AND
YOU PREVAIL YOU'RE GUARANTEED
TO GET YOUR ATTORNEY FEES PAID
BUT- IF YOU'RE A DEFENDANT AND
YOU PREVAIL. THE ONLY WAY THAT
YOU CAN PREVAIL IS A SHOW THAT
THE CLAIM WAS FRIVOLOUS SO THIS
IS UNBALANCED AGAIN IN THE
FAVOR OF. THOSE THAT WISH TO
SEE DEEP POCKETS OF EMPLOYERS
FOR SOME FRIVOLOUS CLAIMS SOME
LEGITIMATE CLAIM TO WE SHOULD
<c.green>E EXTENDING THAT PERIOD.</c>
UNLESS WE EVEN THE PLAYING
FIELD LET'S HAVE THE DEFENDANT
ATTORNEYS IF THEY PREVAIL TO BE
ABLE TO GET ATTORNEY FEES FROM
THOSE THAT ARE FINDING CASES
AGAINST THEM. SO AGAIN
CALIFORNIA REMAINS BUSINESS
UNFRIENDLY WE CONTINUE THAT
MANTRA COLLEAGUES WE MAY NOT
FEEL THE EFFECTS OF BUSINESS
FLEEING TE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
TODAY BUT I ASSURE YOU WITHIN
FIVE YEARS YOU ARE GOING TO
SEE. A DECREASE IN OUR REVENUES
A DECREASE IN JOBS AND
EXACERBATIONS OF ARE HOMELESS
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND YOU OWN
IT FOR THOSE REASONS I REJECT
AB EIGHT FOUR THREE WORSE
ENERGY TO VOTE NO. THANK YOU
CENTER STILL MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE THERE JACKSON WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU I
CHOSE TO ADDRESS ONE ISSUE IF
WE START SEEING A REDUCTION IN
THE INCOMES FROM THE INCOME OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT IS
CLEARLY DUE TO THE POLICIES OF
THIS CAR WHITE HOUSE THAT
SINGLE CELL CALIFORNIA TO TRY
DO EVERYTHING IT CAN TO
UNDERMINE OUR STRONG ECONOMY SO
THAT ARGUMENT IS JUST
ABSOLUTELY. INCORRECT AND DOT
WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT NOW IS
PROTECTING THE RIGHTS OF
EMPLOYEES CURRENTLY THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAS THE RIGHT TO
SEEK ATTORNEY'S FEES ARE NOT
MANDATORY BUT THEY ARE
AVAILABLE UPON REQUEST AN
APPLICATION TO THE COURT. THIS
BILL IS AN ATTEMPT TO MAKE SURE
THAT EMPLOYERS BEHAVE THE WAY
THEY'RE SUPPOSED TO. THIS ISN'T
TAKING GOOD PEOPLE AND
PUNISHING THEM FOR DOING THE
RIGHT THING THIS IS TAKING
EMPLOYERS WHO DO THE WRONG
THING WHO VIOLATE LABOR LAWS TO
TRY TO RETALIATE AGAINST THEIR
EMPLOYEES WHO TRY TO ASSERT
THEIR RIGHTS THAT'S WHAT THIS
BILL IS ABOUT WE REALIZE. THAT
WE NEED TO EXTEND THE STATUTE
BECAUSE OF SIX MY. KINDS OF
COMPLAINTS AND CANNOT FULLY DO.
THAT KIND OF WORK IN A PROPER
AN EXPEDITIOUS WAY ALLOWING A
PRIVATE RIGHT OF ACTION TO THE
EXTENT THEY PREVAIL IF THEY
DON'T PREVAIL. NOBODY GETS THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SEEK ATTORNEY'S
FEES BUT IF THEY DO PREVAIL
THEY WOULD BE ENTITLED TO THOSE
FEES IT'S JUST ANOTHER WAY TO
PROTECT WORKERS. WHO TRY TO
ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS UNDER WHICH
WE THROUGH OUR LAWS HAVE
pRESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS. BATES NOBEL. I PORGES
NO BRADFORD I CARRY IT ALL.
CHIANG. NO DALY NO DODD. DURAZO
GALGIANI GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL. I
WITH SO DATO. NO JACKSON BY
JONES NO LEYVA BUY MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL BY MORNING BY MORE
LOCK NO MORALE. NIELSEN. NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE. NO NUMBER. IRAQ OWSKI HI
WINNER BY WILK NO SENATOR MOVES
A CALL MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE
SENATORS SKINNER. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIVE TWENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AND ACT
REALLY IN DEALING ARTS CENTER
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS AB FIVE
TWENTY ONE TASKS THE UC DAVIS
FIREARM VIOLENCE RESEARCH
CENTER WITH RESEARCHING AND
DEVELOPING PROGRAMS FOR HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS SO THAT THEY CAN
PLAY A ROLE IN PREVENTING. GUN
VIOLENCE INJURIES AND DEATHS WE
KNOW THAT. DOCTORS EMERGENCY
ROOM NURSES SURGEONS ARE THE
ONES YOU INTERACT WITH VICTIMS
OF GUN VIOLENCE AND THEIR
FAMILIES AND THIS BILL
RECOGNIZES THAT HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS HAVE A UNIQUE ROLE IN
BOTH RESPONDING TO AND
PREVENTING GUN VIOLENCE AB FIVE
TWENTY ONE IS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. IS BROADLY
SUPPORTED BY MAJOR MENTAL
HEALTH AND MEDICAL ASSOCIATIONS
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION WITHOUT I
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS BATES.
BELL FIVE LARGEST BRADFORD.
CABALLERO BY. BRADFORD BRADFORD
I. CHIANG. DALY NO DODD. BY
DORADO GALGIANI GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROW NO HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE I
JACKSON. JONES. NOTE LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL HI MONNING
BY MORE LOCK WELL NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER AYE STERN. I
STONE NOVEMBER ABA CASKEY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. CENTER MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY SEVEN SENATOR
ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PERCENT. SENATOR ALLEN WAS
SEVENTY SEVEN. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
SEVENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
POLAND RELATING TO THE
POLITICAL FORM ACT OF NINETEEN
SEVENTY FOUR. SENATOR ALLEN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATORS CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF A
FEW STATES TO HAVE CITY KIND
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS.
BUT NO LOCAL CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS TO THIS MEANS THAT
UNLESS LOCAL GOVERNMENT ADOPTED
TONE CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS LITERALLY ANY AMOUNT TO
BE CONTRIBUTED DIRECTLY TO A
CANDIDATE FOR LOCAL OFFICE.
THIS IS KIND TO RIDICULOUS
PROPORTIONS IN SOME PLACES
WE'VE SEEN EXAMPLES OF CITY
COUNCIL MEMBERS RECEIVING
DIRECT CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A
SINGLE DONOR THAT ARE AS HIGH
AS A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
IN A SMALL CITY. PROVISIONS OF
THIS MAGNITUDE UNDERMINE PUBLIC
TRUST IN DEMOCRACY THIS BILL
DOES VERY SIMPLE THING IT
ESTABLISHES A DEFAULT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION LIMIT. AT THE SAME
LEVEL THAT WE HAVE HERE AT THE
STATE. FOR THOSE COUNTIES AND
CITIES THAT HAVE NOT ADOPTED
THEIR OWN LIMITS. AND SO BUT I
WILL SAY THIS MAINTAINS
COMPLETE LOCAL CONTROL SO IF IT
ANY POINT LOCAL JURISDICTION
WANTS TO OPT OUT BY ENACTING
ITS OWN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
WITH THE LOWER HIGHER THAN THE
DEFAULT THEY CAN THEY CAN DO
THAT. BUT THE WHAT WHAT THIS
DOES INSTEAD OF SETTING THE
DEFAULT AS THERE BEING NO
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS HE SAYS WE
OUGHT TO SET THE DEFAULT AT THE
STATE LEVEL FOR THE LEGISLATORS
AND THEN THE JURISDICTION CAN
GO LOWER HIGHER IF THEY WANT
TO. THIS A GOOD GOVERNANCE
MEASURE IT SUPPORTED BY ALL THE
GOOD GOVERNMENT GROUPS AND I
RESPECT FOR NAY VOTE ASK FOR A
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER ALLEN
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR PORCHES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ACTUALLY.
SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL A
DISTILLATION IN MY FORMER
CAPACITY AS A SUPERVISOR I HAD
TO PUT FORWARD A PIECE
LEGISLATION THAT DEALT WITH
TERM LIMITS AND CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS. NEITHER OF WHICH WERE
RECEIVED FAVORABLY MY DAD BUT
THE IDEA THAT WE HAVE SOME
UNIFORMITY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOING FROM THE LOCAL
ON UP TO THE STATE I THINK IS A
STEP IN THE RIGHT THE RIGHT
DIRECTION THERE'S A TON OF
DISPARITY. BOB FROM ONE
JURISDICTION TO THE NEXT AND I
SUPPORT. LOCAL CONTROL IN THIS
COMPROMISE LEGISLATION ALLOWS
FOR A BASS LINE TO EXIST BUT
LOCAL ENTITIES TO MAKE THEIR
OWN DECISIONS. SHOULD THEY WISH
TO SO I THINK THIS IS A SMART
MOVE FORWARD. THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. JONES
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
AND I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR AT
HAVING THE LOCAL CONTROL ASPECT
OF IT IN THERE BUT- I JUST FEEL
LIKE SOME OF THE REGULATIONS
ALREADY UNDER THE A FEW PC
CONTROL AND THE LOCAL CONTROL
REGARDING. CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
ARE REALLY INCUMBENT PROTECTION
TOOLS BECAUSE AS AN INCUMBENT
HI YOU WE'VE GOT ACCESS TO
STAFF AND CAMPAIGN FOLKS TO
HELP US COMPLY. WITH ALL THESE
RULES AND REGULATIONS WERE AS
SOMEBODY WHO'S LOOKING AT
GETTING INVOLVED IN THE
POLITICAL PROCESS AS A BEGINNER
AS A NEW PERSON RUNNING FOR
OFFICE. THEY'RE VERY CONVOLUTED
THEY'RE HARD TO UNDERSTAND IT'S
EASY TO MAKE A MISTAKE AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S ADDS TO THAT.
AND FOR THAT REASON I'LL BE
VOTING NO THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR JONES SAWYER STONE. THE
PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE IN
OPPOSITION AB FIVE SEVENTY ONE
COMING FROM THE COUNTY WHERE
WE'RE STILL KIND OF THE WILD
WEST OF POLITICS IN RIVERSIDE
COUNTY WE DON'T HAVE TERM
LIMITS WE DON'T HAVE CAMPAIGN
FINANCE LIMITS. WHEN I RAN FOR
SUPERVISOR OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY
THE FOURTH LARGEST COUNTY IN
THE STATE THE TENTH LARGEST
COUNTY IN THE COUNTRY I RAN
AGAINST AN ENTRENCHED INCUMBENT
IN A COUNTY WHERE AN INCUMBENT
HAD BEEN BE IN THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS. NOW IF YOU HAVE. LIMITS
THAT ARE PLACED UPON THOSE THAT
ARE TRYING TO CHALLENGE THE
STATUS QUO. THAT'S GONNA BE
VERY DIFFICULT BECAUSE INCOME
AND ESPECIALLY A SUPERVISOR HAS
A VAST ARRAY OF HIGH. DOLLAR
CONTRIBUTORS NAMELY DEVELOPERS.
AND SO FOR ME TO RUN FOR COUNTY
SUPERVISOR I CAN TELL YOU THAT
A LOT OF FOLKS THOUGHT I DIDN'T
HAVE A CHANCE BECAUSE THEY
CLAIM THAT WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
RAISE ENOUGH MONEY BUT THROUGH
A STRONG GRASSROOTS CAMPAIGN
AND YES. SOME DONORS AND WANTED
TO SEE A HIGHER QUALITY OF LIFE
AND RIVERSIDE COUNTY I RECEIVED
SOME LARGER CONTRIBUTIONS
STILL. NOT MATCHING WITH THE
INCOME AND SUPERVISOR HAD. I
WOULD SAY THAT WORKING ON THE
GROUND WALKING TWENTY THOUSAND
HOMES PROBABLY HAD A STRONG.
AFFECT ON MY ABILITY TO PREVAIL
IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND SO. I
ALSO AGREE THAT THIS IS NOTHING
MORE THAN AN IN COMBAT
PROTECTIVE MEASURE LET THE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS DECIDE FOR
THEMSELVES. WHAT THEY SHOULD DO
WITH REGARD TO ANY CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION LIMITS THAT THEY
WANT TO EMBRACE ANY AT ALL ONE
THING WE DON'T LIKE FROM LOCAL
GOVERNMENT TO MANY OF US CAME
FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT. I WHEN
WE OF THE LEGISLATURE TELL THEM
HOW THEY HAVE TO RUN THEIR
MUNICIPALITIES IT'S VERY
OFFENSIVE AND FOR THOSE REASONS
I URGE A NO VOTE IN SB FIVE.
SEVEN ONE. YOU CENTER SO
MEMBERS ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SENATOR ALAN JULY TO CLOSE.
FOR MEMBERS HI. THIS BILL DOES
NOT TELL THEM WHAT TO DO IT IF
HE DID ABSOLUTELY PRESERVES THE
LOCALITIES ABILITY. TO CHANGE
THE DEFAULT RIGHT NOW THE
DEFAULT IS THERE'S AN UNLIMITED
THERE'S NO LIMIT. ALL THIS AS
IT SHOULD FOR THE DEFAULT IS
BUT THEY CAN GO AHEAD AND CROSS
WHATEVER POLICY THE ONE. OF MY
ONE KINDOF QUESTION FOR YOU IS
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT BIG
DEVELOPERS GETTING INVOLVED
WITH RACES. THEY'RE THE ONES
WHO ARE THE MOST LIKELY TO STEP
UP WITH THE KINDS OF
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT WOULD BLOW
OUR CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION
LIMITS ON THE WATER. ME TELL
YOU THIS IS THIS IS THE
PRECISELY WHY THE KINDS OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE BEHIND
THIS BILL ARE BEHIND THIS BILL.
THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN. CALIFORNIA COMMON
CAUSE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA. REPRESENT US THESE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE NOT IN
THE INCUMBENT PROTECTION
BUSINESS THESE ORGANIZATIONS
THAT ARE IN THE GOOD GOVERNMENT
BUSINESS. WE SHOULD HAVE
CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION LIMITS
IT'S ONE WAY OF TRYING TO. HAVE
SOME LEVEL ACCOUNTABLE. COUNTY
BILLION OR SYSTEM AND I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA. ATKINS. BATES NOBEL
I PORGES AYE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG I DALY NO
DODD. BY DORADO. GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ. GROW BY
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HILL. I
WAS SO. BY TITLE I JACKSON.
JONES NO LEYVA HI I'M MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING BY
MORE LOCK NO MORALE NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN BY PORTANTINO. I ROTH BY
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER. OUR CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK. HI SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
SENATOR WHITE CAL SKI. PASS ON
FILE FILE. ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO
SENATOR BELL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER O'DONNELL AND ACT REALLY
INTO PUBLIC WORKS. SENATOR BELL.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THIS IS.
OF A LAW THAT. MAKES THE A
LOOPHOLE CLOSED. IN IN TERMS OF
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITIES THERE
FUNDED WITH. CONDUIT REVENUE
BONDS WHICH ARE TAX EXEMPT
BONDS OF THAT FINANCE THESE
FACILITIES ARE UNDER EXISTING
LAW CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITIES
ARE FUNDED WITH STATE EDUCATION
BONDS ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH PREVAILING WAGE AND HIGH
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS. ARE
UNDER THE FIELD ACT NOW THESE
OTHER BONTA CONDUIT REVENUE
BONDS WHICH RECEIVE THE BENEFIT
OF THE TAX EXEMPTION DO NOT.
THIS BILL AB SIXTEEN THIRTEEN
DEFINES PUBLIC WORKS INCLUDE A
CHARTER SCHOOL FACILITY
PROJECTS THAT RECEIVED. THE
FUNDING THROUGH THESE CONDUIT
REVENUE BONDS WOULD INSURE
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS RECEIVED FROM FRIENDLY
WAGE. AND ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT
FROM THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARJUN AYE VOTE IS THE
CLOSEST LUPO. THANK YOU SENATOR
BELL MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. NOBEL
BY PORGES NO BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG. DALY DODD I
DORADO. GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG.
HILL AYE HUESO I TADO. JACKSON.
JONES NO LEYVA TIME ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL. HI MONNING. BY MORE
LOCK. NO MORALE NO NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO BY ROTH HI
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE. NOVEMBER I WOULD COUNTY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK. SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS REMOVING
THE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY THREE
SENATOR CABALLERO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AND ACT
REALLY INTO STUDENT SUPPORT
SERVICES. SENATOR CABALLERO
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'M
PLEASED TO PRESIDE PRESENT AB
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
SINCERE PREVENT IMPLEMENTATION
OF AB FIVE FORTY THE CALIFORNIA
DREAM ACT AND OTHER MEANINGFUL
PIECES OF LEGISLATION. ACCESS
AND AFFORDABILITY TO HIGHER
EDUCATION IS NOW ATTAINABLE FOR
ARE UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT
POPULATION EACH YEAR
APPROXIMATELY NINETY EIGHT
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOLS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND 27%
OF THOSE STUDENTS GRADUATE FROM
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS. AB
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE WILL
DESIGNATE A DREAMER RESOURCE
LIE IS AN AT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITY TO
ENSURE THAT THESE GRADUATES AND
THEIR FAMILIES WILL HAVE ACCESS
TO THE RESOURCES TO NAVIGATE
THE HIGHER EDUCATION SYSTEM
WHICH AS WE ALL KNOW IS NOT ALL
THAT EASY. ESTABLISHING A
PERMANENT AN INSTITUTIONALIZED
DREAM RESOURCE LIES ON ON
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES. THE END OF ITS
STUDENTS WITH ADDICT
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT GUIDANCE
ABOUT STATE FUNDED LEGAL
SERVICES AN ON CAMPUS
PROTECTION POLICIES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE CENTER
MORLOCK. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. WHEN I FIRST WISH
EVERYBODY A HAPPY ADMISSION DAY.
ON SEPTEMBER NINTH EIGHTEEN
FIFTY WE BECAME THE THIRTY
FIRST ST SO HAPPY HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINTH BIRTHDAY. WELL
SENATOR THE MAJORITY LEADER WAS
YOUR AT THE TIME YOU CAN
PROBABLY REGALIS FOR SOME GREAT
STORIES. MADAM PRESIDENT. LAST
MONTH THE CALIPHATE UNIVERSITY
SYSTEM ISSUED ITS ANNUAL
AUDITED FINANCIAL STATEMENTS
FOR THE YEAR ENDED JUNE THIRTY.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN. IT NOW HAS AN
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT OF
SEVENTEEN BILLION SEVEN HUNDRED
AND NINETY SIX MILLION FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS NO LAST YEAR'S AUDITED
FINANCIAL STATEMENTS ONLY HAD
AN UNRESTRICTED NET THE PRESS
DEFICIT OF THREE BILLION SIX
HUNDRED AND SIXTY THREE MILLION
SEVEN HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
SO IT WENT UP FOURTEEN MILLION
ONE FOURTEEN BILLION ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY TWO MILLION
SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
FOURTEEN BILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE BASICALLY DO TO THE
REQUIREMENT THAT RETIREE
MEDICAL LIABILITIES NEED TO BE
REPORTED ON THE BALANCE SHEET.
THIS CREATED A FIVE FOLD
INCREASE IN THEIR NET DEFICIT.
THE COLLEAGUES PUTTING A
MANDATE ON THE CSU SYSTEM. THE
UC SYSTEM THE CCC'S. IT WILL
MEAN RAISING TUITION. WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO RAISE TUITION
RATES TO PAY FOR THESE COSTS
BECAUSE OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS ARE
GOING TO BE DEALING WITH SOME
MASSIVE LIABILITY ISSUES
RETIREE MEDICAL PENSION PLAN
FOR COLLEAGUES. WE'RE GOING TO
FIGURE OUT SOMEHOW IN THE
BUDGET TO FUND THIS OPPORTUNITY
OR WE SHOULD VOTE AGAINST AB
SIXTEEN FORTY FIVE WHICH IS
WHAT I'LL BE DOING MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING MANSON
RECOVER YOUR WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. IT JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS BATES NOBEL. I PURCHASE
NO BRADFORD. CAFIERO HI. CHIANG
NO DALY NO DODD. DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROVE. HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TACO.
I JACKSON. JONES NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING BY MORE LARK NO REAL.
NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NO BURKE. I WOULD COUNTY.
WIENER HI LIKE WHAT ELSE GUY
WIENER AYE WILK. BY SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR
CINDER JCKSON NOT AT HER DESK
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FIVE
SENATOR WILK. SIR WHAT WOULD
YOU LIKE TO PRESENT FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY FIVE. PASSED SOME
FILE FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX
CENTER PORTANTINO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO AN
ACT RELATING TO POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. CENTER PORTANTINO.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
ENTHUSIASTICALLY SUPPORT A. B.
TWO WHICH IMPROVES ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY PROMISE
PROGRAM BY CLARIFYING CERTAIN
CONDITIONS SO THAT ALL STUDENTS
HAVE THIS. OPPORTUNITY TO GET A
DEBT FREE EDUCATION THROUGH OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM ONE
EXAMPLE OF. THE PROVISIONS IN
AB TWO APPLY TO DISABLED
STUDENTS WHO NOW WILL HAVE MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO FINISH THEIR
DEGREE UNDER A. B. TWO ONE
COLLEGE DEGREES ARE ON
AFFORDABLE OUR ECONOMY SUFFERS
PASSING AB TWO IS JUST THE
RIGHT THING TO DO. FOR
OUTSTANDING STUDENTS BY
PROVIDING THEM THE OPPORTUNITY
FRANKLIN HAVE A DEBT FREE TWO
YEARS OF HIGHER EDUCATION AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
PORTANTINO MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
STONE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M VERY PROUD TO
STAND IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO HAVE
A NUMBER OF COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OF MY DISTRICT. AND IT'S GREAT
THAT WE CAN HAVE OUR STUDENTS%
TO BE ABLE TO FULFILL TWO YEARS
OF THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION.
WITHOUT ANY TUITION TO. EMBARK
ON A TRADE OR PROFESSION THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD BE OUT OF REACH
TO THEM IN AND MINIMIZING THE
LARGE DEBT THAT MANY OF OUR
STUDENTS HAVE TO ENCUMBER THAT
IS A ROAD BLOCK IF YOU WILL. TO
GETTING A HIGHER EDUCATION AND
TO ELEVATE IN THEMSELVES AND
THEIR FAMILIES I WANT TO SEND%
MY APPRECIATION TO ASSEMBLYMAN
SANTIAGO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND URGE MY COLLEAGUES
HERE IN THE SENATE TO MAKE THIS
A UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN VOTE I
SUPPORT EIGHTY TWO AND REQUEST
THAT YOU VOTE YES AS WELL.
THANK YOU CENTER STONE MEMBERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. YOU
LIKE TO CLOSER TO PORTANTINO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SIR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS. I
BILL FIVE LARGEST. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO AYE TING AYE DALY.
DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO. HI
TADO I JACKSON. JONES. I LEYVA
HI I'M ACQUIRE. MITCHELL
MITCHELL AYE MONNING. I'M MORE
LUCK I'M A REAL AYE NIELSEN AYE
PAN BY PORTANTINO. BY ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE I AM BURKE OUR CASKEY I
WIENER AYE WILK. HI. NO ADDING
ON PLEASE THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM ONE AT NINETY ONE SENATOR
STERN ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT WHICH SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER ONE AN
ACT RELATING TO GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING ORDERS CENTER STERN
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT AB THREE THIRTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN
THIS BILL WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO
HAVE. POLICIES AND STANDARDS
RELATING TO G. V. R. OWES OUR
GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
WRITING A JUMPSTART TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT AWARENESS OF THIS
TOOL BY ENCOURAGING LOCAL
DEPARTMENTS TO WORK WITH GUN
VIOLENCE PREVENTION EXPERTS AND
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS TO
DEVELOP THESE POLICIES AND
STANDARDS WE THINK WOULD MOVE
THE NEEDLE FORWARD
SIGNIFICANTLY THERE ALREADY ARE
SOME AUTHORITIES ON THE BOOKS
AND WE'VE BEEN WORKING TO
ENHANCE THOSE FURTHER BUT LAW
ENFORCEMENT NEEDS TOOLS TO GET
GUNS OUT OF THE HANDS OF PEOPLE
WHO WE ALL AGREE SHOULD NOT BE.
HOLDING THAT WEAPON SO THAT'S
WHY LAW ENFORCEMENT AND A
NUMBER OF OTHER ORGANIZATIONS
ARE ON BOARD WITH SUPPORT AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR RIVAL
THANK YOU CENTER STERN MEMBERS
IN THE DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES. HI BILL BY BURGESS I
BRADFORD I CAMBIADO. CHIANG I
DALY DODD BY DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROVE HERTZBERG. HI
HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO I
JACKSON. JONES. NO LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK. RAIL NO
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE NOVEMBER IOWA
CASKEY. I WINNER. HI WILK I
CENTER MOVES A CALL MOVING TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY THREE
SEVEN REQUIRE PASS ON FILE FILE
ITEM ONE NINETY FIVE SENATOR
WIENER. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SOME OF THE NINE SIXTY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK
STONE AND TACKLING A PAROLE.
SENATOR WIENER I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
AB NINE SIXTY FIVE. BY WILL
AUTHORIZE THE SECRETARY OF C.
C. R. TO ALLOW ANY CREDIT
EARNED UNDER PROPOSITION FIFTY
SEVEN. TO BE APPLIED TO
INCARCERATED PERSONS EARLIEST
POP POSSIBLE YOU'VE PAROLE
HEARING DATE. THIS WILL ALLOW
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY SIX AT THE TIME
OF THEIR CONTROLLING OFFENSE.
TO BENEFIT FROM THE
OPPORTUNITIES PROVIDED UNDER
PROP FIFTY SEVEN AND WOULD
INCREASE INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE AND REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING. PROP FIFTY SEVEN
CREATED OPPORTUNITIES FOR
INCARCERATED PEOPLE TO EARN
SENTENCE REDUCING CREDIT FOR
GOOD BEHAVIOR. AND COMPLETION
OF EDUCATIONAL AND
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS.
EARNING CREDITS HELPS
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS RETAIN
HOPE IN THE FACE OF LENGTHY
SENTENCES AND INCENTIVIZE THEM
TO FOCUS ON REHABILITATION.
RECOGNIZING THAT MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE VICTIMS OF EXTREME
SENTENCING AND THE YOUTH HAVE
LESS OF AN ABILITY TO
UNDERSTAND THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THEIR ACTION AND RESIST THEIR
IMPULSES. THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED OVER THE
PAST FEW YEARS THE GRANT
EARLIER PAROLE HEARING DATES TO
YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS.
UNFORTUNATELY EXISTING LAW
PREVENTS YOUTH OF THAT YOUTHFUL
OFFENDERS FROM WRITING CREDITS
OFF THEIR NEW PAROLE HEARING
DATE WHICH UNDERMINES THE
PURPOSE OF PROP FIFTY SEVEN.
OPEN AND CENTER FOR
REHABILITATION THAT PROPERTY
SEVEN CREATED. THOSE CREDITS
ARE JUST AS IMPORTANT TO YOUTH
OF YOUTHFUL OFFENDERS AS THEY
ARE TO THE REST OF THE PRISON
POPULATION. AND IT'S WRONG TO
EXCLUDE THEM FOR BENEFITING
FROM THE CREDITS SIMPLY BECAUSE
OF THEIR AGE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER MEMBERS. DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR HILLS. MADAM
PRESIDENT LADIES DONE THE
SENATE ONE OF THE IRONIES WITH
GOOD TIME CREDIT. THERE REALLY
ISN'T AND HASN'T BEEN EARNED.
IT'S BEEN AN AUTOMATIC SENTENCE
REDUCTION FOR DECADES. YOU'RE
SUPPOSED TO COMPLETE PROGRAMS
AND DOING SO YOU HAVE TO AND
THEN IF YOU ARE A REALLY
SERIOUS OFFENDER AS WOULD BE
THE PROP FIFTY SEVEN CROWD
MURDER FIRST MURDER SECOND
KIDNAPPED. THREE STRIKERS AMONG
OTHERS. YOU HAVE TO DEMONSTRATE
SOME COMPREHENSION AND ABILITY
TO APPLY THE LESSONS THAT YOU
LEARNED IN THE TREATMENT THAT
YOU SUPPOSEDLY. WENT TO AND
WE'RE DEDICATED TO. THAT IS ONE
OF THE IRONIES THAT THE- GOOD
TIME. HAS NEVER REALLY BEEN
REQUIRED TO BE EARNED. NOW WE
WERE TOLD THAT ONLY THE WORST
OF THE WORST WE'RE GONNA. HAVE
TO STAY IN PRISON. WELL PROP
FIFTY SEVEN CHANGED ALL OF THAT.
THE VERY SERIOUS CRIMES THAT I
SPOKE TO ARE ONES FOR WHICH
PROP FIFTY SEVEN THE PRICE. AND
THERE'S ANOTHER IRONY HERE.
SEVERAL YEARS AGO. THE
LEGISLATURE CHANGED. THE NUMBER
OF YEARS A LIFE IN MATE WITH
POSSIBILITY OF PAROLE COULD BE
DENIED SUITABILITY
CONSIDERATION. FORMALLY AT BEST
IT WAS BASED ON THE NUMBER OF
MURDERS THAT YOU COMMITTED. ONE
MURDER YOU CAN ONLY BE DONE I
TWO YEARS BEFORE YOU CAN BE
CONSIDERED AGAIN. THREE OR MORE
FIVE YEARS. WE CHANGED IT TO BE
FIVE YEARS. FOR ANYBODY. BUT
PUT A PROVISION IN THE BILL.
AND THAT WAS MY OWN DOING IS
CHAIR OF THE BOARD PRISON TERMS
I SOUGHT THIS BECAUSE I FELT
THAT THIS WOULD HELP THAT
STATUTE PREVAIL. LEGAL
CHALLENGES. WHICH IT DID BEFORE
THE US SUPREME COURT. THE
PROVISION SAID THAT AFTER THREE
YEARS. ON A FIVE YEAR DENIAL.
THE IN MAY. COULD APPLY IT TO
THE BOARD. FOR A HEARING SOONER
THAN THE FIVE YEARS. IF THEY
HAD DEMONSTRATED AN EXAMPLE RAY
PERFORMANCE IN THE
REHABILITATIVE AFTER. LATER THE
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. CHANGE
THAT TO FIFTEEN YEARS. MAXIMUM
THE NILE. OF SUITABILITY. IT
MADE ATTORNEYS GOT REALLY
CREATIVE WITH THAT THOUGH. AND
LET THAT MATURE IN PROP FIFTY
SEVEN WHERE BY ALMOST EVERY
YEAR NO MATTER HOW MANY YEAR
DENIAL YOU RECEIVE. THE INMATES
ARE COMING BACK. FOR HEARINGS
MUCH SOONER. SO ONE WHO WOULD
TO BE DESERVING OF A FIVE YEAR
DENIAL AND EIGHT YEAR DENIAL A
FIFTEEN YEAR TO DIAL. IS BACK
IN THREE YEARS. FOR
CONSIDERATION AGAIN. FOR THE
SEVERITY AND SERIOUSNESS OF THE
CRIMES THAT THEY COMMIT. THAT'S
NOT A LONG AND SUSTAINED
REHABILITATIVE PERIOD OF TIME.
LIFE IN MAKES OF ALWAYS BEEN
DEEMED THE SAFEST TO RETURN TO
SOCIETY. THAT'S NOT BECAUSE
THEY WERE SAFE INMATES
NECESSARILY AND IT'S BECAUSE
THEY HAVE SIMPLY SERVE MORE
TIME. AND FINALLY GOT IT. THAT
THEY NEEDED TO DO SOME
REHABILITATION THEY HAD TO STAY
OUT OF TROUBLE AND WHETHER
INCARCERATED NOT A TRUE ONE
FIFTEEN TO ONE TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH IS THE DEFINITION OF A
DEATH DISCIPLINARY BEHAVIOR.
AGAIN. THE SUN THE BATTLE ISSUE.
HAS THEY HAVE THEY RETAIN
THEMSELVES. IN TREATMENT IN
REHABILITATION SUFFICIENTLY TO
GET. AND NOT JUST AN AUTOMATIC
FREE TICKET OUT EVERY TIME
WE'VE CHANGED AGAIN IN THE MID
EIGHTIES GOOD TIME CREDIT WAS
50% FOR EVERYBODY. IN THE MID
EIGHTIES WAS CHANGED. YOUR
SERIOUS AND VIOLENT CONTROLLING
CASE SERIOUS AND VIOLENT. YOU
ONLY GOT 15% GOOD TIME CREDIT.
WASN'T MUCH JOURNEY EITHER. AND
THEN THAT WAS CHANGED BACK
EVERYBODY GETS 50% GOOD TIME.
ONE THING THAT THAT MOST ASSURE
FOR EARLY DOES IT DENIES THE
CRIME VICTIMS. AND THEIR
FAMILIES. WHO GRIEVE OVER THE
LOSS OF A LOVED ONE OR SUFFERED
AT THE HANDS OF A SERIOUS
REPEAT OFFENDER. IT DENIES THEM
THE ONLY THING SOCIETY CAN
PROVIDE THAT. NOT CLOSURE
THERE'S NO SUCH THING AS
CLOSURE. THERE IS ONLY JUSTICE.
AND JUSTICE MADE JUST DESSERTS
THE SEVERITY OF THE CRIME
COMMITTED AGAINST INDIVIDUALS.
AND AGAINST SOCIETY. I ARGUE
MODE MIL FURTHER IN THIS
DIRECTION. WE'VE BEEN HEADED.
IN DENYING. JUSTICE TO CRIME
VICTIMS. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN MEMBERS ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATOR
SKINNER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I JUST STAND. AS THE
TEAR PUBLIC SAFETY WHO AND THE
PUBLIC SAFETY BUDGET COMMITTEE
WHERE WE HAVE NOT ONLY
OVERSIGHT HEARINGS ON THESE
ISSUES OF THE REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE
FACILITIES WE ALSO VETS ALL OF
THE BUDGETARY ISSUES RELATED TO
IT. AND WHAT WE HEARD FROM OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM TEHAMA WAS THAT.
OUR PROGRAMS ARE REALLY
REHABILITATIVE AND THAT WE GIVE
PEOPLE CREDITS FOR REALLY
NERVOUS FOR DOING NOTHING IN
EFFECT. WHILE CERTAINLY DURING
THE DEPTHS OF THE RECESSION.
BECAUSE OF BUDGET CUTS MANY
MANY OF THE VERY IMPORTANT
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
G. E. D. PROGRAMS ODD DRUG
COUNSELING SUBSTANCE ABUSE
TREATMENT AND OTHERS WERE CUT
OR ELIMINATED FROM OUR SYSTEM
THOSE HAVE BEEN RESTORED AND
THEY ARE AVAILABLE IN WORKING
THROUGH OUT OUR STATE PRISONS
AND FOR THOSE OF US WHO HAVE
BOTH HAD OVERSIGHT HEARINGS AND
TOURED MANY OF THESE PRISON
FACILITIES WE SEE THAT THESE
PROGRAMS OR ROBUST. THEY'VE
BEEN EVALUATED AND THEY'RE
HAVING BENEFICIAL IMPACTS
SOMEONE TO CORRECT THE RECORD
ON THE NOTION THAT SOMEHOW
THESE CREDITS ARE BEING GIVEN
TO PEOPLE FOR WHOM THERE THE
THERE'S BEEN NO GOOD BEHAVIOR
SHOWN OR NO REAL PARTICIPATION
IN SUBSTANTIVE OR QUALITY
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS I WOULD
FINALLY NOTE THE CALIFORNIA
CONTINUES TO HAVE THE HIGHEST
PERCENT. AND THIS IS POINT
BASED ON OUR TOTAL PRISON
POPULATION AS COMPARED TO OTHER
STATES WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
PERCENT OF PRISONERS SENTENCED
EITHER AS ADULTS OR JUVENILES
WHO ARE SERVING LIFE SENTENCES
THAT IS HIGHER. THAN GEORGIA.
IN SYLVANIA FLORIDA AND
MICHIGAN FOR EXAMPLE THIS IS A
NEEDED BILL AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER SKINNER
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
SENATOR WIENER WHICH LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'D JUST TO CLARIFY A
FEW THINGS FIRST OF ALL THE
FOCUS HERE IS NOT A GOOD TIME
CREDITS AS WAS. DISCUSSED
EARLIER IT'S EDUCATIONAL
CREDITS IN CCAR'S BEEN VERY
CLEAR THAT THOUGHT WILL BE THE
FOCUS EDUCATIONAL CREDITS OF
THIS CREATES AN INCENTIVE FOR
THESE INMATES TO ENGAGE IN
EDUCATIONAL PROGRAMS
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS. GET
THEIR LIFE BACK TOGETHER SO
THAT THEY CAN RE INTEGRATE.
INTO SOCIETY I THINK WE ALSO
NEED TO NOT LOSE SIGHT. THAT
THIS IS NOT ABOUT AUTOMATIC
PAROLE THIS IS ABOUT
ELIGIBILITY FOR A HEARING.
ELIGIBILITY SIMPLY TO MAKE YOUR
CASE THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
REHABILITATED IT AND THAT YOU
SHOULD BE PAROLED ALLOWING THAT
TO HAPPEN A BIT EARLIER WHEN
SOMEONE COMMITTED THE CRIME. IT
IN THEIR USE THAT'S ALL THIS IS
ABOUT ALL I KNOW IT'S THE SAME
PROCESS SUPPLIES AND IN TERMS
OF VICTIMS BEING ABLE TO
PARTICIPATE AND SO FORTH. AND
THIS MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD IN THE ENDS AS THE CENTER
FOR BERKELEY EACH HAS MENTIONED
AS PROGRESSIVE AS WE LIKE TO
THINK WE ARE SOMETIMES IN
CALIFORNIA. OUR CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM HAS BEEN
ANYTHING BUT WE HAVE LED THE
WAY IN MASS INCARCERATION WE
HAVE LED THE WAY IN YOUTH
INCARCERATION WE HAVE LED THE
WAY IN OUR PRISON SYSTEM.
CROWDING OUT OTHER CRITICAL
BUDGET PRIORITIES LIKE YOU SEE
LIKE CSU AND IT'S TIME. TO
REFORM THE SYSTEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER WIENER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS BATES NOBEL BY
BURGESS NO BRADFORD I COME
AGAIN. CHIANG NO DALLY NO DOT.
HI DORADO I GALGIANI. NO GLAZER
I GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO. FOR TITLE.
NO JACKSON. JONES NO LEYVA. BY
MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL. HI MONNING
I'M MORE LUCK RAIL. NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I ROTH.
BY RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN AYE
STONE NO AMBERG OUR CASKEY HI
WINNER BY WILK. NO MEMBERS WE
HAVE A FULL HOUSE SO WE'RE
GOING TO CALL THE ROLL AGAIN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS.
CABALLERO GROWTH WITH SO I.
JACKSON BY LOCK. I TWENTY FIVE
KNOWS ELEVEN THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS I INADVERTENTLY SKIPPED
OVER FILE ITEM ONE NINETY TWO
SENATOR ARCHULETA. NOT AT HIS
DESK. ALL RIGHT MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY SEVEN
SENATOR GONZALEZ. PASS ON FILE
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT
SENATOR HILL MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY THE LEVIN
SIXTY SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AN ACT RELATING TO
UNDERGROUND INFRASTRUCTURE
SENATOR HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN LEGISLATION OF
MINE SB SIX SIXTY ONE CREATED
THE DIG SAFE ACT WHICH INCLUDED
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE DIG
SAFE PORT. IN ADDITION TO
ESTABLISHING THE DIG SAFE BOARD
THE ACT REQUIRES A PERSON
PLANNING TO CONDUCT AN
EXCAVATION TO CONTACT THE
APPROPRIATE REGIONAL
NOTIFICATION CENTER PRIOR TO
COMMENCING THE EXCAVATION. IT
THEN REQUIRES OWNERS OF
SUBSURFACE INSTALLATIONS AT ACT
EXCAVATION SITES TO MARK THEIR
UNDERGROUND INFRASTRUCTURE
WITHIN TWO WORKING DAYS OF
RECEIVING A NOTIFICATION. EVERY
OPERATOR OF SUBSURFACE
INSTALLATIONS IS REQUIRED TO
PARTICIPATE WITH THE REGIONAL
NOTIFICATION CENTER HOWEVER A
REPORT RELEASED EARLIER THIS
YEAR BY THE CPUC FOUND THAT
PACIFIC GAS AND ELECTRIC. WOULD
SOMETIMES RECORD THAT IT HAD
REACHED AN AGREEMENT WITH AN
EXCAVATOR TO DELAY LOCATING AND
MARKING PIPELINES WHEN IN
REALITY IN EMPLOYEE HAD LEFT
ONLY A VOICE MESSAGE OR MADE NO
CONTACT AT ALL. THAT RAISE THE
POSSIBILITY THAT CONSTRUCTION
COULD BEGIN BEFORE A CREW KNEW
WHERE THE PIPES WERE LOCATED.
THE REPORT IDENTIFIED OVER WHAT
OTHER WIDESPREAD INSTANCES IN
WHICH P. JEANNIE PIPELINE
LOCATION INFORMATION WAS
FALSIFIED. THE FORMER P. UC
COMMISSIONER CALLED THE
REPORT'S FINDINGS DISCUSSED IN
AND DEEPLY APPALLING. AB ELEVEN
SIXTY SIX WOULD IMPROVE THE
NOTIFICATION PROCESS REGARDING
THE LOCATION OF SUBSURFACE
PIPELINES BY REQUIRING
UTILITIES TO PROVIDE AN
ELECTRONIC POSITIVE RESPONSE.
ON THE PIPE ONE LOCATION STATUS
AT A SPECIFIC SITE BEFORE
EXCAVATION CAN BEGIN CURRENTLY
ELECTRONIC POSITIVE RESPONSES
IS VOLUNTARY IN CALIFORNIA SB
ELEVEN SIXTY SIX WOULD REQUIRE
THIS RESPONSE WHICH MANY OTHER
STATES ALREADY DO THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU CENTER
HELLO MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
FAITH. SEE AND HEAR NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES HI BILL HI BRIDGES HI
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE TING
AYE DALY AYE DODD. ARE THERE
ALSO I GALGIANI I GLAZER.
GLAZER GONZALEZ HI GROW I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
FOR TITLE I JACKSON. I JONES HI
LEYVA HI I'M ACQUIRE BY
MITCHELL. BY MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK BY AMARILLO BY NELSON. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE I AM BURKE. I WOULD
COUNTY I WINNER BY WILK BY.
RIGHT THINKING MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY NINE SENATOR JACKSON'S.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL ON FILE
ITEM WHEN NINETY EIGHT CENTER
JACKSON ARE YOU PREPARED TAKE
A- PASS ON FILE VERY GOOD. YES
THAT'S FINE. FILE ITEM TWO ZERO
SEVEN SENATOR UMBERG. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY SOME
MEMBER MCCARTY ENACT REALLY AND
AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS SENATOR
UMBERG THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I RISE
PRESENT AB TEN EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY WHICH
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH TO
CONSIDER AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMS
AS RECIPIENTS OF PROP SIXTY
FOUR REVENUES. WHEN VOTERS
PASSED PROP SIXTY FOUR THEY
WERE PROMISED THE REVENUES
GENERATED WITH SUPPORT AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS AND THESE AFTER
SCHOOL PROGRAMS PREVENT REDUCE
SUBS ABUSE HELP IMPROVE SCHOOL
RETENTION ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE.
VERSION AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG MEMBERS IN
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
EIGHT BY BILL I PURCHASED AYE
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
BY DALY AYE DODD. I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW BY HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO I TADO I
JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. IT'LL BY MORNING BY
MORE LUCK I'M A REAL. NIELSEN
PAN. I PORTANTINO AYE ROTH.
RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN. AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG OUR COUNTY I
WINNER BY WILK HI CENTER MOVES
A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TO ELEVEN SENATOR
SKINNER. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWELVE FIFTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AN ACT
RELATING TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT
CENTER SKINNER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AB TWELVE FIFTY FIVE
BUILDS UPON THE GOVERNOR'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER WHICH HAS NOW
ESTABLISHED AN ONLINE
SEARCHABLE INVENTORY OF SURPLUS
STATE PROPERTY THAT COULD BE
USED FOR EXAMPLE POTENTIALLY
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS ENABLE A SIR
A SEARCHABLE INVENTORY OF
SURPLUS CITY AND COUNTY
PROPERTY. THE DECISIONS ON WHAT
TO DO WITH THAT PROPERTY IS
STILL LEFT TO LOCAL CONTROL THE
BILL DOES NOT INTERFERE AT ALL
WITH THAT LOCAL CONTROL THE
GOAL IS TO HELP IDENTIFY NEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO HELP MEET OUR
HOUSING NEEDS. THE CITIES AND
COUNTIES WOULD REPORT THE
INFORMATION TO OUR DEPARTMENT
OF HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT WHICH WOULD ENABLE
ITS INCLUSION IN THE EXISTING
INVENTORY OF ALL STATE OWNED
PARCELS THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER SKINNER MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. I ATKINS
BATES. BELL I BRIDGES ARE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
CHIANG AYE DALY. AYE DODD I
DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG.
HI HILL AYE HUESO TITLE I
JACKSON BY JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL AYE MONNING
HI MORE LOCK I'M A REAL. I
NIELSEN I PAN I PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. RUBIO I SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK. SENATOR
MOVES THE CALL MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TO TWELVE SENATOR HILL
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX FORTY SEVEN
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER KALRA AN ACT
RELATING TO OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
CENTER HILL THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT A. B. SIX FORTY SEVEN
WOULD REQUIRE COSMETIC AND
DISINFECTED MANUFACTURERS WHO
ALREADY. DEVELOP SAFETY DATA
SHEETS TO POST THIS INFORMATION
ONLINE AND TRANSLATED INTO FOUR
COMMON LANGUAGES SPANISH
VIETNAMESE CHINESE AND KOREAN
SPOKEN BY SALON PROFESSIONALS
SALON PROFESSIONALS MANY OF
WHOM ARE IMMIGRANTS WOMEN OF
COLOR AND HAVE LIMITED ENGLISH
SKILLS ARE REGULARLY EXPOSED TO
BEAUTY CARE PRODUCTS CONTAINING
A MULTITUDE. OF CHEMICALS KNOWN
OR SUSPECTED TO POSE HEALTH
RISKS AND CAUSE HARM BY
REQUIRING SAFETY DATA SHEETS BE
ACCESSIBLE ONLINE AND
TRANSLATED INTO COMMON
LANGUAGES WILL RAISE AWARENESS
OF THE HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCES
ALONG PROFESSIONALS WORK WITH
EVERY DAY. AND ALLOW THEM TO
IMPROVE THEIR HEALTH AND WE CAN
GET. AB NO OPPOSITION HAS
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND SENATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE COLLECTION THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES. BILL
I PURCHASED AYE BRADFORD. AYE
CABALLERO. AYE TING AYE DALY
AYE DODD ADDRESS SO. I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO I TADO I JACKSON. I JONES.
BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL
BY MORNING. I'M MORE LUCK I AM
A REAL. AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH. RUBIO
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE BY
AMBERG OUR HEALTHY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK HI SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TO THIRTEEN SENATOR
NIELSEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FIFTY
SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY AND ACKLAND
WILDLIFE CENTER NIELSEN THEN
PRESENTLADIES AND GENTLEMEN
THE SENATE THIS BILL WILL
EXPAND SO ON OF THE LONG
ESTABLISHED PRACTICE AND WAS
FORMALIZED IN LEGISLATION BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY. I
BELIEVE YEAR AGO. THE PRACTICE
IS TO FLOOD THE RICE FIELDS. IN
THE FALL AFTER THE HARVEST.
ALLOWING. MENDIS AMOUNTS OF
EXPANDED HABITAT FOR A
MIGRATING. BIRDS SPECIES. IT
ALSO HAS ANOTHER IMPACT. RICE
STRAW NOT THE COLONEL'S BUT THE
STRAW. DOES NOT DECOMPOSE
READILY IN THE SOIL BECAUSE OF
THE HIGH SILICA. THINK BLACKS
HIGH SILICA CONTENT. IF THE
WATER IS UP ON AN OVER THAT END
IN MORE IMPORTANTLY IF THE RICE
STRAW I IN CONTACT WITH THE
SOIL THAT DECOMPOSES MUCH MORE
RAPIDLY. ANOTHER BIT OF AN
IRONY WHEN THE MIGRATING BIRDS
COME IN. AND THEY'RE FEEDING
AND LIVING. ON THOSE RICE
FIELDS. THEY ARE ACTUALLY
PADDING DOWN. THE RICE STRAW SO
THAT IT COMES IN CONTACT WITH
THE SOIL. THEREBY ENHANCING THE
DECOMPOSITION. THAT HAS BEEN
EXTRAORDINARILY HELPFUL AS A
TOOL FOR DECADES TO. GIVE US A
ALTERNATIVE TO OPEN FEEL
BURNING OF THE RICE. THE
GREATEST BONE IS THE AMOUNT OF
HABITAT THAT DOES PROVIDE FOR
MY GRADING SPECIES. DRIVE UP
AND DOWN THE VALLEY IN THE
WINTER TIME IT'S A BEAUTIFUL
SIGHT. TO SEE ALL OF THOSE
BIRDS. OUT IN THOSE RICE FIELDS.
VERY HAPPY AND CONTENT. BUT
WHILE THEY ARE HAPPY AND
CONTENT IT'S ALSO HELPING US.
DISPOSE OF SOMETHING THAT USED
TO BE A HUGE PROBLEM THIS
PROVIDES SOME INCENTIVES.
POLICE SHE FOR EXAMPLE WHO WERE
BOY IF THEY ARE LEASING THAT
LAND IT'S QUICKER AND EASIER
FOR THEM. TO BE ABLE TO. SECURE
THE RELEASE AND THEN GET AN
APPROVAL. TO FLOOD THOSE FIELDS.
THAT HELP. AND IT ENCOURAGES
MORE LAND AND THAT'S THE MOST
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF THIS
ENCOURAGING MORE OPEN FEEL
FLOODING. TO PROVIDE HABITAT
FERRARI OR THAT OUR SPECIES OF
BIRDS MIGRATING BIRDS I WOULD
URGE AN AYE VOTE. THE USER
NIELSEN MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
THAT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL I BURGESS EFFORT. I
CABALLERO AYE TING AYE DALY AYE
DODD AYE DORADO AYE GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE
HUESO. BY TITLE I JACKSON. I
JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL. BY MONEY I'M MORE
LUCK I'M REAL BY NELSON.
NIELSEN. HI PAN AYE PORTANTINO
I ROTH. RUBIO. I SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR
CASKEY I WINNER. BY WILK BY
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
FOURTEEN SENATOR BELL MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE ACT
REALLY MCCOURT'S CENTERVILLE
PRESIDENT MEMBERS SO THIS
CREATES A PILOT PROJECT TO
TEST. THE USE THE REMARK REMOTE
COURT REPORTING IN SANTA CLARA
COUNTY. WE WORLD STUDY THIS AND
IT WILL ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE
TO DETERMINE THE RELIABILITY
AND FEASIBILITY DEPLOYING TO
TECHNOLOGY. WHILE DOING SO IN A
CONTROLLED MANNER THAN SHARES
THE ACCURACY AND RELIABILITY
COURT RECORDS CAN BE MAINTAINED
IN A PROPER MANNER. HAS AND I
UNANIMOUS VOTE I REGION I WROTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BELL MEMBERS A
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING THAT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS BATES. HI
BILL. I PORGES. AYE BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO BY CHIANG. I DALY
AYE DODD I DORADO. HI GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER I GONZALEZ I GROW. I
HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO. BY
TADO BY JACKSON BY JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
HI MONNING BY MORE LOCK ON RAIL
AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH RUBIO I
SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG OUR COUNTY OUR WINNER BY
WILK. SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO FIFTEEN
SENATOR WIENER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TEN
SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON AND ACTUALLY IN THE
FOSTER CARE. CENTER WIENER I
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT SOME BILL TEN
SIXTY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON I WAS WILL ENSURE THE
FOSTER YOU'D HAVE A CONSISTENT
AND STRONG HOME FOUNDATION OR
NOT UNNECESSARILY MOVED. FROM
ONE PLACE TO ANOTHER AB TEN
SIXTY ONE REQUIRES A SOCIAL
WORKER PLACEMENT AGENCY TO
DEVELOP AND IMPLEMENT A PLAN TO
PRESERVE THE EXISTING PLACEMENT
BEFORE MAKING A CHANGE THE PLAN
MUST INCLUDE CONFLICT
RESOLUTION AND FACILITATED.
EIGHT SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS BY BRADFORD I KELLY
HERO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD
I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. I
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HIGHER TITLE BY JACKSON I JONES.
BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK I'M REAL. I NIELSEN I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH. RUBIO
HI SKINNER BY STERN AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE OUR COUNTY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. SENATOR MOVES
A CALL MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE ON THE FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTEEN SENATOR HILL. CRITICS
PERCENT TO SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
SIR MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTY
FORTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AND NATURAL INTO
EMPLOYMENT SENATOR HILL THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT AB SEVENTEEN FORTY
EIGHT THIS BILL CONFORMS THE
CALIFORNIA FAMILY RIGHTS ACT TO
THE UNIQUE WORK SCHEDULE AND
CIRCUMSTANCES OF FLIGHT CREW
MEMBERS AS THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS DONE IN THE
FEDERAL FAMILY AND MEDICAL
LEAVE ACT THIS BILL HAS RECEIVE
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NO OPPOSITION
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL
COLLEAGUES. THANK YOU CENTER
HELL MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS. BATES HI BILL. BY
BURGESS. FIVE BRADFORD I
CARRIER I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE
DODD I DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH
AYE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO AYE OR TACO AYE JACKSON
AYE JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING I'M
MORE LOCK. I'M A REAL I NIELSEN.
I PAN. PORTANTINO I ROTH. RUBIO
SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE. I AM
BURKE OUR COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI. THEN REMOVE THE CALL
MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM TO
EIGHTEEN SENATOR GLAZER. PASS
ON FILE FILE ITEM TO NINETEEN
SENATOR ALAN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN TWENTY FOUR BUT IT'S
IN THE COMMITTEE ON NATURAL
RESOURCES AND EXPLAIN TO
ENVIRONMENT QUALITY SENATOR
ALAN MEMBERS SO THIS IS AN
ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE BILL NOT TO
RESOURCE COMMITTEE BUILDING
SEVERAL NON CONTROVERSIAL
AMENDMENTS TO SEE QUINN RELATED
STATUTES IN ADDITION TO TAKING
CLEAN UP THE BILL REACTIVE
PRAYER EXEMPTION. FOR THE
CLOSURE OF RAILROAD GRADE
CROSSINGS ORDERED BY THE P. YOU
SEE ALLOWING THEM TO QUICKLY AT
CLOSE ON SAFE CROSSINGS THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION HAS
RECEIVED NO NO VOTES. RESPECT
FASHIONABLE THANK YOU SENATOR
ALLEN MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES HI BILL I BURGESS
HI BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CHIANG BY DALY AYE DODD AYE
DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW I HERTZBERG.
BY HILL AYE HUESO I TITLE AYE
JACKSON AYE JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL HI MONNING
I'M MORE LUCK I AM A REAL BY
NELSON. I PAN PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH. RUBIO HI SKINNER I STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR COUNTY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK. HI CENTER
MOVES A CALL MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM TO TWENTY. OKAY SENATOR
JONES ARE YOU ON YOUR WAY TO
YOUR DESK. THERE WE GO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL A SIXTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CUNNINGHAM AN ACT
RELATING TO STATE PROPERTY.
SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I AM RISING TO.
PRESENT AB EIGHT SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CUTTING HIM.
THIS BILL REQUIRES THE
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION ON ANY
LAND REPORT AS ACCESS WITHIN A
HUNDRED FIFTY DAYS IF ANY OTHER
STATE AGENCY IS INTERESTED IN
THE LAND. CURRENT LAW DOES NOT.
OUTLINE ANY TIME FRAME WHICH
HAS RESULTED IN UNNECESSARY
DELAYS. HAVE NO AGENCIES
SIGNALS INTERESTS IN THE
ALLOTTED TIME. TGS CAN BEGIN
SELLING THE PROCESS GIVEN THE
PROCESS STREAMLINED AND
ACCOUNTABLE I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER JONES
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES HI BILL BY BURGESS
I BRADFORD I CABALLERO AYE TING
AYE DALY AYE DODD. I DORADO I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. BY HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO. BUYER TADO I
JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY AYE
MORE LUCK I AM A REAL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN. PORTANTINO HI.
ROTH RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG IOWA
CASKEY I WINNER. BY WILK HI.
CENTER MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
TWENTY TWO SENATOR UMBERG PASS
ON FILE FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY
SENATOR BRADFORD. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE
THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WEBER
RELATIVE TO AFRICAN DESCENDANTS
OF SLAVES IN THE UNITED STATES.
SENATOR BRADFORD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT ACR ONE THIRTY
ON BEHALF OF DOCTOR WHEREVER
LOOKS TO ADDRESS. THE HISTORY
OF CERTAIN SLAVERY HERE IN THIS
COUNTRY THIS PAST AUGUST MARK
FOUR HUNDRED YEARS SINCE THE
FIRST AFTER AN AFGHAN WAS
RIPPED FROM THEIR FAMILY THEIR
HOMELAND AND BROUGHT TO UNITED
STATES IN BONDAGE AS SLAVES.
QUEEN SIXTEEN NINETEEN IN
EIGHTEEN SIXTY FIVE FOUR
MILLION AFRICANS AND THEIR
DESCENDANTS WERE DE HUMANIZED
DEPRIVED OF THEIR LIFE LIBERTY
AND CULTURAL HERITAGE THE FACT
REMAINS A BLOCK TODAY ARE STILL
UNDERPAID. UNDEREMPLOYED
UNDEREDUCATED OVER POLICED AN
OPEL OVER REPRESENTED IN
PRISONS AND JAILS THIS
RESOLUTION SIMPLY RECOGNIZES
THE HISTORY OF INJUSTICE THE
BLOCKS OF INDOOR IN UNITED
STATES. AND THE NEED FOR
REPARATIONS REPARATIONS OUR
BODY MELDING THE WRONGS OF
SLAVERY IN THE WRONG OF
CALIFORNIA ENGAGED BY ENABLING
SLAVERY TO CONTINUE IN THIS
STATE. CALIFORNIA'S LOOK TO AS
A LEADER IN HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUES
AND TAKING A PROGRESSIVE STANCE
AGAINST INJUSTICE BUT IT WAS
CALIFORNIA THAT REFUSE TO
PROVIDE ASYLUMS FOR FUGITIVE
SLAVES AND PASS LAWS THAT
PREVENT. FREAKS FREED SLAVES
FROM LIVING HERE IN MY DISTRICT
THERE IS A AREA. NOW KNOWN AS
THE GUARDIAN A WETLANDS BUT IT
WAS AFFECTIONATELY REFERRED TO
AS THE **** SLOW. AND THE
EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS WERE
AFTERNOON AFTERNOON FREE OUR
PRINTS WRE FORCED TO LIVE ON
LAND. THAT WAS UNABLE TO FARM
OR BUILD HOUSING. REPARATIONS
OUR ROOM READY TO THE ECONOMIC
LEGAL POLITICAL AND EDUCATION
AND JUST AS A STILL EXPERIENCE
BY BLOCKS DESCENDANTS OF SLAVES
TO THIS DAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU SAID A
RED FOR MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE SENATOR MITCHELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT I STAND PROBABLY IS A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS TO.
OPENLY DECLARE MY SUPPORT FOR A
C. R. AT ONE THIRTY. MEMBERS I
NEED NOT TELL YOU OF THE
HORRORS AND IN HUMANITY THE OLD
AFRICANS AND COUNTLESS OTHERS
IN MANY OF THEIR DESCENDANTS
HAVE SINCE SPACE IN THIS
COUNTRY. WE ALL KNOW THE
INDISPUTABLE FACTS OF SLAVERY.
OF BEING THREE FIFTHS OF A
HUMAN OF JIM CROW OF
SEGREGATION OF MASS
INCARCERATION NEGLECT NEGLECTED
COMMUNITIES OF A WAY TO GAPS
EDUCATION GAPS AND HEALTH
DISPARITIES. BUT THEY'VE
CLEARLY NO NEED FOR ME TO GIVE
YOU A BLACK HISTORY LESSON
TODAY SO INSTEAD I WANNA REMIND
US ALL OF OUR RESPONSIBILITY
THE FIGHT FOR JUSTICE IN EQUITY
FOR THE PEOPLE OF OUR GREAT
STATE. ALL REMIND US ALL THAT
AFTER FOUR HUNDRED YEARS OF
AFTER AMERICAN HISTORY
DISCRIMINATION AND JUSTICE IN
INEQUALITY REMAINS FOR BLACK
CALIFORNIANS IN ALL SECTORS OF
LIFE IN POLICY. I WAS ASKED BY
MANY PEOPLE IF I DIDN'T HAVE.
BIGGER BROADER RESPONSIBILITIES
IN TO CREATE LEGISLATION ON
SOMETHING AS SEEMINGLY TRIVIAL
AS HAIR. THAT'S JUST AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW THE VERY POLITE THAT
PLAGUE BLACK CALIFORNIANS DAILY
LIVES ARE SO UNIQUELY AN
ABSURDLY DISCRIMINATORY THAT
THOSE WHO DON'T BASED THESE
INJUSTICES. SOMETIMES CAN'T
FATHOM THE DIRE NEED TO CORRECT
THEM. SO AS I'M OFTEN REMINDED
OF THE GREAT WORDS OF DR KING
QUOTE. INJUSTICE ANYWHERE IS A
THREAT TO JUSTICE EVERYWHERE.
MEMBERS IT'S ALL OF OUR
RESPONSIBILITIES TO CORRECT THE
FOUR HUNDRED YEARS OF IN YOU
PUT IN HUMANITY AND
DISCRIMINATION AGAINST AFRICAN
DESCENDANTS IN THIS STATE. EVEN
IF IT SEEMS AS RIDICULOUS THE
SOME THAT'S HOW I CHOOSE TO
WEAR MY HAIR. THOSE OF YOU WHO
KNOW I'M A MOTHER OF HEARD ME
TALK ABOUT RYAN AND SOME OF YOU
MAY KNOW THAT HE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEND THIS
ENTIRE SUMMER IN GHANA. WORKING
FOR A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
TEACHING YOUNG CHILDREN. TO
READ IN A VERY REMOTE VILLAGE.
AND ON Y BEHALF. HE WENT TO
THE DUNGEONS I ASK HIM I
COULDN'T GO SO I ASKED HIM TO
GO TO. HERE WITH ME DIRECTLY
WHAT THE EXPERIENCE WAS TO GO
TO THE DUNGEONS. THE GOAL AND
LOOK OUT THE DOOR OF NO RETURN.
AND TO IMAGINE IF HE COULD AS
AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD. TO STEP
OUTSIDE OF THE DOOR LOOKING OUT
AT A BASS OCEAN AND HAVE
VIRTUALLY NO IDEA. WHAT WAS TO
BECOME OF YOU YOUR FAMILY YOUR
CHILDREN YOUR LIFE THEY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO CONCEPT. OF WHAT
THAT MIDDLE PASSAGE EXPERIENCE
WOULD BE LIKE. ANSEL WAS
AMAZING TO ME THROUGH THE EYES
AND THE STORY OF AN EIGHTEEN
YEAR ALL WHAT HE FELT. IN
STANDING AS A YOUNG AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAN BORN AND RAISED IN
CALIFORNIA WHAT IT FELT LIKE TO
STAND IN THE DUNGEON AND
IMAGINE WHAT HIS FOR MOTHERS IN
FOR FATHERS MUST OF FELT LIKE.
YOUNG MEN AS YOUNG AS HE IS
THAT A TEAM SO TODAY I WEAR MY
BRACELET THAT HE BROUGHT ME
BACK MADE BY THE CHILDREN IN
THE VILLAGE YOU WORKED IN AND
KOASATI. AS A REMINDER TO
MYSELF. AS IF I NEED ONE. ALL I
NEED TO DO IS LOOK IN THE
MIRROR EVERY DAY. OF Y. SIXTY
NINETEEN IN THAT HISTORY IS SO
IMPORTANT AND SHOULD BE
IMPORTANT TO US ALL I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF A C. R. ONE
THIRTY AND HOPE THAT YOU WILL
OF. AS WELL. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL. FOR THE DISCUSSION
DEBATE CENTER DRAWS SO. THANK
YOU AND THE ARE ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
LATINO CAUCUS I JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT. WE ALSO LOOK AT
ANOTHER PART OF THE HISTORY OF
AFRICAN AMERICANS IN THIS
NATION AND THAT IS THE PART
THAT HAS TO DO WITH THE COURAGE
AND THE RESISTANCE. THAT THEY
HAVE LED WHICH HAVE OPEN THE
WAY FOR OTHERS OF US. TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE THE RIGHTS THAT WE
DESERVE AND THAT WE HAVE IN
THIS IN THIS COUNTRY AND
PARTICULARLY. IMMIGRANTS THE
ONLY GROUP OF IMMIGRANTS TO
THIS NATION THAT WERE FORCED TO
COME HERE. WITH SLAVERY WAS THE
AFRICANS. AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS. EVERYONE ELSE CAME
HERE. BECAUSE WE WANTED A
BETTER LIFE WE THOUGHT WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A BETTER LIFE.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING THAT HAS
TO BE RECOGNIZE THE FORCE. THAT
THAT. BLACK MEN AND WOMEN AND
CHILDREN WERE FORCED TO COME TO
THIS COUNTRY. THAT IS A VERY
DISTINCT HISTORY IN THIS
COUNTRY BUT MORE THAN ANYTHING
I WANT TO STAND. AND SHOW LOVE
RESPECT AND HONOR FOR THE MANY
MANY. MILLIONS OF AFRICAN
AMERICANS. WHO GAVE THEIR
LIVES. WERE NOT ONLY A BETTER
LIFE FOR THEMSELVES BUT FOR THE
REST OF US THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DRAWS SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. YOU KNOW A RESOLUTION
LIKE THIS. CAN MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
VERY UNCOMFORTABLE. IT'S ONE
THING TO LOOK BACK IN HISTORY.
AND SEE THINGS THAT WERE DONE
TERRIBLY RONG AND SIMPLY
ACKNOWLEDGE IT AND THEN TURN
THE PAGE. BUT IT'S ANOTHER
THING TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE WRONG
AND SAY WE HAVE TO MAKE IT
RIGHT. AND YET. HOW DID HOW
DOES ONE DO THAT HOW DOES ONE
DO THAT. WHEN THE ERRORS WERE
DONE SO LONG AGO AND- IN SUCH A
CONTINUOUS WAY. AND SO YES IT'S
AN UNCOMFORTABLE CIRCUMSTANCE A
RESOLUTION LIKE THIS. BUT AS WE
HAVE SPOKEN ON THE FLOOR ABOUT
HISTORY IN OTHER CIRCUMSTANCES.
WHERE PEOPLE THAT. WE EVEN HOLD
A HIGH ESTEEM LEADERS OF OUR
NATION LEADERS OF OUR STATES.
IT'S A HEALTHY THING TO LOOK
BACK I THINK. BUT NOT JUST TO
ACKNOWLEDGE A WRONG BUT TO SAY
WHAT CAN WE DO TO MAKE IT
RIGHT. AND SO AS UNCOMFORTABLE
AS IT IS TO. EVEN LOOK AT THE
CIRCUMSTANCE LOOK AT THIS
HISTORY I THINK IT'S THE RIGHT
THING TO DO. AND I. URGE THE
PASSAGE OF THE RESOLUTION TODAY.
THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE CENTER SKINNER. Q. MADAM
PRESIDENT DIAMOND MEMBERS SOME
PRE SHOULD HAVE OF THE COMMENTS
THAT HAVE BEEN MADE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS RESOLUTION WHICH I ALSO
STAND STRONG SUPPORTER OF.
WE'VE RECOGNIZED WHAT THE-
INTERMENT OF OUR JAPANESE
AMERICANS. DID IN TERMS OF THE
ECONOMIC IMPACT ON THE AND
THEIR FAMILIES AND WHILE THE
REPARATIONS THAT WERE GIVEN TO
JAPANESE AMERICANS. DID NOT
REALLY MEET THE REAL FULL
ECONOMIC IMPACT IT LEAST
ACKNOWLEDGED THE HARM IN AN
ECONOMIC WAY THAT OUR POLICY.
DID TO THAT TO A FULL
GENERATION AND MULTIPLE
GENERATIONS OF JAPANESE
AMERICANS SO WE'VE APOLOGIZED
TO JAPANESE AMERICANS WE HAVE
GIVEN ORDER THROUGH A MULTIPLE
OTHER RECOGNITIONS HAND WE HAVE
GIVEN REPARATIONS. BUT FOR
DESCENDANTS OF SLAVES IN THIS
COUNTRY WE HAVE NOT DONE THAT
AND REGARDLESS OF WHETHER WE
HAVE A BLACK HISTORY MONTH OR
ANY OTHER WAYS THAT WE SOMEHOW
TONE FOR THE SIN OF SLAVERY ON
THE FOUNDING OF THIS COUNTRY
AND THE ECONOMIC WEALTH OF THIS
COUNTRY THE ONLY REAL WAY. TO
APPROPRIATELY. CORRECT THAT'S
AN OF SLAVERY IS TO PROVIDE
REPARATIONS TO THIS DESCENDANTS
OF BLACK SLAVES NOW WHILE THIS
RESOLUTION DOES NOT HAVE. THE
COSTS RELATED TO THOSE
REPARATIONS IT IT LEAST ADDS.
TO A COMMITMENT TO HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION. IT TO GETTING THERE
WHICH IS IN MY OPINION
ESSENTIAL AND WITHTHAT I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER SENATOR MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
THIS RESOLUTION JUST A LITTLE
HISTORY LESSON ON THIS FLOOR IF
YOU LOOK OVER AT THE BUS. THAT
LEROY IS STANDING IN FRONT OF
RIGHT THERE OF. FORMER STATE
SENATOR. DAVID BRODERICK HE WAS
KILLED IN A DUEL. WITH A
SUPREME COURT JUSTICE NAMED
DAVID TERRY. BRODERICK STOOD
FOR CALIFORNIA NOT BEING A
SLAVE STATE. N. SUPREME COURT
JUSTICE DAVID TERRY. WANT TO
CALIFORNIA TO BE A SLAVE STATE
THE WAY THEY SETTLED THAT
DISPUTE WAS A DUAL AT LAKE
MERCED. WHERE. SENATOR
BRODERICK LOST HIS LIFE. FAST
FORWARD TO OUR EXPERIENCE. WHAT
COMES TO MIND IS THE PROCESS
THAT WAS UNDERTAKEN IN SOUTH
AFRICA. AT THE END OF APARTHEID
WHEN NELSON MANDELA LED A TRUTH
AND RECONCILIATION PROCESS TO
BRING TOGETHER VICTIMS OF
APARTHEID WITH THE OPPRESSORS
TO ADDRESS FACE TO FACE HOW
THEY WERE GOING TO BUILD A NEW
SOUTH AFRICA. I'D SUBMIT THAT
PROCESS WAS VERY SUCCESSFUL
THAT PROCESS IS NEVER TAKEN
PLACE IN THE UNITED STATES AND
WE BEGAN BUYING NICK KNOWLEDGE
MINT OF THE NEED FOR
RECOGNITION AND REPARATIONS
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL PROMOTE IN
INFORM DIALOGUE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR SCHOOLS. TO
BUILD A FUTURE THAT CANNOT HIDE
THE PAST HIGHER CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MINING THIRD
AWAY SO. I JUST WANT TO ADD ON
JUST TO SIMPLY SAY THAT THIS
THIS COUNTRY IS STILL A
STRUGGLING WITH THIS ISSUE.
WE'RE STILL STRUGGLING WITH
WITH THE PAST IT'S STILL VERY
MUCH ALIVE WE SEE SO MANY
ECONOMIC. INJUSTICES AND
IMBALANCES AND INEQUALITIES IN
OUR COUNTRY THAT FOR SO MANY TO
HAVE TO STILL LIVE IN POVERTY.
WHEN IT WHEN SOME GAINS WERE
STARTED TO BE MADE IN THE
SIXTIES AND SEVENTIES AND
EIGHTIES UNFORTUNATELY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE PASSED BILLS LIKE
PROP ONE EIGHTY SEVEN AND PROP
TOOL FOR. THAT HAVE. OF GREATLY
DIMINISHED OUR ABILITY TO
EDUCATE. PEOPLE IN THE IN THE
DISEASE DISADVANTAGED A COLUMN.
WE STILL HAVEN'T NATIVE
AMERICANS THAT ARE HAVE THE
HIGHEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATES IN
THE LOWEST COLLEGE GRADUATION
RATES HIGHEST. OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL DROPOUT RATES NATIVE A
AND YOU KNOW THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN COMMUNITY ALSO. LIZ IN
IN SUCH DIRE STRAITS IN THIS
COUNTRY YET. WE HAVE LAWS THAT
HAVE. GOTTEN IN IN THE WAY OF
US HELP HELPING TO RESTORE SOME
LEVEL OF JUSTICE TO THESE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY. SO I
SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION BUT I
THINK WE NEED TO REVISIT. THE
WAY CALIFORNIA APPLIES
EQUITABLE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
PEOPLE THE STATE WE NEED TO
OVERTURN PROP TWO OH FOUR. WE
NEED TO FIND WAYS TO IMPROVE
THE EDUCATION OF OUR SCHOOLS AS
YOU KNOW MANY OF OUR SCHOOLS.
FUNDING IS RELATED TO THIS IS
TIED TO. THEIR THEIR LOCAL TAX
BASE AND OFTEN TIMES THAT'S A
VERY. UNFAIR WAY OF ALLOCATING
THAT. SO TWO OH NINE I'M SORRY
PROP TWO OH NINE THANK YOU. THE
SENATOR MISDIRECTED ME PROP TWO
OH NINE IS THE PROPOSITION I
WAS MENTIONING. BUT THAT IS
STILL VERY MUCH THE LONG
CALIFORNIA SOME WE NEED TO
CHANGE AND CALLIN FOR UNITY TO
TAKE A LEAD ON THIS AND I
APPLAUD THIS MEASURE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR HUESO CENTER PAN.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
CENTERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
US POURTANT RESOLUTION AND- NO
THIS THE RESOLUTION SPEAKS TO
THE HISTORY WHICH DISPLAYS THE
FIRST BROUGHT TO VIRGINIA
ACTUALLY I SPENT PART OF MY USE
GOING UP IN VIRGINIA AND COURSE
THE RIVER VISITING JAMESTOWN
AND IN WILLIAMSBURG AND SO
FORTH BUT PEOPLE THAN OFTEN
TALK MUCH ABOUT THE HISTORY OF
SLAVERY AND AT LEAST AT THAT
TIME WHEN I WAS GOING UP WHEN
YOU IS THERE CERTAINLY KNEW.
BUT I THINK THE- ISSUE OF
CERTAINLY REPARATIONS WE THINK
ABOUT THE TREMENDOUS. ASSET
DISCREPANT TALK ABOUT INTO
DESPAIR YOUR INCOME DISPARITY
BY GENDER INCOME THE STREET I
RACED WE TALK ABOUT THE ASSETS.
DISPARITIES THAT WE HAVE THAT'S
A CUMULATIVE THE FACT OF NOT
ONLY SLAVERY BUT OF COURSE OF
JIM CROW IN OTHER A SEGREGATION
WHERE. AFTER AMERICANS WERE NOT
ALLOWED O SENSUALLY TO KEENLY
WEALTH. AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THAT THAT IS FAR THE
FUNDAMENTAL INJUSTICE OF WHAT
NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED AND SO I
THINK THIS RESOLUTION CERTAINLY
IS A STEP FORWARD. A CERTAINLY
IS SOMEONE WHOSE OUT. OF THE
API BACKGROUND I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT YOU KNOW SO MANY
PEOPLE SAY WELL I CAME OVER
LATER NOW THIS IS PART OF OUR
COUNTRY'S PART OF FABRIC OF OUR
COUNTRY IS PART OF IT. THE
NATURE OF OUR COUNTRY GREW AND
WE NEED TO FACE THAT AND THIS
RESOLUTION SO IMPORTANT STEP
FORWARD IN THAT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
CENTER ARCHULETA. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I ALSO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS RESOLUTION. BUT
I COME THROUGH IT IN A
DIFFERENT LIGHT BECAUSE THE
FACT THAT. I SERVED. WITH THE
EIGHTY SECOND AIRBORNE AND
WE'RE STATION ORIGINALLY IN
FORT BRAGG NORTH CAROLINA. SO
YOU CAN IMAGINE HOW THIS GUY
FROM CALIFORNIA WAS IN NORTH
CAROLINA BECAUSE THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN FRIENDS WHO I HAD AT
THE TIME. WE'RE LIKE ME. THEY
WERE FROM LOS ANGELES WE WERE
ALL TOGETHER WERE MELTING POT.
SO I HAD NO IDEA THAT THE SOUTH
WAS GOING THROUGH THAT IN THE
SIXTIES. BUT I DID LEARN. THAT
THE MAN THAT I SHARED WITH THAT
IT THAT UNIT THE EIGHTY SECOND
AIRBORNE WITH THE BRAVES.
AUDIBLE AND THE MOST AMERICAN
THEY COULD POSSIBLY BE THEY
LOVE THIS COUNTRY THEY FOUGHT
FOR IT THEY BELIEVED IN IT. AND
I WAS PROUD TO SERVE THEM SURE
WITH THEM SIDE BY SIDE SO I AM
PROUD TO CALL THEM BROTHERS AND
SISTERS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
COLUMN TO AMERICANS AS THEY
SHOULD BE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU CENTER
ARCHULETA MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
BRADFORD WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ALL ACROSS THE
STATE WHO RECOGNIZED THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS MEASURE. AS
WE TALK ABOUT THE ATROCITIES
THAT HAVE BEEN COMMITTED. ALL
OVER THIS COUNTRY AND ALL OVER
THE WORLD THERE'S NO GREATER
ONE THEN THEN SLAVE MEANT OF
AFRICANS WHO WERE BROUGHT HERE
AGAINST YOUR WILL OVER FOUR
HUNDRED YEARS AGO AND TO
RECOGNIZE THIS TO THIS
RESOLUTION IS JUST A SMALL
STEP. BUT WE HAVE TO UNDERSTAND
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY YEARS AGO
WHEN PRESIDENT LINCOLN SIGN
DECAL EMANCIPATION PROCLAMATION
IT STATED THAT AFRICAN SLAVES
AND THEIR DESCENDANTS WOULD BE
ENTITLED TO FORTY ACRES AND A
MULE. ANOTHER BROKEN PROMISE BY
THIS COUNTRY TO THE PEOPLE OF
AFRICAN DESCENT WE'RE STILL
STRIVING FOR OUR EQUAL SHARE OF
WHAT IS THE AMERICAN DREAM WHAT
IS THE CALIFORNIA DREAM. IT IS
ONLY FAIR WE HAVE FOUGHT FOR
REPARATIONS AS WE STATED FOR
JAPANESE AMERICANS TO WERE
WRONGFULLY INTERNED DURING A
WORLD WAR TWO WE'VE EVEN FOUGHT
FOR WAR BENEFITS FOR FILIPINO
BROTHERS AND SISTERS WHO
FOUGHT. IN WORLD WAR TWO. WHAT
MAKES THIS COUNTRY GREAT WHAT
MAKES THIS GREAT. IS THE
ENSLAVEMENT OF BOX WHO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS COUNTRY AND
WE HAVE FAILED TO RECOGNIZE IT
THIS RESOLUTION IS A SMALL STEP
IN RECOGNIZING THE MASSIVE CONT
CONTRIBUTIONS THAT. AFRICAN
AMERICANS AND AFRICAN
DESCENDANTS OF MAY TO THIS
COUNTRY REPARATIONS IS JUST A
SMALL PART OF A DEVELOPMENT
THAT SHOULD SAVE WE'RE SORRY
FOR THE INJUSTICE THAT BAT A
PEOPLE HAVE SUFFERED IN ORDER
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA GREAT IN
ORDER TO MAKE AMERICA GREAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. I BILL I
PORGES BRADFORD I CARRY IT ALL
BY CHIANG. DALY DODD HI THERE
ALSO. I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROW. HERTZBERG. I
HILL AYE HUESO HI TADO I
JACKSON. JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. HI MONNING
BY MORE LAW. MORRELL NIELSEN.
PAN BY PORTANTINO. RUBIO HI
SKINNER. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING
TO SUSPEND THE ROLL CALL ON
THIS ITEM WE WILL COME BACK TO
IT. ENTER HERTZBERG FOR WHAT
PURPOSE TO RISE. REPUBLICANS
HAWKINS IN THE CAUCUS LOUNGE
DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS IN THE MEDI
LOUNGE WE ARE IN RECESS
MEMBERS BOTH THE REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS OF THE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS
HAVE ENDED IF YOU'LL TAKE YOUR
SEATS WERE GOING TO PICK UP
WHERE WE LEFT OFF WHICH IS ON
FILE ITEM THIRTY. MISTER
SECRETARY. FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA BY
ATKINS ALLEN I. ATKINS BATES BY
WELL HI PORGES. BRADFORD I
CAMBIADO I CHIANG. DELHI DODD.
I DORADO HI GALGIANI BY GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO HIGHER TULLOW
I JACKSON I JONES. LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL HI HI
MONNING HI MORE LOCK MORALE.
NIELSEN PAN HI PORTANTINO I
ROTH HI RUBIO I SKINNER. BY
STERN AYE STONE. NUMBER IOWA
CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK.
SENATOR MOVES A CALL MEMBERS IN
FRONT OF YOU YOU HAVE A
SUPPLEMENTAL FILE FILE NUMBER
ONE. FILE ITEM THREE TWENTY SIX
SENATOR PAN ARE YOU PREPARED
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL SEVEN FOURTEEN BY
SENATOR PAN AND NATURALLY INTO
PUBLIC HEALTH CENTER PAN THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS OUR
RIGHTS PERCENT SB SEVEN
FOURTEEN WHICH DEMANDS SB TWO
SEVEN SP TWO SEVENTY SIX
PREVIOUSLY PASSED BY THE
SENATE. THE MAN IT'S REQUESTED
BY THE GOVERNOR AND AGREED TO
BY OUR SPONSORS OUR COLLEAGUES
IN ASSEMBLY I APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN OUR HOUSES
IN THE GOVERNOR DOES RESULT IN
THIS BILL SO WE CAN KEEP
CHILDREN SAFE FROM FROM
PREVENTABLE DISEASES. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE PRO TEM IN
ALL OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE WHO
HAVE CALLED FOR CIVILITY IN
REASON IN THE DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE SB SEVEN FOURTEEN MAKES
THE FOLLOWING SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES SB. TWO SEVENTY SIX
STUDENTS ENROLLED IN SCHOOL
PRIOR TO JANUARY TWENTY TWENTY
WITH EXISTING MEDICAL EXEMPTION
WILL NO LONGER BE REQUIRED TO
SUBMIT EXEMPTION TO THE STATE
HOWEVER CHILDREN WITH EXISTING
EXEMPTIONS WE REQUIRED TO
OBTAIN A NEW EXEMPTION. WHEN
THEY BEGIN KINDERGARTEN SEVENTH
GRADE OR IF THERE NEWLY ROLLING
IN A SCHOOL DISTRICT OR SCHOOL.
EXEMPTIONS GRANTED AFTER JERRY
TWENTY TWENTY WILL BE FILED AT
THIS MEETING CRITERIA SELES IN
SB TO SEND THE SIX WILL BE
REVIEWED. ALL PERMIT EXEMPTIONS
REMAIN VALID THROUGH THE END OF
THE STUDENTS CURRENT GRADE
SPAN. REVIEW EXEMPTIONS ISSUE
BY POSITION TO ISSUED MORE FIVE
A YEAR BEGAN STARTING JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY. POSITION
TO ARE PLACED ON PROBATION FOR
A MUSICIAN RELATED REASONS WILL
HAVE ALL THE EXISTING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS ISSUED REVOKED WILL
BE PROHIBITED FROM WRITING
EXEMPTIONS IN TAYLOR
AFFIRMATION. AND REMOVES
REQUIREMENT THE PHYSICIAN
CERTIFY UNDER PENALTY OF
PERJURY THAT THE INFORMATION
PROVIDED IN AN EXEMPTION. IS
TRUE I SPECIALLY. FOR ASPIRIN
AYE VOTE IN CONCURRENCE WITH
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN. DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE SENATOR STONE YES CENTER
MOTIONS A RESOLUTIONS PLEASE.
WE ARE ON A BILL RIGHT NOW I
WANT TO MAKE A MOTION WITH THE
APPROPRIATE REQUEST IS I'D LIKE
TO MAKE A MOTION TO INVOKE
SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE DASH
TEN D. ON SB SEVEN ONE FOUR. SO
CAN BE HEARD IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE. MADAM PRESIDENT
GIVEN THE SUBSTANTIAL ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS TO SB SEVEN ONE FOR
DEALING WITH CHILDHOOD
IMMUNIZATIONS. I MOVED TO
INVOKE SENATE RULE TWENTY NINE
TEN SO IT CAN BE HEARD AND THE
SENATE. HEALTH COMMITTEE. I
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON THAT
MOTION THANK YOU SIR ONE MOMENT
.
HERTZBERG FOR PURPOSE TO RISE.
WHO SPOT OF THE MOTION IF YOU
JUST GIVE ME A MOMENT TO A YES
IT WILL GIVE A CHANCE FOR THE
REPUBLICANS TO CAUCUS ON THIS.
YES
. CENTER FOR HERTZBERG FOR
PURPOSE YOU RISE THAT WOULD
REGARDING THE MOTION THAT WAS
MADE. BY SENATORS STONE. WITH
ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE-
COMMITTEE OF REFERS MEASURES IN
THIS HOUSE UNDER OUR RULES OF
THE RULES COMMITTEE. THEY HAVE
MADE SUCH A DETERMINATION WITH
RESPECT TO HIS MOTION. AND I
REQUEST A NO VOTE ON HIS MOTION
TO REMAKE YOUR CENTER HERTZBERG
CENTER STONE YOU'RE REQUESTING
AN AYE VOTE. SENATOR HERTZBERG
IS REQUESTING A NO VOTE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
.
I'D LIKE TO ASK EVERYONE IN THE
GALLERY EVERYONE IN THE GALLERY
TO MAINTAIN SOME CIVILITY WE
ARE TRYING TO CONDUCT BILL
SITTING HERE. THERE IS
STABILITY HERE SIR ON OUR PART
NOT YOURS. SOONER GROW FOR
PURPOSE YOU RISE POINT OF ORDER
MA'AM. PLEASE PROCEED. CENTER
GROVE THROUGH THE THROUGH THE
PRESENT AND MOVE TO EXPEL THE
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS IN THE
GALLERY APPROPRIATELY. I
APPRECIATE THAT THE SIEGE FEES
ALREADY ON IT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. RIGHT MEMBERS WE ARE NOW
GOING BACK TO THE ROLL CALL
CENTER HERTZBERG IS REQUESTING
AN AYE VOTE EXCUSE ME SENATOR
HURTS FOR IS REQUESTING A NO
VOTE. THUNDERSTONE IS
REQUESTING AN AYE VOTE. SENATE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. ALLEN. MARCH
LETTER NO ATKINS. BATES HI BILL
NO BURGESS HI BRADFORD NO NO
COMING AT ALL NO CHIANG. HI
DALY HI DODD. NO DORADO NO
GALGIANI. NO GLAZER NO GONZALEZ
NO GROWTH HI HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG NO HILL. NO WAY SO NO
HER TITLE. NO JACKSON NO JONES.
HI LEYVA NO NO MCGUIRE. NO
MITCHELL NO MONNING. NO MORE
LOCK HIGH MORALE. HI NIELSEN HI
PAN NO PORTANTINO NO ROTH. NO
RUBIO NO SKINNER. NO STERN NO
STONE. HI NUMBER NO WHAT COUNTY.
NO WIENER NO WILK HI. EYES
ELEVEN KNOWS TWENTY SEVEN THE
MOTION FAILS WE'RE BACK TO THE
BILL IN CHIEF. SENATOR MORLOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES THE GOVERNOR HAS A
BILL ON IMMUNIZATIONS IN
VACCINES. AND SB SEVEN ONE FOUR
IS A SAD. I AM DOWN IT SHOULD
HAVE GONE TO COMMITTEE. BUT IT
APPEARS WE'RE JUST TALKING PAST
EACH OTHER. YES VACCINES HAVE
AN AMAZING MODERN HAVE BEEN AN
AMAZING MODERN DAY TOOL TO READ
TO CREATE SMALL POX POLIO AND
MUCH MORE. BUT NO. CERTAIN
INDIVIDUALS ARE ALLERGIC TO THE
INGREDIENTS OF ONE OR MORE OF
THE VACCINE. THEREFORE IMMUNIZE
THOSE WHO CAN AND CHAU GRACE
AND MERCY TO THOSE WHO CAN'T.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CHILDREN.
SACRAMENTO SEEMS TO BE MORE
CONCERNED ABOUT BOB CATS. IN
THE ARE ABOUT TODDLERS WHO DO
NOT RECOVER FROM AN
ANAPHYLACTIC SHOCK. WISDOM
WOULD DICTATE THAT WE FIND THE
SWEET SPOT. OR PUT THIS DEBATE
ON HOLD UNTIL WE FIND IT.
CALLING SINCE BILL'S GONE PAST
PROPER FORM AND DECORUM IT NOW
STRIKES ME AS VINDICTIVE. THIS
LEGISLATION IS EVEN SCARING OUR
MEDICAL COMMUNITY. MY MOTHER
HAD FIVE. BROTHERS. ALL GREW UP
ON THE FARM ALL BIG STRAPPING
GUYS MY UNCLE HURLED REMINDED
ME OF CHARLTON HESTON WHEN I
SAW HIM WORKING ONE DAY SHIRT
OFF MOVING. PAY BILLS ON THE
JERRY. I WOULD NEVER MESS WITH
UNCLE HURLED HE AND HIS MY AUNT
GLADYS HAD FOUR WONDERFUL SONS
AND THEN WHEN NUMBER FIVE
NUMBER FIVE SON CAME. ROBBIE
WAS DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED.
HE A NEVER LEARN TO TALK. HE
NEVER WALK OR CRAWLED. MY AUNT
AND UNCLE HAD TO. A SYSTEM
EVERY DAY. HIS MUSCLES KEEP HIM
MOVING. WHEN WE VISITED WE
WOULD DO THE SAME WITH ROBBIE.
HAVING A DISABLED CHILD IS A
FULL TIME OBLIGATION. IT
CHANGES YOUR LIFE DRAMATICALLY
AND THAT'S WHAT THESE PEOPLE
FEAR. ROBBIE PASSED AWAY IN
YOUR DISTRICT MADAM CHAIR
PROBABLY GREW UP IN CHINO.
ROBBIE PASSED AT ABOUT THE AGE
OF TEN. AND I'VE NEVER SEEN MY
UNCLE. SO BROKEN. IS THAT THE
FUNERAL. WE'VE GOT TO CONSIDER
THE POTENTIAL CONSEQUENCES OF
ALLERGIC REACTIONS. WE'VE GOT
TO HIT THE PAUSE BUTTON MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES AND I URGE
A NO VOTE ON SB SEVEN ONE FOUR
THANK YOU MEDI REDDITOR MORLOCK
SENATOR STONE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES AND.
BEFORE I START I WOULD LIKE TO.
RESPECTFULLY ASK PEOPLE IN THE
GALLERY IN PEOPLE IN THE
CAPITAL TO. WATCH YOUR
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. WITH
RESPECT. THIS IS THE
LEGISLATIVE BODY IN THE SENATE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND.
YOU KNOW THIS. ISSUE OVER
IMMUNIZATIONS HAS. PRESS NEED
TO. MAJOR. PRESSURES OF MY OWN
PROFESSION OF BEING A
PHARMACIST AND HAS PUSHED ME TO
THE LIMITS. BENG AN ELECTED
OFFICIAL AND BALANCING THE TWO.
YOU KNOW. I THINK IT'S
UNFORTUNATE IF ANY OF US. EVER
VILIFY PEOPLE DON'T WANT TO
HAVE A VOICE HERE IN THE STATE
CAPITAL. AND I'VE HEARD OVER.
THE YEARS THAT I'VE BEEN HERE
WHEN. PEOPLE WANT TO HAVE
PARENTAL RIGHTS OVER THEIR
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND ARE.
LABELED EXTREMISTS LABELED ANTI
BAXTER'S. WHEN THERE IS NOTHING
STRONGER MY FRIENDS. THEN
WANTING THE BEST FOR YOU THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF YOUR
CHILD. NOW. I KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT
MEDICINE TO BE DANGEROUS. HI
THERE ARE THOSE OF YOU THAT OF
ALLEGED ON THE FLOOR THAT I
SHOULD BE BE TALKING ABOUT
LEGAL ISSUES BECAUSE I'M NOT A
LAWYER AND THEREFORE. MY
COMMENTS ARE MY OPINIONS SO
SHOULD BE DISREGARDED. THE I.
WELCOME PEOPLE TO DEBATE ME
AND- DISCUSS THE MERITS OF.
MEDICINE AND DRUGS. LET ME JUST
SAY A FEW THINGS. WHEN WE WERE
CONSIDERING SB TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN. IT WAS AT THE TIME I HAD
MY FIRST GRAND CHILD. AND IT
WAS DETERMINED. THAT. MY
GRANDDAUGHTERS ONE YEAR
BIRTHDAY. THAT SHE WAS AUTISTIC
WE DIDN'T KNOW. TO WHAT EXTENT.
IT HAPPENED. AT ABOUT THE SAME
TIME THAT SHE RECEIVE THE MMR
VACCINE. COINCIDENTALLY THE
SYMPTOMS OF AUTISM CHAU AT
APPROXIMATELY THE SAME TIME.
AND I HAD A. A CHALLENGE WITH
MY OWN CHILDREN. WHEN SB TWO
SEVENTY SEVEN CAME ON AND I WAS
A CO AUTHOR OF TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN BECAUSE I'M NOT ONLY
LEARNED ABOUT IMMUNIZATIONS
I'VE TAUGHT ABOUT THEM AT THE
UNIVERSITY LEVEL. BUT IT
CREATED SOME SIGNIFICANT
FRICTION. BETWEEN MY CHILDREN.
AND MYSELF. AND LET ME SAY THIS
THEY DON'T THEY CALL. MEDIC
GIVING MEDICAL SERVICES A
PRACTICE AND THE REASON WHY
THEY CALL IT AT A PRACTICE IS
BECAUSE IT'S NOT PERFECT. WE DO
THE BEST THAT WE CAN. TO HEAL
PEOPLE AND PREVENT THEM OF
DISEASES THAT ARE MINOR AND
DISEASES THAT ARE VERY SERIOUS.
BUT HERE'S WHAT WE DO NOW. WE
KNOW THAT A HUMAN IMMUNE SYSTEM.
IS NOT FULLY MATURE UNTIL A
CHILD IS TWELVE TO FOURTEEN
YEARS OLD AND WHILE I BELIEVE
IN THIS IS ONLY ME SPEAKING
WITH NO SCIENTIFIC BACK UP. AS
I LOOK AND SEE THE INCIDENCE OF.
AUTISM IN THE STATE IN THE
COUNTRY. IS THAT. WITH THE
IMMUNIZATION SCHEDULES THAT WE
SEE. I THINK THAT THE SCHEDULE
THAT WE GIVE THESE
IMMUNIZATIONS AND MAY BE TOO
ONEROUS SERVE YOU WELL MAYBE
TOO OVERWHELMING FOR A CHILD'S
IMMUNE SYSTEM. THE BECAUSE
WHAT'S CALLED AN AUTO IMMUNE
REACTION NOW WHAT IS AN AUTO
IMMUNE DISEASE MANY OF YOU HAVE
HEARD OF THINGS LIKE LUPUS AND
ALL SORT OF COLITIS AND GRAVES
DISEASE FIBROMYALGIA.
VASCULITIS RHEUMATOID FEVER.
WE'RE STILL LEARNING ABOUT THE
IMMUNE SYSTEM AND HOW IT WORKS
AND A LOT OF THESE TV
COMMERCIALS THAT YOU SEE ABOUT
DRUGS THAT TREAT THINGS LIKE
ALL SORT OF CORRUPT COLITIS AND
RHEUMATOID ARTHRITIS OR DRUGS
TO TRY TO TEMPER OUR OWN IMMUNE
SYSTEM FROM ATTACKING. NORMAL
CELLS AND TISSUES. WITHIN THE
HUMAN BODY. SO. WE HAVE. THE
CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL AND
THEY MONITOR. DRUGS ALONG WITH
THE FEDERAL DRUG ADMINISTRATION
AND THEY. THEY PRINT ADVERSE
REACTIONS THAT HAPPEN WHEN SOME
POPULATIONS ARE IMMUNIZED. BUT
YOU HAVE TO UNDERSTAND THAT NOT
EVERY ADVERSE REACTION IS
PRINTED IN THE CDC GUIDELINES.
AND THAT'S WHERE I THINK THAT
THE PATIENT AND PHYSICIAN
RELATIONSHIP. BECOMES SOMETHING
THAT IS IMPORTANT. AND
SOMETHING THAT CERTAINLY.
SHOULD BE RESPECTED. SO. HERE
WE ARE TODAY. AND WE ALWAYS
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CITIZENS HAVE THE RIGHT TO
EXPRESS THEMSELVES IT'S
DEMOCRACY. BUT AS WE HAVE SEEN
SB SEVEN ONE FOUR COME TO THE
FOREFRONT. I THINK IT'S GOING
TO BE A MOCKERY OF DEMOCRACY.
IF WE ALLOW THIS BILL. TO NOT
HAVE THE ONE PUBLIC HEARING.
CONTENT OF SB SEVEN ONE FOUR IS
A MATERIAL CHANGE TO THE
LEGISLATION THAT WE HAVE
PREVIOUSLY. AN ACTOR. MEMBERS
LET'S GO ALL THE WAY BACK. ALL
THE WAY BACK TO TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN WHEN SB TWO SEVEN SEVEN
WAS DEBATED IN THIS
LEGISLATURE. I KNOW BECAUSE I
WAS A PROPONENT. ONE OF THE
REASONS I SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE WAS BECAUSE MY- GOOD
CALLING FROM SACRAMENTO.
PROMISE THAT WITH ITS PASSAGE
MEDICAL EXEMPTIONS WOULD BE
ALLOWED IN HONOR. BUT DON'T
TAKE MY WORD FOR IT. TAKE THE
SENATORS WORDS ON APRIL
FIFTEENTH TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN.
MY FRIEND THE SENATOR FROM SAN
FRANISCO RELEASED A FACT
VERSUS MATH PRESS RELEASE IN
WHICH HE SAYS THAT IT IS FALSE.
I QUOTE SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN
WOULD PREVENT CHILDREN WHO NEED
THEM FROM RECEIVING EXEMPTIONS.
HE THEN FOLLOWED UP BY SAYING
SB TWO SEVENTY SEVEN LEAVES TO
THE DISCRETION OF DOCTORS. WHEN
A CHILD REQUIRES A MEDICAL
EXEMPTION FROM REQUIRED VACCINE
VACCINATIONS. CALIFORNIANS WERE
TOLD AT THE TIME AND TIME AGAIN.
THE EXEMPTIONS WOULD BE ALLOW.
THE SENATOR AND THE LEGISLATURE.
INCLUDED MYSELF INCLUDING
MYSELF MADE A PROMISE. BUT
COLLEAGUES THAT PROMISES NOT
BEING CUFFED. EVEN OUR
ILLUSTRIOUS GOVERNOR SAW THE
FLAWS IN SB TWO SEVENTY SIX AND-
INSISTED ON AMENDMENTS. OR. HE
WOULD BASICALLY THREATENED TO
NOT SIGN OR POTENTIALLY VETO
THE LEGISLATIO AND THAT BRINGS
US TO HEAR TODAY RIGHT NOW
VOTING ON THIS BILL. THAT'S THE
EQUIVALENT OF PASSING
LEGISLATION IN THE DARK OF
NIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY.
WHY DO I SAY THAT. WELL TO
BEGIN SB SEVEN ONE FOUR WAS NOT.
AND NEVER WILL BE HEARD IN
PUBLIC. BECAUSE OF THE WAVING
OF RULE TWENTY NINE DASH CAM
AND WHAT DOES THE RULE TWENTY
NINE DASH TEN SAY. IT PROTECTED
THIS INSTITUTION AND TO PROTECT
THE CITIZENS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IT THE BILL WAS
TO BE GOT AN AMENDED. WHICH I
BELIEVE IS AN ABUSE OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS AT LEAST IT
WOULD BE A PUBLIC HEARING SO
THE PUBLIC COULD WEIGH IN. ON A
BILL THAT THEY SUPPORT. FOR A
BILL THAT THEY OPPOSE. HOWEVER.
AS THE SAYING GOES RULES ARE
MEANT TO BE BROKEN AND THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS SURE TAKEN.
THAT SAYING TO HEART. JOINT
REAL TWENTY NINE DASH TEN WAS
WAY. IN OUR CONSTITUENTS WERE
NEVER GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY. TO
FORMALLY FORCED TO VOICE THEIR
OPINIONS ON SB SEVEN ONE FOUR
WHAT DO YOU FRAZIER. WE ALREADY
KNOW WHAT THE OUTCOME OF THE
VOTE IS GOING TO BE WITH US
LEGISLATURE WHY NOT GIVE THE
CONSTITUENTS MANY OF WHOM. ROLL
ALL NIGHT LONG. TO COME TO THIS
CAPITAL SO THEIR VOICE COULD BE
HEARD SO THAT THEIR
LEGISLATURE. AND THEIR CAPITAL
BUT TELL THEM WE DON'T WANT TO
HEAR FROM YOU. WE DON'T CARE
WHAT YOU HAVE TO SAY. WE'RE
COMING ON THE FLOOR WE'RE GOING
TO VOTE THE WAY WE ARE TOLD THE
WAY WE FEEL WE'RE GOING TO VOTE
ON THIS ISSUE WHETHER YOU AGREE
WITH US. OR DISAGREE WITH US.
AND TO SEE MY FRIENDS IN THE
CAPITAL OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE TO THE LEFT
IS ALWAYS TALK ABOUT TOLERANCE
AND ACCEPTANCE. AND DIFFERING
OPINIONS I HAVE TO SEE THIS
MORNING BUT NOT ONLY A MOTHER
BUT A GRANDMOTHER IT'S TOUGH TO
IN THE FRONT OF THE CAPITOL IT
IS ARRESTED BECAUSE THEY WANT
EXHIBIT THEIR SECOND THE FIRST
AMENDMENT RIGHTS. JUST A FEW
HOURS AGO. SB SEVEN ONE FOUR
MOVED TO THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR
AND- HERE IT IS ON THE SENATE
FLOOR. THIS BILL IS BE VOTED ON
WITHOUT EVER BEING HEARD TO THE
PUBLIC HEARING PROCESS STIFLING
ANY CITIZEN FROM COMMENTING FOR
AGAINST THE MEASURE. COLLEAGUES
PUBLIC HEARINGS MATTER. THEY
MAY NOT SEEM TO BY SOME MEMBERS
HERE BUT THEY MATTER TO THE
PEOPLE THEY MATTER TO THE OPEN
PROCESS THOSE LEGISLATURE
PRETENDS TO SUPPORT. THE MATTER
TO THE INTEGRITY THIS
LEGISLATURE SEEMS TO BE DOING
EVERYTHING POSSIBLE TO CALL
INTO QUESTION. THE PUBLIC
DESERVES A CHANCE TO VOICE
THEIR OPINION ON ALL MEASURES
THE PASS THROUGH THIS HOUSE.
SOME OF THE LEGISLATURE MIGHT
NOT THINK LISTENING TO THEIR
CONSTITUENTS IS NECESSARY. SOME
MAY NOT EVEN WANT TO HEAR WHAT
THEIR PEOPLE THINK BUT- JUST
BECAUSE YOU DISAGREE WITH THE
PUBLIC DOESN'T MEAN THAT OUR
VOICES SHOULD BE SILENCE. AND
IGNORED NOT ONLY IS IT BAD
BUSINESS IT'S ON DEMOCRATIC AND
EVEN WORSE I WOULD SAY IT'S A
MOCKERY OF DEMOCRACY. YOU KNOW
MY FRIENDS. I SAT THROUGH A
VERY LONG HEARING IN THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WILL BE HEARD SB TWO
SEVENTY SIX AND I WAS THE
CHAIRMAN. AND I CHOSE TO. GIVE
THE AUTHOR A LOT OF RESPECT IN.
IN RESERVING MY OPINIONS FOR
THE FLOOR AND GIVING HIM AN
HONEST AND EARNEST CHANCE TO
PASS HIS BILL. BUT I HAVE TO BE
VERY HONEST WITH YOU. THERE WAS
A COUPLE THOUSAND PEOPLE THAT
CAME WITH IT DIDN'T COME ALONE.
THEY CAME WITH THEIR VACCINE
INJURED CHILDREN. AND WHEN I
SAW THE MORBIDITY OF WHAT
VACCINATIONS CAM DUE TO PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER. THESE
PEOPLE HAVE VERY GOOD POINTS TO
BE CONCERNED IF THEIR CHILDREN
AFTER CHILD HAD AN ANAPHYLACTIC
REACTION HAD PERMANENT BRAIN
DAMAGE TO IMMUNIZATION. WOULD
YOU WANT YOUR GRANDCHILDREN TO
BE IMMUNIZED IF IT'S A FAMILY
HISTORY OF AN ADVERSE REACTION
THAT YOU DON'T KNOW COULD
HAPPEN TO A SECONDCHILD IN
THAT SAME FAMILY. I BECAME VERY
EMPATHETIC WHEN I SAW NOT ONE
NOT TWO WE'RE TALKING. DOZENS
IF NOT OVER A HUNDRED OF
SEVERELY INJURED KIDS NOW. I
BELIEVE THAT THESE INJURIES.
ARE RARE BUT THEY HAPPEN IN
EVERY PARENT HAS THE RIGHT TO
BE CONCERNED. ABOUT THE HEALTH
AND WELFARE OF THEIR CHILDREN.
LET'S JUST QUICKLY GET BACK TO
EXEMPTIONS LET'S ASSUME THAT
THE STATUS QUO WERE TO CONTINUE.
YES YOU WOULD STILL SEE POCKETS
OF IMMUNIZATION LESS THAN 95%
IF YOU ALLOW THE EXEMPTION
PROCESS TO CONTINUE AS IT HAS
MY FRIENDS LESS THAN 1% OF THE
CHILDREN THAT ARE IMMUNIZED IN
THE STATE WOULD BE GIVEN
EXEMPTIONS THAT'S NOT NEAR
ENOUGH TO TAKE US BELOW A 95%
HEARD. IMMUNIZATION SO WHY ARE
WE PICKING A FIGHT. THOUSANDS
IF NOT HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF.
PARENTS WANTING TO PROTECT
THEIR CHILDREN IN A SYSTEM THAT
WORKS IN A SYSTEM THAT WAS
PROMISED TO BE IMPLEMENTED A
CERTAIN WAY ONLY TO HAVE THE
CARPET PULLED OUT FROM
UNDERNEATH THEM. I CAN'T TELL
YOU. HOW IT HURTS ME. WHEN I
VISIT MY SON AND MY DAUGHTER IN
LAW. AND. I SEE MY SIX AND A
HALF YEAR OLD AUTISTIC
GRANDDAUGHTER. WHO WEARS A
DIAPER. WHO HAS NEVER HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THEIR PARENTS
OR ME. WHEN I TELL MY
GRANDDAUGHTER I LOVE YOU I
WOULD GIVE A MILLION DOLLARS TO
HEAR MY GRANDDAUGHTER SAY I
LOVE YOU GRANDPA. AND I'M
HOPING THAT THROUGH TIME THAT.
WITH TECHNOLOGY AND THERAPIES
THAT. MY SIX AND A HALF YEAR
OLD AUTISTIC GRANDDAUGHTER WILL
LEAD A GOOD AND PRODUCTIVE LIFE
IN SOME WAY. IT ALSO KIND OF
REMINDS ME OF A COUSIN WHEN I
WAS GROWING UP. MY COUSIN WAS
NAMED LARRY. HILLARY WAS A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT. HE WAS A
LITTLE BIT SLOW. AND I ASKED MY
MOM AND DAD YOU KNOW WHAT'S
WITH LYRICS. AND THEY SAID WELL
HE WAS BORN AND HE HAD SOME
BRAIN DAMAGE WHEN HE WAS BORN
AND- WE'RE HOPING FOR GOOD
THINGS FOR HIM. AND I HAVE TO
KIND OF GIVE A SHOUT OUT
BECAUSE. IT WAS PRESIDENT JOHN
F. KENNEDY. THAT PUT A LOT OF
THESE. PEOPLE THAT HAD BRAIN
INJURIES TO WORK. MY COUSIN
MARY MAY GOD REST HIS SOUL WORK
FOR THE POST OFFICE IS ONE OF
THE GREATEST EMPLOYEES. IN THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY. SO MY
FRIENDS. I PLEAD WITH YOU I
EMPATHIZE WITH YOU THIS
SHOULDN'T BE A PARTISAN ISSUE.
WE SHOULDN'T BE VILIFYING
PARENTS THAT ARE ONLY ACCUSED
OF WANTING THEIR CHILDREN TO BE
HEALTHY WHY WOULD ANY PARENT
WANT TO NOT IMMUNIZE THEIR
CHILDREN AGAINST THE DISEASE
LIKE MEASLES THAT COULD KILL
THEIR CHILDREN AND WHAT THE
OVERWHELMING FEAR THAT THEY
HAVE THAT THE CURE COULD BE
WORSE THAN THE DISEASE ITSELF.
SO. FOR THE SAKE OF
TRANSPARENCY IN IN THE SAKE OF
PROCESS FOR THE SAKE OF
DEMOCRACY. AND IN THE SAKE OF
THIS INSTITUTION. AND TO GIVE
PARENTS IN CALIFORNIA THE PEACE
OF MIND THAT THEY CAN EXERT
THEIR PARENTAL RIGHTS TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH OF THEIR
CHILDREN. I AM ASKING YOU AND
I'M BEGGING YOU PLEASE VOTE NO
ONE SB SEVEN ONE FOUR. THANK
YOU CENTER STONE. FURTHER
DISCUSSION BATES SENATOR JONES.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS. ARISE FOR A COUPLE
PURPOSES THIS AFTERNOON ONE
OBVIOUSLY IS TO VOTE AGAINST SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN. BUT I THINK
MORE IMPORTANT TO ME TODAY
AFTER HAVING SERVED IN THE
LEGISLATURE FOR NOW SEVEN YEARS
SIX IN THE ASSEMBLY NOW ONE IN
THE SENATE. I WOULD LIKE TO
RISE TO APPEAL TO OUR BETTER
NATURE AS THAT SENATORS ELECTED
REPRESENTATIVES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND ALONG THAT LINE
OF THOUGHT I WOULD LIKE TO
DEFEND. THE HONOR OF THE SENATE.
N. F. WE CAN ALL TAKE A LOOK AT
THE MODEL ABOVE THE ROSTRUM.
I'M GONNA TRY TO PRONOUNCE IT
IN LATIN BUT ALL THE- TELL US
ALL WHAT IT MEANS IN ENGLISH.
SENATE TORRES S. CIVITATIS
LIBERTARIAN TULARE. IT IS THE
DUTY OF THE SENATE TO PROTECT
THE LIBERTIES OF THE PEOPLE.
THAT'S THE MOTTO THAT WE SERVE
IN THIS HOUSE UNDER EVERY
SINGLE DAY. AND THE SCIENCE HAS
BEEN DEBATED AND THE PURPOSES
OF BEEN DOING DEBATED. BUT THE
QUESTION I ASK YOU TODAY. IS
WHAT IMPENDING CRISIS. IS THAT
IS HAPPENING TODAY IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT IS COMPELLING
US TO TAKE THESE EXTRAORDINARY
STEPS IN THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. TO RAM THIS BILL
THROUGH. INTRODUCE JUST UNDER
THE DEADLINE OF AMENDMENTS. AND
I WILL SAY. THAT I DO THANK GOD
THAT FOR THE PROPOSITION A
COUPLE YEARS AGO THEY GAVE US
THE SEVENTY TWO HOUR RULE SO
THAT TODAY IS ACTUALLY THE
DEADLINE FOR TO BE INTRODUCED
OTHERWISE IT COULD HAVE BEEN
SLAMMED THROUGH. AT MIDNIGHT ON
FRIDAY. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF
THE SENATE THIS IS AN ABUSE OF
OUR POWER. THIS IS AN ABUSE OF
THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. THIS
IS A VIEWS OF THE NINE HUNDRED
PLUS THOUSAND CALIFORNIA'S
CITIZENS THAT EACH ONE OF US
ARE ELECTED TO REPRESENT IN AN
HONEST AND DUTIFUL MANNER.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE I APPEAL TO YOUR BETTER
NATURE. THAT THERE IS NO
IMPENDING CRISIS THAT WE HAVE
TO SOLVE TODAY BY VOTING FOR
THIS BILL. MADAM PRESIDENT LIKE
PERMISSION TO READ ONE
PARAGRAPH PLEASE WITHOUT
OBJECTION. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WHEN THOMAS JEFFERSON WROTE THE
DECLARATION OF INDEPENDENCE HE
OUTLINED TWENTY SEVEN ABUSES.
OF THE OF THE MONARCHY THAT THE
COLONIES. WERE UPSET ABOUT. ANY
ITEMIZE EACH ONE OF THOSE
TWENTY SEVEN ABUSES IN ANY HE
CLOSED THAT ITEM IS ATION WITH
THIS PARAGRAPH. AT EVERY STAGE
OF THESE OPPRESSIONS. WE HAVE
PETITIONED PETITION FOR REDRESS
IN THE MOST HUMBLE TERMS. OUR
REPEATED PETITIONS HAVE BEEN
ANSWERED ONLY BY REPEATED
INJURY. A PRINCE WHOSE
CHARACTER IS THUS MARKED BY
EVERY ACT. WHICH MAY DEFINE A
TYRANT IS UNFIT TO BE THE RULER
OF FREE PEOPLE. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE. LET'S
PLEASE NOT SHOW OURSELVES TODAY
TO BE ON FIT. TO BE RULERS OF
FREE PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. HOW WE CAN SOLVE
THAT PROBLEM AND THAT
PREDICAMENT IN TWO WAYS. NUMBER
ONE THE SENATE WITHDRAW SB
SEVEN FOURTEEN AND NUMBER TWO
WE PETITION THE GOVERNOR TO
VETO SB TWO SEVENTY SIX. YOU
VERY MUCH I ASKED. I ASKED FOR
A NO VOTE ON SB SEVEN FOURTEEN
THANK YOU SENATOR JONES MEMBERS
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
CENTER PAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SB SEVEN FOURTEEN ACTUALLY
GRANDFATHER'S EXISTING MEDICAL
EXEMPTIONS FOR SEVERAL YEARS AT
THE REQUEST OF THE GOVERNOR. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR PAN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA HI
ATKINS HI BATES NO BILL HI
PORGES NO BRADFORD HI CAMBIADO.
HI TING NO DALY NO DODD. HI
THERE ALSO HI GALGIANI. HI
GLAZER. I GONZALEZ HI GROWTH NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TADO HI JACKSON. I JONES. NOTE
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL
HI MONNING HI MORE LAW KNOWN
REAL. NO NIELSEN NO HAN HI
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE NO
NUMBER HI WHAT COUNTY HI WINNER.
HI WILK NO. THIS CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ROUGH.
EYES TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS ELEVEN
THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE
ARE. REALLY. TO OUR GUESTS IN
THE GALLERY IF YOU IF YOU
CANNOT CONTROL YOURSELVES YOU
WILL BE ASKED TO LEAVE
. CENTER
GROW FOR WHAT PURPOSE TO RISE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
LOOKING CAUCUS IN THE RULES
ROOM IMMEDIATELY IN THE RULES
RUBIO. MADDIE LOWNDES
IMMEDIATELY MAGGIE LOUNGE YES
OKAY BY THE CAUGHT CARSON'S
WILL BE BEST. RIGHT HERE THAT
BE GREAT THANK YOU REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS IN THE **** LOUNGE
. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE ARE BACK BOTH
CAUCUSES HAVE ENDED WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO MOVE BACK IN
THE FILE SENATOR JACKSON ARE
YOU PREPARED TO PRESENT FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AN ECHO
IN THE FARMS SENATE JACKSON
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES THIS MEASURE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY NINE PROMOTES
GREATER PUBLIC SAFETY AND MORE
A MORE COMPREHENSIVE POLICY.
ENFORCEMENT MODEL FOR
INDEPENDENT AMMUNITION VENDORS
A CALIFORNIA GUN SHOWS CURRENT
LAW OUTLINES PUBLIC SAFETY
MEASURES FOR FIREARM DEALERS
WHO SELL AMMUNITION IN THE
STATE BUT INDEPENDENT
AMMUNITION VENDORS DO NOT
RECEIVE THE SAME SCRUTINY. THIS
MEASURE SPONSORED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA HAS TWO DISTINCT
PARTS THE FIRST PART OF THE
BILL ADDRESSES THE
INCONSISTENCY WITH WHICH
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION VENDORS
A CALIFORNIA GUN SHOWS ARE
TREATED UNDER STATE LAW.
COLLEAGUES THERE ARE OVER A
HUNDRED GUN SHOWS A YEAR IN
CALIFORNIA THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE IS PRIMARILY
RESPONSIBLE FOR ENFORCING
FIREARMS LAWS ACT THESE ONE
HUNDRED GUN SHOWS. THIS MEASURE
THEN IS AN IMPORTANT MEASURE TO
CLOSE LOOPHOLES AND ENSURE ALL
FIREARMS AND AMMUNITION VENDORS
IN CALIFORNIA ARE SUBJECT TO
THE SAME LICENSING AND
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. SECOND
PART OF THE BILL WOULD UPDATE
THE DEAL RECORD OF SHALE
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS THE DRAWS
FEE THE BILL WOULD REDUCE THE
NON REGULATORY FEE FOR THE
FIREARMS TRANSACTIONS FROM
NINETEEN DOLLARS TO ONE DOLLAR.
AND AUTHORIZED THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO CHARGE A SEPARATE
FEE OF THIRTY ONE DOLLARS IN
NINETEEN CENTS PER FIREARM
RELATED TRANSACTION SOLELY TO
COVER THE COSTS OF FIREARMS
RELATED REGULATORY ACTIVITIES
WITHOUT THESE ADJUSTMENTS THE
DRAWS FUNDS WILL BE DEPLETED.
AND THE FUND IS EXPECTED AT
THIS POINT WITHOUT THIS
CORRECTION AND ADJUSTMENT TO
BECOME INSOLVENT INSOLVENT BY
MAY OF TWENTY TWENTY. IF AND
WHEN THE DRAWS FUND DOES BECOME
INSOLVENT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL NOT HAVE THE
CAPACITY TO COMPLETE THOSE VERY
IMPORTANT BACKGROUND CHECKS
WITHIN THE TEN DAY STATUTORILY
REQUIRED PERIOD. THE PROPOSED
THE ADJUSTMENT WOULD PROVIDE
SUFFICIENT REVENUES TO AVERT
THE POTENTIAL SALE OF FAR. ARMS
TO PERSONS WHO HAVE NOT
UNDERGONE THIS COMPLETE
BACKGROUND CHECK AND THIS BILL
IS ALSO A CRITICAL STEP TOWARD
ENSURING THAT THE DRAWS ACCOUNT
POSSESSES THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY FOR OUR STATE TO MEET
ITS OBLIGATION TO ADMINISTER
AND ENFORCE OUR NATION'S
LEADING GUN SAFETY LAWS WITH
THAT. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER JACKSON MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA HI ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO. BELL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD
HI CABALLERO HI JANE NO DALY NO
NO DODD. I DORADO I GALGIANI.
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ BY GROVE NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TADO. JACKSON HI JONES
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL BY MONEY. I'M MORE
LOCK NO MORALE NOTE NIELSEN NO
PAN AYE PORTANTINO. BY ROTH
RUBIO AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY BY
WIENER HI WILK NO. THIS CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. GALGIANI HI
TITLE. ROTH. PRICE TWENTY SEVEN
KNOWS ELEVENTH THE MEASURE
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE FORWARD TO A FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY NINE SENATOR JACKSON'S
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
FOUR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA
AN ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC
RECORDS SENATE JACKSON THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
I RISE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA IS A. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY FOR IT. THIS MEASURE
WILL REQUIRE PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
RETAIN PUBLIC RECORDS THAT ARE
TRANSMITTED BY EMAIL FOR AT
LEAST TWO YEARS THIS WILL
CLARIFY EXISTING PUBLIC RECORD
RETENTION LAW AND BRING IT INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
EMAILS AS WE KNOW OUR CRITICAL
C2 CONDUCTING THE PUBLIC'S
BUSINESS AND RETENTION
REQUIREMENTS FOR PUBLIC RECORDS
NEED O BE PROPERLY APPLIED TO
THEM CURRENTLY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND AGENCIES HAVE
RADICALLY DIFFERENT EMAIL
RETENTION POLICIES. SOME CITIES
KEEP THEIR EMAILS FOR AS LITTLE
AS THIRTY DAYS. WHILE OTHERS
KEEP THEIR EMAILS INDEFINITELY
THIS WILL GIVE GUIDANCE TO THEM
AS WE KNOW IN TWENTY NINETEEN
EMAILS ARE OF EQUAL RELEVANCE
TO PAPER RECORDS AND THIS
MEASURE INSURERS ARE PUBLIC
RECORD RETENTION REQUIREMENTS.
ARE APPROPRIATELY REPLY TO
EMAILS GIVEN THEIR INCREASING
IMPORTANCE AND HELP PUBLIC
AGENCIES CONDUCT THEIR WORK I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BY BATES HI BILL BY
BURGESS BRADFORD I CARRIER I
CHIANG BY DELHI. DODD. HI
DORADO AYE GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ BY GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TADO AYE JACKSON AYE
JONES. NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M MORE
LOCK RAIL. NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE
THIS NOVEMBER OUR CASSIE BY
WIENER AYE WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. YES DALY NO
GROWTH. MORE LOCK. MORRELL.
FIVE THIRTY TWO KNOWS FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
FOUR SENATOR ALLEN ARE YOU
PREPARED TO PRESENT. PASS ON
FILE. FILE ITEM TWO THIRTY
EIGHT SENATOR HERTZBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL A FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA AN ACT RELATED TO
ELECTIONS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT IN EIGHTEEN TWELVE
THE GOVERNOR OF MASSACHUSETTS
WAS A YOUNG GENTLEMAN BY THE
NAME OF ELBRIDGE GERRY. IT IS
HIS NAME THAT WE GOT THE WORD
GERRYMANDERING BECAUSE HE HAD
WRITTEN A DRUG DRAWN A DISTRICT
IN BOSTON AT THAT TIME THAT
LOOKED LIKE A MYTHICAL
SALAMANDER IT WAS SAID. THAT
BECAME THE TERMS STAY THE
CALIFORNIA PASSED THE VOTER OF
FIRST ACT ON NOVEMBER TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT WHICH
CREATED A BIPARTISAN COMMISSION
AND SINCE THEN THE STATE A
CALIFORNIA EVERYBODY WHO'S HERE
TODAY IN THIS HOUSE HAS A
DISTRICT DRAWN BY THAT
BIPARTISAN COMMISSION. INSTEAD
OF BY ELECTED OFFICIALS HOWEVER
UNLIKE THE STATE LEVEL
REDISTRICTING THERE ARE VERY
FEW REQUIREMENTS GOVERNING CITY
AND COUNTY REDISTRICTING TO
ENSURE THE PROCESS IS FAIR.
THIS MEASURE WILL CREATE CLEAR
STANDARDS FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES. BY DOING THREE THINGS
CLARIFYING THE CRITERIA FOR
DRAWING DISTRICT LINES
IMPROVING TRANSPARENCY BY
MAKING MAPS AVAILABLE
INCREASING PUBLIC ENGAGEMENT BY
REQUIRING MINIMUM NUMBER OF
HEARINGS I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
MEMBERS OF THE DISCUSSION AND
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. BATES NOBEL
I PURCHASE NO BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG NO DALY NO
DODD. HI DORADO HI GALGIANI. I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW. NO
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI WITH SO I
TADO AYE JACKSON AYE JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LUCK NO
MORRELL NO NIELSEN. PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASSIE. I WIENER
AYE WILK NO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. THE BILL
HAS. BY TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS
WE'RE GONNA MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM TO EIGHTEEN SENATOR
GLAZER. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN
TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LOW AND ACT REALLY INTO
PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
CENTER GLAZER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA
HERE. ON THE FLOOR A NUMBER OF.
THAT RENEWAL BILLS FOR OUR
BUREAUS IN THIS IS THE FIRST
ONE THIS IS A BY MY COLLEAGUE
IN THE ASSEMBLY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW. DEALING WITH THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY EXTENDS THE SUNSET
DATE TWO TWENTY TWENTY FOUR.
GIVES THE BOARD AT EXTENSION
WILL GIVE THE BOARD TIME DAY
DEMONSTRATED SUCCESS IN ITS
GROWTH THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU
MAKES. UP FOR THE CHANGES THAT
AUTHORIZES THE BOARD OF
ACCOUNTANCY DISTRIBUTED
NEWSLETTER ELECTRONICALLY
SECOND REQUIRES ALL APPLICANTS
AND LICENSEES WHO POSSESS A
VALID EMAIL ADDRESS PROVIDED.
THIRTY REVISES THE REQUIREMENT
TO ADOPT REGULATIONS RELATING
TO FELONY FINANCIAL CRIMES.
THAT ARE DIRECTLY IN ADVERSELY
RELATED TO QUALIFICATIONS
FUNCTIONS ARE DUTIES OF A
CERTIFIED PUBLIC ACCOUNTANT.
AND FINALLY CODIFIES IT A FEE
INCREASE TO TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
DOLLARS. AND INCREASES THE
STATUTORY MAXIMUM TO TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY DOLLARS. THAT
THIS BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
BATES BELL FIVE LARGEST BY
BRADFORD I CARRIER I CHIANG AYE
DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. HI TITLE I
JACKSON. I JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK I AM A
REAL. AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO I ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG. ABA KELSEY I WINNER HI
WILK HI. I THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
THE- PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS BATES BATES AYE
AYES THIRTY NINE NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES WE ARE MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TO FORTY SENATOR
ALLEN ARE YOU PREPARED TO
PRESENT. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FIFTEEN FORTY BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GABRIEL AND ACTUALLY IN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND CLING THEIR TO
RUSTIC FACSIMILE SENATOR ALAN
MEMBERS I AM VERY PLEASED THAT
BOTH MY OFFICIAL CAPACITY
CENTER BUT ALSO CHAIR OR A LIST
OF JEWISH CAUCUS VERY PLEASED
TO PRESENT AB FIFTEEN FORTY
EIGHT WHICH WOULD CODIFY THE
CALIFORNIA STATE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM. AND
PROVIDE MUCH NEEDED ASSISTANCE
TO NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AT
RISK OF HATE MOTIVATED VIOLENCE
THE DRAMATIC INCREASE IN HATE
MOTIVATED VIOLENCE AN INCREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF HATE GROUPS
HAVE MADE IMPROVING SECURITY.
AT INSTITUTIONS SERVING
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES AN
URGENT PRIORITY THIS BILL
CODIFIES AND STRENGTHENS THE
CALIFORNIA STATE NONPROFIT
SECURITY GRANT PROGRAM WHICH IS
NOW BEING ADMINISTERED BY THE
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
RAINING THIS PROGRAM IN STATUTE
IS AN IMPORTANT STEP FORWARD IN
PROTECTING CALIFORNIA'S.
COMMUNITIES TARGETED BY HATE TO
PRIORITY FOR OUR CAUCUS AND HAS
NO OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
BATES HI BILL BY BURGESS HI
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE TING
AYE DALY AYE DODD AYE DURAZO
AYE GALGIANI. AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ BY GROVE. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO. HIGHER
TOTAL AYE JACKSON AYE JONES BUT
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING AYE MOORLACH AYE
MORRELL AYE NIELSEN. HI PAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE AMBERG OUR CASKEY AYE
WIENER BY WILK HI. I THIRTY
NINE TWO ZERO THE MEASURE I
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY AYE AYE SIR NINE NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM TO FORTY ONE
SENATOR DRAWS SO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SOME OF
THE FORTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES AN ACRYLATE
ELECTIONS SENATOR RAZA. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT TODAY I AM
PRESENTING ASSEMBLY BILL FORTY
NINE THE CALIFORNIA VOTER
PROTECTION ACT OF TWENTY
NINETEEN ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SABRINA CERVANTES. IN A
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY LIKE
OURS NOTHING IS MORE
FUNDAMENTAL THAN PROTECTING AND
PROMOTING THE RIGHT TO VOTE.
OUR STATE ELECTION LAWS OF
EMBODY THIS BY MAKING VOTING BY
MAIL EASIER MORE ACCESSIBLE AS
A RESULT MORE MORE CALIFORNIA
VOTERS ARE CHOOSING TO EXERCISE
OUR RIGHT TO VOTE BY MAIL. IN
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN MID TERM
ELECTIONS MORE THAN 65% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS USED VOTE BY
MAIL BALLOTS IT IS IMPERATIVE
IMPERATIVE THAT OUR STATE LAWS
REFLECT IS GROWING REALITY.
HOWEVER SADLY DURING THOSE SAME
MID TERMS IT BECAME EVIDENT
THAT THERE ARE STILL FLAWS IN
OUR SYSTEM THAT MUST BE FIXED.
IN THE CALIFORNIA VOTER
PROTECTION ACT WILL HELP FIX
THIS IN TWO WAYS RESTORE
REQUIRE COUNTY REGISTRARS TO
COMPLETE THE DISTRIBUTION OF
MAIL BALLOTS TO EARLY WELL BY
E-MAIL REGISTRANTS WITHIN FIVE
DAYS OF WHEN THEY BEGAN BEGIN
TO SEND BALLOTS OUT. SECOND THE
BILL CLARIFIES THAT REGISTRARS
WILL START SENDING OUT MAIL
BALLOTS NO LATER THAN TWENTY
NINE DAYS. CURRENTLY TWENTY
NINE DAYS IS EXISTING THRESHOLD
FOR WHEN BALLOTS I TO BE SENT
THIS ADDED FLEXIBILITY WILL OUT
COUNTY REGISTRARS TO SEND THE
MAIL BALLOTS OUT EARLIER. THAN
TWENTY DIED DAYS IF THEY WANT
THIS WILL HELP INSURE THAT
VOTERS RECEIVE THEIR BALLOTS ON
TIME THAT WAY THEY CAN HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO PROPERLY
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHT TO VOTE.
INCLUDING DOING SUFFICIENT
RESEARCH RESEARCH COLLEAGUES I
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE THANK
YOU. FOR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THING MAN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BATES. BILL. BATES I
BILL AYE GORGEOUS I BRADFORD
AYE CABALLERO AYE AYE CHIANG BY
DELHI. DODD I DORADO. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG BY
HILL AYE HUESO. HIGHER TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I'M
ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL. HI MONNING
I'M MORE LUCK MORALE. NIELSEN.
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY STERN AYE
STONE NO BURKE. OUR CASKEY I
WINNER BY WILK BY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS. DALY
GROVE MORE LOCK LIKE I RAIL NO
NIELSEN. ICE THIRTY THREE NO
THREE THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO FORTY TWO.
SENATOR PORTANTINO. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN TEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO RENT INCREASES
SENATOR PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT A. B.
ALIVE AND TEN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACCORDING TO THE STATE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIA RENT IS
APPROXIMATELY 50% HIGHER THAN
THE REST OF THE COUNTRY RAINY
INCREASES IN SIGNIFICANT
NUMBERS AND FREQUENCY CAN
CREATE SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL
PRESSURE EVEN FOR THE MOST
ECONOMICALLY FORTUNATE
HOUSEHOLDS. IN MY DISTRICT IT
IS NOT UNCOMMON TO SEE RAINY
INCREASES OF 2230% OR EVEN
HIGHER AB ELEVEN TEN WOULD
EXTEND THE NOTICE PERIOD
REQUIRED FOR A LANDLORD TO POSE
IMPOSE A RENT INCREASE OF MORE
THAN 10% ON A TENANT FROM SIXTY
DAYS TO NINETY DAYS IN ADDITION
RENT INCREASES FOR THE PURPOSE
OF NOTICING WILL BE CALCULATED
ON A CUMULATIVE BASIS FOR THE
PREVIOUS TWELVE MONTHS THE
CURRENT THE CURRENT REQUIREMENT
IN LAW OF THIRTY DAY NOTICE FOR
PROPOSE RUNNING CREASES OF 10%
OR LESS. REMAIN UNCHANGED AB
ELEVEN TEN IS SPONSORED BY THE
CITY ONE AND IS SUPPORTED BY
THE LEAGUE CALIFORNIA CITIES
CITY OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AB ELEVEN TEN HAS
RECEIVED OPPOSITION AND FINING
ALTERNATE HOUSING TAKES TIME
RESOURCES AND IS DESTRUCTIVE TO
PEOPLE'S LIVES THIS EXTENSION
OF THE TIMELINE WILL BENEFIT
THOSE TENANTS AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SAYING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I ATKINS.
EIGHT NOBEL AYE BURGESS NO
BRADFORD I COME A GYRO I CHIANG.
DELHI DODD I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO. HIGHER TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL AYE MONNING
AYE MOORLACH NO MORALE NO
NIELSEN NO PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH. RATHER RUBIO I
SKINNER. BY STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR KELSEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS CHIANG NO
DALY. GROWTH. ICE TWENTY EIGHT
KNOWS NINE THE MEASURE PASSES
pITEM NUMBER TWO FORTY THREE
SENATOR JONES. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
NINETY SIX BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AN ACT RELATED TO MOTOR
VEHICLES SENATOR JONES THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE
NINETY SIX ON BEHALF OF MR
GRAYSON THIS BILL ENSURES
GREATER CONSUMER PROTECTION BY
ALLOWING CONSUMERS TO
ELECTRONICALLY AUTHORIZED CAR
REPAIRS AND BY UPDATING NOTICE
REQUIREMENTS FOR SERVICE
BULLETINS. CURRENT LAW IS
UNCLEAR AS TO WHETHER OR NOT
CONSUMERS CAN ELECTRONICALLY
AUTHORIZED A NEW CAR DEALER TO
WORK ON RECALL REPAIRS THIS
BILL UPDATES THE CALIFORNIA
UNIFORM ELECTRONIC TRANSACTION
ACT. TO ENSURE THIS ELECTRONIC
AUTHORIZATION AUTHORIZATION FOR
RECALL REPAIRS IS ALLOWED I
POLITELY AND SOMEBODY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE ON A. B. FIVE NINETY
SIX. IS THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SAYING IT
NINE THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL VOTE IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING
NONE ICE THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO FORTY
FOUR SENATOR HER TITLE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN NO ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY AN ACT
RELATING TO CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS REYES TO PRESENT AB
THIRTEEN ZERO ONE RELATED TO
PRIVATE ADOPTION FUNDING. THE
PRIVATE AGENCY ADOPTION
REIMBURSEMENT PROGRAM WAS
CREATED IN NINETEEN SEVEN
SEVENTY FOUR TO HELP
INCENTIVIZE PRIVATE ADOPTION
FOR CHILDREN WHO WOULD
OTHERWISE REMAIN IN FOSTER CARE.
SINCE THE PROGRAM'S CREATION AS
A STATE WE HAVE SEEN MAJOR
CHANGES WITH THE TWO THOUSAND
ELEVEN REALIGNMENT AND THE
CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORM CHILD
WELFARE. AB THIRTEEN ZERO ONE
RESTRUCTURES THE P. A. A. R. P.
PROGRAM TO HELP CONTAIN COST TO
THE COUNTIES WHILE AT THE SAME
TIME PRESERVING THIS MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING. MECHANISM FOR
PRIVATE ADOPTION AGENCIES WHO
DO THE CRITICAL WORK A FINING
PERMANENT FAMILY PLACEMENTS FOR
CHILDREN IN NEED. UNDER THE
BILL COUNTIES WILL TAKE ON THE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR COMPENSATED
ADOPTION AGENCIES FOR THEIR
OTHERWISE AND REIMBURSE COST
AND FINDING A PLACE IN A CHILD
WITH THE FAMILY WHILE SHIFTING
SOME OF THE FUNDING FROM THE
STATE DOWN TO THE CUNTY LEVEL.
THIS WILL ALSO GIVE THE
COUNTIES A PROVIDERS MORE
FREEDOM FOR REIMBURSEMENT COST
FOR OTHER ACTIVITIES.
EMPLACEMENTS AND NOT JUST THE
LIMITED ADOPTION COST I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. OR ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. THING MAN
THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR YOU
MAY UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION. SEEING
NONE THE MEASURE PASSES ICE
THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO. I'M SORRY
ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO JUST
CHECKING TO SEE IF YOU'RE AWAKE
MOVING ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
FORTY FIVE. SENATOR PAN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ A SOME OF
THE NINE FORTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY AND ACT REALLY
INTO LOCAL GOVERNMENT CENTER
PAN THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT CENTERS OUR
RIGHTS PERCENT EIGHTY NINE
FORTY FIVE BY SUMMER MCCARTY A
MEASURE TO ALLOW LOCAL AGENCIES
THE INCREASED AMOUNT OF SURPLUS
FUNDS THEY MAY INVEST IN SECURE
FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS CALLED
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS. THIS BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE THAT LOCAL
AGENCIES DO THIS BUT PROVIDES
THIS AS AN OPTION AND ONLY THAT
MAKES FINANCIAL SENSE FOR THEM
THESE DEPOSITS ARE FDIC INSURED
LIQUID ARE NO RISK CALIFORNIA
THE ONLY STATE IN THE COUNTRY
WHICH HAS A CAP ON RECIPROCAL
DEPOSITS. RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS
ARE OFTEN MADE WITH SMALLER
COMMUNITY BANKS AND CREDIT
UNIONS THESE LOCAL FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS ARE GOOD EMPLOYERS
IN OUR COMMUNITY PROVIDES
FINANCIAL OPPORTUNITIES
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE OFTEN
TURNED AWAY BY THE BIG BANKS
INCREASING THIS CAP. MEANS THAT
THESE COMMUNITY BANKS WILL HAVE
MORE ABILITY GIVE OUT CREDIT
FOR THINGS LIKE SMALL BUSINESS
LOANS THEY HAVE A DIRECT
MULTIPLIER EFFECT ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES RECENT AMENDMENTS
HAVE REMOVED ALL OUT. FORM.
OPPOSITION I SUSPECT WE ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. SENATOR MOORLACH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT QUESTION
FOR THE AUTHOR. YOU PREPARED
ANSWERED YES I'M IT WILL BE
HEARD THIS AND GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE IT ALSO APPLIED TO
COUNTY TREASURER'S AND I WAS
HOPING THAT THAT COULD BE
CHANGED IT WAS AT ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS. I BELIEVE SO CAN
YOU REPEAT WHAT THE BENEFIT
THAT YOU'RE TYPES HE SAID IT
WAS HER. I'M SORRY THAT HE DOES
CAN YOU REPEAT THE PART OF THE
QUESTION THE QUESTION PART.
WELL THIS IS THIS IS GOING TO
CHANGE CODE SECTION FIFTY THREE
SIX A ONE. WHICH APPLIES TO
COUNTY TREASURER'S AS WELL AND
OKAY THIS THIS SHOULD REALLY
WORK MOST. APPROPRIATELY FOR
SMALL MUNICIPAL DISTRICTS NOT
FOR LARGER COUNTY SO I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED. ABOUT THIS
BILL BECAUSE IT'S A LITTLE
BROAD AND IT SINCE I COME FROM
A BACKGROUND WHERE. THE
LEGISLATURE MADE CHANGES TO
INVESTMENT POLICY OPPORTUNITIES
THAT CREATED. THE CIRCUMSTANCES
IN ORANGE COUNTY I GET A LITTLE
NERVOUS SIDE THAT'S- WHY I'M
I'M- ASKING THE QUESTION I
APOLOGIZE. BECAUSE OF THE
VOLUME OF BILLS AND ALL THE FUN
WERE HAPPEN IT'S HARD WELL READ
ALL THE AMENDMENTS BUT I WOULD
SAY CERTAINLY V. S. THE
AMENDMENTS HAVE TAKEN THE
OPPOSITION AWAY AYE. AYE
ESTIMATE I CANNOT. I DON'T KNOW
SPECIFICALLY THAT PARTICULAR
QUESTION WAS ADDRESSED THAT IF
THAT WAS ONE OF THE REASONS FOR
OPPOSITION I MENTIONED THAT IT
WAS. COULD NOT KEEP READING
THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SAYING
NINE. CENTER PAN YOU MAY
CONCLUDE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU YOU NEED.
MEMBERS THIS ITEM IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL THERE
IS AN OBJECTION WILL WILL DO A
ROLL CALL. MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE RECALL THE ROW ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. HI BILL BY
BURGESS AYE BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALY AYE
DODD AYE DORADO AYE GALGIANI.
GLAZER BY GONZALEZ. GROWTH I
HERTZBERG BY HILL AYE HUESO. I
TADO I JACKSON BY JONES I LEYVA
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. BY
MORNING I'M MORE LUCK. NO
MORALE HI NELSON. I PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBERG ABA CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS CHIANG HI.
GALGIANI HI GONZALEZ HI. FIVE
THIRTY EIGHT KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO FORTY SIX
SENATOR RUBIO ARE YOU PREPARED.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL SIX EIGHTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AN ACT
RELATING TO INDIAN CHILDREN.
CENTER RUBRIC RUBIO THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU UP
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I RISE TO
PRESENT AB SIX EIGHTY SIX THIS
BILL WILL PROTECT INDIAN
CHILDREN BY CONTINUING TO
CONFORM CALIFORNIA'S CHILD
WELFARE LAWS TO THE FEDERAL
INDIAN CHILD. WELFARE ACT I SEE
W. A. WAS ENACTED IN NINETEEN
SEVENTY EIGHT IN RESPONSE TO
THE WHOLE CELL REMOVAL OF
INDIAN CHILDREN FROM THEIR
PARENTS FAMILIES TRIBES AND
COMMUNITIES SINCE ITS PASSAGE
ICWA HAS PROVIDED IMPORTANT
RIGHTS. AND PROTECTIONS TO
NATIVE AMERICAN FAMILIES AB
SIXTY I'M SORRY SIX EIGHTY SIX
ENSURES THAT INDIAN TRIBES CAN
PARTICIPATE AND I SEE W. EIGHT
CASES BY AUTHORIZING ACCESS TO
TELEPHONIC OR OTHER ELECTRONIC
REMOTE ACCESS OPTIONS FOR COURT
APPEARANCES. IT ALSO INCREASES
ICWA COMPLIANCE BY CLARIFYING
PLACEMENT APPROVAL STANDARDS
FOR INDIAN CHILDREN THIS BILL
HAS NO OPPOSITION AND HAS
RECEIVED BROAD BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOU I WILL THANK YOU. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SEEING NONE THIS
ITEM IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION. SEEING. NINE THIRTY
NINE ICE THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON
TO ITEM TWO FORTY SEVEN.
SENATOR PORTANTINO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GONZALEZ AND
ACT RELATED STATE CLAIMS MAKING
A PRISONER FOR TO CLEARING
THEIR THROATS TAKE FACT MERELY
CENTER PORTANTINO THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
I MEMBERS AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
ONE IS AN URGENCY MEASURE THAT
WOULD APPROPRIATE EIGHT HUNDRED
AND THREE. MILLION DOLLARS TO
THE PARTMINER GENERAL SERVICE
FOR THE PAYMENT OF FIVE STATE
CLAIMS. EXCUSE ME I'M NOT SURE
ON THE DOLLAR AMOUNT. EIGHT
HUNDRED AND TWO DOLLARS AND
SIXTY CENTS FOR THE PAYMENT OF
THE FOLLOWING FIVE NOW THERE'S
SOME. I APOLOGIZE THIS HAMASAKI
MEANT. I HAD DOES PASS ON FILE
PLEASE OKAY. OKAY OKAY. HE RUNS.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE IT'S
CORRECT. NO PROBLEM CENTER
PORTANTINO. WE WILL PASS WELL
PAST THAT TEMPORARY WILL TAKE
UP ITEM NUMBER TWO THIRTY SEVEN.
TWO THIRTY SEVEN. WILL TAKE UP
ITEM NUMBER TWO THIRDS THIRTY
SEVEN SENATOR LEYVA MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TO NINETY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WOULD ENACT REALLY NAY
HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. CENTER
LEYVA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TO NINETY BELIEVE
IT OR NOT CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
UNSCRUPULOUS HEALTH CARE
PROVIDERS TO ENROLL PATIENTS IN
COMMERCIAL COVERAGE. HEY
INSURANCE PREMIUMS ON THEIR
BEHALF THEN BILL INSURERS
OUTRAGEOUS RATES THERE MANY
TIMES THE COST OF PROVIDING THE
ACTUAL CARE. THE LAW ALLOWS THE
SCHEME TO EXPLOIT PATIENTS EVEN
WHEN COMMERCIAL COVERAGE MAY
NOT BE IN THE PATIENT'S BEST
INTEREST IN THE END MANY
PATIENTS FIND THEMSELVES FACING
UNEXPECTED OUT OF POCKET COSTS.
AND DISRUPTIONS IN CARE JUST SO
THESE CORPORATIONS CAN MAKE IT
EASY BACK OR IN THE TYPICAL
CASE MANY MILLIONS OF BUCKS AND
WE ALL PAY THE PRICE FOR THIS
WHAT AB TWO NINETY WILL DO IS.
REMOVE THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
TO STEER PATIENTS ON TO
COMMERCIAL COVERAGE REQUIRED
THAT HEALTH PLANS EXCEPT THE
PREMIUM PAYMENTS AND COVER THE
ENROLLEE. CREATE PATIENT
BILLING PROTECTIONS SUCH AS A
PROHIBITION ON BALANCE BILLING
PREVENTING THE FINANCIALLY
INTERESTED ENTITY FROM CUTTING
OFF PAYMENTS MID YEAR AND
MAKING SURE THAT THE PATIENT
ISN'T STEERED INTO COVERAGE
THAT DOES NOT FIT THEIR NEEDS
WHAT AB TWO NINETY WILL NOT DO.
IT WILL NOT APPLY TO ANY
CURRENT AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND
RECIPIENT AS. STOP A KF FROM
PAIN PATIENTS HEALTH INSURANCE
COVERAGE IT WILL NOT CAUSE ANY
CURRENT DIALYSIS PATIENT TO
LOSE COVERAGE IT WILL NOT ALLOW
INSURANCE COMPANIES TO DROP AND
ROLL LEASE. THE MOST A RECENT
AMENDMENTS TO AB TOO MUCH
NINETY MAKE THE FOLLOWING
IMPORTANT CLARIFICATIONS. THESE
AMENDMENTS EXCEPT EXEMPT ALL
DIALYSIS PROVIDERS OTHER THAN
THE TWO WORST ACTORS.
GRANDFATHER ALL PATIENTS
CURRENTLY RECEIVING PREMIUM
ASSISTANCE FROM THE AMERICAN
KIDNEY FOUNDATION. DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION OF DIALYSIS
RELATED PROVISIONS INTO THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FOUNDATION GETS
A NEW OFFICE OF INSPECTOR
GENERAL OPINION THAT SHOWS AB
TWO NINETY WON'T CONFLICT WITH
THEIR SAFE HARBOR. MEMBERS
VOTING FOR THIS BILL WILL
PROTECT PATIENTS AND BRING DOWN
THE COST OF HEALTH CARE FOR
CONSTITUENTS IN YOUR DISTRICT
WHO ARE STRUGGLING TO AFFORD
THEIR PREMIUMS. IT IS TIME THAT
WE STOP THIS BLATANT
MANIPULATION OF THE MARKET AND
SCHEME THAT EXPLAINS PATIENTS.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ITEM. CENTER STONE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS A JUST
A CONTINUED ASSAULT ON
COMPANIES THAT ARE.
CAPITALISTIC AND MAKE MONEY.
HOW MANY OF YOU HAVE DIALYSIS
CLINICS IN YOUR COMMUNITIES
ESPECIALLY IN SOME OF YOUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES CALL A COMMON
MAY TAKE SOME OF THE DIALYSIS
CLINICS IN THE MORE URBAN AREAS
IN THE MORE RURAL AREAS BECAUSE
FRANKLY THERE'S NOT ENOUGH
PEOPLE THE NEED DIALYSIS AND
RURAL AREAS TO. JUSTIFY THE
INVESTMENT OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO NOT ONLY BUILD OUT
THESE FACILITIES BUT TO. STAFF
FROM. AB TWO NINETY WILL HARM
LOW INCOME DIALYSIS PAYS
PATIENTS SUPPORTERS DISPUTE
THAT BUT NOTHING IN THIS BILL
TAKES PATIENCE OUT OF HARM'S
WAY AS BAD THIS BILL ALSO IS A
RATE SENDING BILL. WENT LIKE
COMPANIES COMPETE. IF PASS A
BEAT TO NINETY NEGATES
PRIVATELY PRIVATELY NEGOTIATED
KRON CONTRACTS. AND THAT'S
PROBABLY WHY. THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF. CALIFORNIA.
DIALYSIS COUNCIL IS OPPOSED
ALAMEDA CONTRA COSTA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION AS OPPOSED
CALIFORNIA HISPANIC I'M A
CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION
IS. OPPOSE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IS OPPOSED A VERY
IMPORTANT ORGANIZATION OF MY
DISTRICT THE DESERT AIDS
PROJECT. IS OPPOSED. FOR
CERTAIN DIALYSIS PATIENTS IT
SAID IN THE STONE THAT THE
MEDICARE RATE AS THE
REIMBURSEMENT RATE THE MEDICARE
RATES A SO YOU'LL KNOW OFTEN
DOESN'T EVEN COVER THE ENTIRE
COST. OF GETTING A DIALYSIS
TREATMENT TO A BENEFICIARY.
THIS IS A PROBLEM FOR DIALYSIS
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
GROWTH RATE OVER THE NEXT TEN
YEARS. IS 5% OF WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THE CLAMPS. ON THE ABILITY
OF DIALYSIS CENTERS CENTERS TO.
COVER THE COSTS AND YES I KNOW
IT'S A BAD WORD AROUND HERE
MAKE A PROFIT. THEN YOU'RE JUST
NOT GOING TO SEE THE GROWTH OF
DIALYSIS ANDERSON IN THE IN THE
HOUSE CITY CALIFORNIA
ESPECIALLY IN THE RURAL AREAS
WHERE. FRANKLY I HAVE A LOT OF
POVERTY. AND. WE'VE ALL SEEN
WITH OUR CHILDHOOD OBESITY
PROBLEM OUR GROWTH IN TYPE ONE
DIABETES. A ONE OF A NUMBER ONE
CAUSES OF KIDNEY FAILURE OR
KIDNEY IS THAT ARE BEGINNING TO
FAIL IS TYPE TWO DIABETES SO
WE'RE SEEING A GROWTH IN THE
NEED AND YET WE WANT TO PUT A
CAP ON THE GROWTH OF DIALYSIS
CENTERS BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
ALLOWING THEM TO RECOUP. THEIR
COSTS AND MY FRIENDS IF THEY
DON'T. THERE ARE NUMBER OF AT
THE NOT ALLOWED TO RECOUP THEIR
COSTS WE'RE NOT GOING TO BUILD
THE CENTERS AND I'M CONCERNED
THAT THAT'S GOING TO REDUCE THE
ACCESSIBILITY. OF NEW DIALYSIS
PATIENTS THAT NEED A PLACE TO
GO. WHERE THEY HAVE TO
SOMETIMES GO FOUR TIMES A WEEK
YEAH AND SIT FOR HOURS ON END.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU EVER.
WITNESSED A DIALYSIS PATIENT
AFTER THEY'VE GONE THROUGH THE
TREATMENT BUT THEY'RE EXTREMELY
EXHAUSTED TAKE SOME HOURS TO
RECOVER. BUT IF THEY DON'T DO-DIALYSIS THEY LOSE THEIR LIVES.
SO MY FRIENDS BY SUPPORTING AB
TWO NINETY PATIENTS ARE GOING
TO LOSE TAXPAYERS ARE GOING TO
LOSE AND CERTAINLY SO MANY
PEOPLE THAT WE SAW DURING THE
HEALTH COMMITTEE FROM ALL WALKS
OF LIFE THE CLAIM THAT WE WILL
BE TAKING AWAY THIS VITAL
SERVICE OF THEM. COULD BE PUT
IN HARM'S WAY. LET'S MAKE SURE
THAT WE HAVE A GOOD DIALYSIS
INFRASTRUCTURE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. WE SEE A LOT OF
ATTACKS ON THE HEALTH CENTER
DIALYSIS CENTERS A LOT OF WHICH
IS COME FROM LABOR. AGAIN YOU
KNOW WE HAVE TO HAVE WHAT'S
CALLED A LABOR CAUCUS HERE IN
THIS IN THE STATE SENATE A
LABOR CAUCUS AND SO WE HAVE
THESE BILLS THAT ARE SHUT DOWN
OUR THROATS BY LABOR RELEASE WE
CAN. POINT TO AN ORGANIZATION
THAT IS TELLING US WHAT WE
SHOULD DO AND WE SEE THIS TIME
AND TIME AGAIN HERE IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR. SO
WHO YOU GONNA SUPPORT EVEN
SUPPORT THE LABOR UNIONSON
THIS ONE ARE YOU GONNA SUPPORT
FOR PATIENTS IN THE DIALYSIS
ESPECIALLY POOR PATIENTS YOUR
VOTE IN AB TWO NINETY WAS
CERTAIN INDICATE THAT I KNOW
I'M VOTING I VOTING NO ONE AB
TWO NINETY. BETTER NIELSEN.
THAT A PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN THE SENATE I AS WELL
URGENT NO VOTE. THERE HAVE BEEN
PROBLEMATIC LAST MINUTE
AMENDMENTS SOMETIMES WE CAN GET
AROUND THOSE SOMETIMES WE CAN'T.
BUT THE OPPOSITION IS
INSTRUCTIVE PARTICULARLY TO ONE
WHO REPRESENTS A RURAL AREA AND
HAS DEALT EXTENSIVELY WITH. THE
PAUCITY OF CLINICS AVAILABLE TO
THE FOLKS THAT WE SERVE IN OUR
RURAL AREAS. AND I GATHER
THAT'S IN PART WHY THE KIDNEY
FUND. AS CONCERNED ABOUT THIS.
THEY NOTE THAT THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED LOW INCOME INDIVIDUALS
WILL NOT NOW BE ABLE TO BE
SERVED. 68% OF THESE PATIENTS
THAT THEY A SISTER AFRICAN
AMERICAN LATINO OR ASIAN. WITH
AN AVERAGE INCOME OF ONLY
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR.
THAT SOUNDS A LOT LIKE
POPULATIONS THAT THOSE OF US
WHO REPRESENT RURAL AREAS HAVE
GOT TO CONTEND WITH. WHAT ARE
NOT WHAT IS NOT ANSWERED THEN
IS WHAT WILL THEN HAPPEN. TO
THEIR HEALTHCARE. IF THERE IS
NOT AN SENATE. AND COMPANIES
THAT DO PROVIDE THEY HAVE TO
HAVE SOME INCENTIVE AS MY-
COLLEAGUE HAS JUST MENTIONED.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY IT'S C.
CONSTRAINING OF THE OPPORTUNITY
OF OUR DIALYSIS PATIENTS. TO
HAVE THAT ACCESS. AND I AM VERY
KEENLY HALL TO KEENLY AWARE.
FOR MORE OF PLOY A THAT I SPENT
SO MUCH TIME WITH OVER THE LAST
MANY YEARS. WHO DID HAVE TO
SUFFER THE RIGORS. THE RIGORS
OF THAT TREATMENT. EVERY WEEK
SIMPLY TO STAY ALIVE. AND THE
AMOUNT OF ENERGY IT TOOK HIM TO
RECOVER. FROM THE RIGORS OF
THAT DIALYSIS. WHEN YOU'RE
TRIFLING OR AFFECTING THE
HEALTH OF INDIVIDUALS 2 DEGREES
IN THAT THIS WILL. IT IS
INCUMBENT ON US TO BE VERY VERY
CAREFUL. ABOUT KNOWING. THE
LONG TERM CONSEQUENCES AS WELL
AS THE SHORT TERM CONSEQUENCES
I URGE A NO VOTE. SENATOR
MITCHELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES I'M
A MEMBER OF HEALTH COMMITTEE
AND WE HAD A LONG FASTENING
DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS BILL AND
LET ME BE CLEAR ABOUT THE BILL
THAT'S BEFORE US TODAY IT. IS A
COMPROMISE. I WOULD LOTS OF
ENGAGEMENT FROM LEADERSHIP WITH
THE COMMON GOAL OF PROTECTING
PATIENTS. I THINK THE MILLIONS
THAT EITHER THE AMERICAN KIDNEY
FINE OR WHOEVER SPENT ON BUYING
COMMERCIAL TIME ON FOR THOSE
COMMERCIALS WITH OFF IN THE
LAST MONTH WERE HORRIBLY
MISLEADING. AND I AM SADDENED
OF PEOPLE BOUGHT THE RHETORIC.
ON THE BILL OF GOODS THEY WERE
SOLD. I FELT THAT I CONTINUE TO
FOLLOW MY COLLEAGUE ON THIS
FLOOR WHO YOU KNOW CONTINUES TO
CLAIM THAT WE ARE BOUGHT AND
SOLD BY AN ENTITY AND I HAVE TO
SAY ONCE AGAIN PARTICULARLY
AFTER THE RESOLUTION TALK ABOUT
SIXTY NINETEEN THAT I'M NOT FOR
SALE. AND I HAVE TO GET MY CUP
FOR SADDAM TO FOLLOW THAT
ANYMORE. THE AMERICAN KIDNEY
FUNDS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WHICH STRUCK ME AS A NON PROFIT
EXECUTIVE. PRIOR TO BECOMING
ELECTED I WAS STRUCK AT THE
PERCENTAGE OF THIS NONPROFIT
FUNDING THAT COMES FROM. TO
DONORS. IN NONPROFIT ACCOUNTING
IRS RULES ARE VERY PARTICULAR
ABOUT THE SOURCE OF FUNDING FOR
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND YOU
CAN'T HAVE ALL YOUR CA FUNDING
COMING FROM A SINGLE SOURCE
BECAUSE THE IN INFERENCE IS
THAT THAT IS SIMPLY A WAY IN
WHICH THE- THE PRIVATE
ORGANIZATION IS GETTING A TAX
WRITE OFF. ON BY HAVING THE
NONPROFIT QUOTE UNQUOTE THAT
THEY HAVE COMPLETE ON
JURISDICTION OVER AND SO THAT
WAS AN ISSUE THAT WE BROUGHT UP
REPEATEDLY DURING THE COMMITTEE
IT WAS A CONCERN. SEPARATE FROM
WHAT THE AMERICAN CAN BE FUN
CLAIM THEY WERE DOING IT WAS
REALLY WHETHER OR NOT THEY WERE
A TRUE INDEPENDENT NOT FOR
PROFIT ORGANIZATION. NOT BEING
STEERED CALL STEERAGE NONPROFIT
ACCOUNTING. LOOK IT UP. ARMED
WITH 82% OF THEIR FUNDS COMING
FROM THE LARGEST I OFFICE
COMPANIES IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT
WAS A PROBLEM IN TERMS OF
REALLY DETERMINE WHETHER THEY
WERE INDEPENDENT. NUMBER TWO
BALANCE BILLING. IS AN ISSUE
THAT WE HAVE TO GUARD AGAINST
ON THE REGULAR. IT'S NOT ABOUT
NOT ALLOWING A PRIVATE ENTITIES
TO EARN PROFIT. IT'S WHO
THEY'RE GOING TO EARN THE
PROFIT ON THE BACKS OF AND
MAKING SURE THAT THESE
VULNERABLE PATIENTS. WHO DO
RELY ON THEIR ABILITY TO DIAL
SITES FREQUENTLY BUT IT'S NOT
BALANCED ON THEIR BACK. THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FUND AS I
RECALL DIDN'T OPERATE DIALYSIS
CLINICS INDEPENDENTLY SO IT'S
NOT ABOUT THE LIMITATION OF
CLINICS THAT ANOTHER
MISSTATEMENT. IT'S ABOUT
BALANCE BILLING AND WHO COVERS
THE COST TO GO ABOVE AND BEYOND
WHAT THEIR INSURANCE ALREADY
COVERS. AND SO HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL WILL BE REQUIRED TO COVER
PATIENTS WHOSE PREMIUMS HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN PID BY THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FUN OR SOMEONE
ORGANIZATIONS. FOR AWHILE SAY
IT AGAIN. THE ACTORS ON THOSE
TV COMMERCIALS THE DIALYSIS
PATIENTS THAT WE SAW WHO TOOK
THEIR TIME TO COME UP HERE WILL
NOT LOSE. A MINUTE. OF THEIR
OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE DIALYSIS
SERVICES. BECAUSE HEALTH
INSURANCE COMPANIES ARE
REQUIRED TO COVER THAT EXPENSE.
YOU KNOW A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO
FOR MEDI CAL WHEN WE HAD TO CUT
MEDI CAL WE COULDN'T GET
AGREEMENT ON THE BUDGET WHEN
THE BUDGET REQUIRE TWO THIRDS
VOTE. THE LEGISLATURE CUT MEDI
CAL SERVICES. WE LIMITED WHAT
MEDI CAL PATIENTS THAN THE
FREQUENCY OF THE VISIT A MEDI
CAL PATIENTS AT HALF TO SEVEN
TIMES PER MONTH. THAT INCLUDED
DIALYSIS PATIENTS. AND SO IN
OUR INABILITY TO GET A BUDGET
THROUGH BOTH HOUSES WE
COMPROMISE THE LIVES OF
DIALYSIS PATIENTS IN A VERY
DIRECT WAY THOSE WHO RECEIVE
MEDICARE HOW QUICKLY WE FORGET
THIS BILL IS AN IMPROVEMENT OF
STATUS QUO. IT ELIMINATES
BALANCE BILLING WHICH IS A BAD
THING FOR THE PUBLIC SECTOR FOR
PATIENTS AND AGAIN IT WILL
REQUIRE THE HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES PROVIDE THE COVERAGE
FOR ALL OF THOSE REASONS I'LL
BE VOTING HI ON AB TWENTY
NINETY TO NINETY. SENATOR GROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE IN OPPOSITION OF AB TWO
NINETY THIS BILL WAS
SIGNIFICANTLY AMENDED AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
WE'RE TOLD THAT THE MINUTES
WERE MADE BETTER IN IT WOULD
PROTECT THE THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED PATIENTS THAT WE HAVE
MOSTLY FOR MINORITY MAJORITY
DISTRICTS AND THE POOR THEY
CAN'T AFFORD SOME OF THE
BENEFITS THAT COME WITH
DIALYSIS TREATMENT AT IT
DOESN'T DO THAT IT ACTUALLY
COME LOOSE THE SITUATION EVEN
MORE. AND YOU KNOW WHEN I HEAR
MY COLLEAGUES SAY THAT NO ONE'S
GONNA LOSE THEIR BENEFITS AND
THE AMERICAN CAN DEFEND IS
GOING TO STAY IN CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S JUST NOT TRUE IF YOU
OPERATE ANY NONPROFIT OR A
BUSINESS. AND JUST A SMALL
PERCENTAGE OF YOUR ASSETS ARE
IN CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA IS
CREATING SOMETHING THAT COULD
CAUSE YOU. TO LOSE YOUR ENTIRE
NATIONAL STATUS AS AN
ORGANIZATION THEN YOU JUST.
TAKE A DEEP BREATH AND CUT IT
LOOSE AND SO THAT'S EXACTLY
WHAT THE AMERICAN CAN DEFEND IS
GOING TO DO. YES INSURANCE
COMPANIES ARE REQUIRED TO COVER
THIS AND HOPEFULLY PEOPLE THAT
ARE WAITING ON DIALYSIS. THAT
ARE BEING COVERED UNDER THE
AMERICAN KIDNEY FIND NOW WILL
SURVIVE THE THREE TO SIX MONTHS
PROCESS TO GET. THEIR INSURANCE
TO APPROVE IT AND THINGS WILL
GO SMOOTHLY BUT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS THAT VOTING FOR THIS BILL
WILL STOP. THE AMERICAN KIDNEY
FUND FROM OPERATING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND IT'S
NOT A THREAT IT'S JUST LOOKING
AT IT FROM A BUSINESS
PERSPECTIVE AND SAYING YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO LOOK OUT FOR THE
OTHER FORTY NINE STATES AND THE
PEOPLE THAT WE SERVE. AND IF
THIS IS GOING TO CAUSE A
PROBLEM IN CALIFORNIA THEN WE
WILL JUST STEM. CUT LOOSE AND I
HAVE REALLY GREAT CONCERNS
BECAUSE THERE ARE THIRTY SEVEN
HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT NEED THIS
SERVICE IN ORDER TO STAY ALIVE.
IF YOU HAVE NOT VISITED A
DIALYSIS CENTER IN YOUR
DISTRICT I WOULD ASK YOU TO DO
THAT. WHEN I WAS ASKED TO GO I
REALLY DIDN'T WANT TO GO
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO SEE.
WHAT I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA SEE
AND WHEN I WENT INTO THE
DIALYSIS CENTER IT WASN'T
ANYTHING LIKE I THOUGHT. THEY
WERE YOUNG PEOPLE. THEY WERE
TEENAGERS THERE WERE MADE IT
MIDDLE AGED INDIVIDUALS THERE
WERE MOMS THERE WERE MORE
VETERANS. THEY WERE JUST PEOPLE
TRYING TO STAY ALIVE IN WHEN
THEY EAT SOMETHING THEY HAVE TO
GO IN TWO OR THREE TIMES A WEEK
FOR SEVERAL HOURS A DAY. AND
THE STAFF IS REALLY FRIENDLY
AND I JUST THINK THAT THAT TIME
ATTACKING THIS PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY. CAUSES THE
DETRIMENTAL EFFECTS TO OUR-
CONSTITUENTS. AND I REALLY DO
BELIEVE WHAT THE AMERICAN CAN
DEFEND SAYS. THAT THEY WILL CUT
THEIR LOSSES IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE WILL HAVE. AN INTERRUPTION
OF SERVICE AND POSSIBLY NOT
HAVE SERVICE. FOR INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DESPERATELY IN NEED OF
THIS SERVICE. AND I THINK WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT OUR
CONSTITUENTS. I'M SURE ONE OF
THOSE THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED
PEOPLE LIVES IN MY DISTRICT.
AND THE REST OF THEM ROOM
SOMEONE LIVING YOUR DISTRICT
AND I WOULD JUST ASK THAT YOU
VOTE NO ON THIS BILL. IS THERE
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE SENATOR
LEYVA YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU
FOR THE ROBUST A CONVERSATION
AND DEBATE IF SOME OF IT IS NOT
ACCURATE. I'M TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT WHERE I WANT TO START WITH
ALL OF THE INACCURACIES I THINK
THE FIRST THING THAT I WANT TO
START WITH IS TO THE SENATOR IN
TEMECULA WONDERING WHY HE'S SO
AFRAID OF UNIONS AND SO AFRAID
OF LABOR. AND FOR MYSELF AS
SOMEONE WHO SPENT THIRTY YEARS
AS EITHER A UNION MEMBER AS
SOMEONE WHO RAN MY OWN LOCAL
UNION WHO IS THE PRESENT THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
LABOR DOESN'T SUPPORT ME I AM
LABOR SO I TAKE OFFENSE WHEN
YOU SAY THAT LABOR OWNS ANY OF
US I AM LABOR. OUR I DON'T SEE
HOW PATIENTS ARE PUT IN IN
HARM'S WAY IN THIS BILL NO ONE
IS GOING TO LOSE COVERAGE BUT
THAT'S A FEAR TALK TALKING
POINT RIGHT WE WANT TO SCARE
PEOPLE. THAT'S WHAT THE TWO
BIGGEST COMPANIES OF DIALYSIS
HAVE DONE IS THERE RUNNING
THESE COMMERCIALS AS MY
COLLEAGUE FROM LA ALLUDED TO
AND THEY'RE SCARING PEOPLE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT THEM BEING
ABLE TO RECOUP THEIR COSTS THIS
IS ABOUT THE MAKING MILLIONS
AND MILLIONS IN PROFITS OFF THE
BACKS OF PEOPLE WHO ARE SICK
AND YES MIGHT DIE IF THEY DON'T
HAVE DIALYSIS. WE TALK ABOUT
WORLD IN POOR AREAS SOME OF YOU
MAY NOT KNOW THAT THE AUTHOR OF
THIS BILL IS IN ONE OF THE
POOREST AND MOST RURAL AREAS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA I DON'T
THINK HE WOULD DO ANYTHING AS A
DOCTOR. TO HARM THOSE PEOPLE.
AND SHAME ON THE AMERICAN
KIDNEY FOUNDATION. IF THEY'RE
GOING TO LEAVE AND THEY'RE NOT
GOING TO TAKE CARE OF THE
PATIENTS THAT THEY ARE
SUPPOSEDLY. SO THEY CARE SO
MUCH ABOUT. I THINK THAT. I
DON'T MIND PEOPLE MAKE A PROFIT
I DON'T THINK ANY OF US DO I
THINK WHAT WE DON'T LIKE IS
THAT WHEN THEY POLITICIZE THIS
ISSUE AND THEY PUT HATE PROFITS
BEFORE PATIENTS. AB TWO NINETY.
IS A BILL MANY OF YOU KNOW I
CARRIED THIS BILL ASHER IS A
BETTER BILL THAN THE BILL THAT
I CARRIED IT OFFERS MORE
PROTECTIONS FOR EVERYONE.
THERE'S NO REASON TO VOTE NO ON
THIS BILL. NO ONE IS GOING OUT
OF BUSINESS NO PATIENTS ARE NOT
GOING TO RECEIVE DIALYSIS BUT
IT IS GOING TO PUT SOME PEOPLE
IN CHECK. FOR MAKING MILLIONS
OF DOLLARS OFF OF PEOPLE'S
ILLNESS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN I ARCHULETA. ATKINS. HI
BATES NOBEL I BURGESS NO
BRADFORD AYE CAMBIADO I CHIANG
NO DALY. DODD. DORADO I
GALGIANI NO GLAZER NO GONZALEZ
I GROWTH NO HERTZBERG. HILL NO
WAY SO. FOR TITLE NO JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA I. AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. NO. NIELSEN NO PAN HI.
TINO I ROTH. RUBIO. SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE NO BURKE. LIKE
OWSKI I WIENER AYE WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ARCHULETA. DALLY HI DODD.
HERTZBERG BY. HUESO ROTH RUBIO
NUMBER. ICE TWENTY ONE KNOWS
THIRTEEN MEASURE PASSES SENATOR
PORTANTINO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
RETURN TO FILE ITEM TWO FORTY
SEVEN. YES MADAM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBERS I HAVE MY MATH GLASSES
ON NOW. I RIGHTS TO
REPRESENTATION MR PART I'M
SORRY DINNER IF I COULD HAVE IT
READY AGAIN SO EVERYBODY KNOWS
WERE AT A MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SOME OF THE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
ANACHRONISTIC CLAIMS MAKING
PROGRESS THERE FOR INCLUDING
THEIR SERVICE TAKE EFFECT
MERELY. NOW THE FLOORS YOUR
SENATOR PORTANTINO THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT A BE EIGHTEEN THIRTY
ONE WHICH IS AN URGENCY MEASURE
THAT WOULD APPROPRIATE EIGHT
HUNDRED AND THREE DOLLARS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES FOR THE PAYMENT OF
FIVE STATE CLAIMS ALL THESE
CLAIMS ARE THE FOR THE RE
ISSUANCE OF STATE CHECKS THAT
WERE NEVER CASH TO THE PARMA
FINANCE HAS APPROVED THE
PAYMENTS. OF THESE CLAIMS ALL
OF WHICH ARE VALID OBLIGATIONS
TO THE STATE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER PORTANTINO MEMBERS ARE
IS THERE ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING
THAT MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES.
HI BILL BY BURGESS. I BRADFORD.
AYE CABALLERO AYE CHIANG KAI
DELI I DONT. I'D RATHER I
GALGIANI. I GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. GROVE. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL. AYE HUESO. I OUR TITLE I
JACKSON I JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. I MONNING
AYE MOORLACH AYE MORRELL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER AYE
STERN AYE STONE. STONE. HI
HAMBURG IA CATHY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK HI. THIS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN HI. GROWTH. RUBIO
RUBIO AYE. ICE THIRTY NINE NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MAJOR
MAJOR MAJOR HOUSES SENATOR WHAT
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE Q.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THE
SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL
SEVEN PM THIS EVENING ALL
MEMBERS ARE EXPECT TO BE BACK
ON THIS FLOOR PROMPTLY AT SEVEN
IN IF YOU'RE ALL WELL BEHAVED
HOPEFULLY WE WILL WE'LL BE OUT
HERE BY NINE PM TONIGHT. SO
WE'LL SEE ALL BACK HERE AT
SEVEN THANK YOU THANK YOU
CENTER WILL MEMBERS WILL SEE
YOU BACK ON THE FLOOR AT SEVEN
PM
. WELCOME BACK MEMBERS WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
TO FORTY NINE SENATOR NUMBER
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY NINE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW AN
ACT RELATING TO TRAFFIC SAFETY
SENATOR UMBERG. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND SEVERAL MEMBERS
THAT ARE HERE. I HAVE BEFORE
YOU AB SEVEN FIFTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW WHICH
REQUIRES CALTRANS UPDATE THEIR
SAFETY GUIDELINES WITH POSITIVE
PROTECTION BARRIERS THAT WILL
PROTECT CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
FROM ON COMING TRAFFIC WITH
FUNDING AVAILABLE FROM SB ONE
CALIFORNIA WILL SEE INCREASED
ROLE WORKING COMING YEARS ARE
DRIVE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER OF
BURKE MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA ATKINS. HI BATES. L.
GORGEOUS EFFORT CABALLERO
CHIANG DALY DODD. HI DORADO.
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH. HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO TADO I JACKSON. BY JONES
HI LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE BY
MITCHELL HI MONNING. I'M MORE
LARK MORRELL. NIELSEN AYE PAN
HI CONTINUE I ROTH I RUBIO.
SKINNER. STERN BY STONE HI
NUMBER TYLER CASKEY I WINNER.
WILK HI. SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
AS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
TWO FIFTY SENATOR RUBIO NOT AT
HER DESK FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
ONE SENATOR CABALLERO NOT AT
TWO SENATOR HERTZBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE FOURTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MELENDEZ AND
ACT REALLY INTO SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES CENTER HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS OF THIS
MEASURE PROVIDES THAT IF THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT OFFERS
INTERSCHOLASTIC ATHLETIC
PROGRAMS THEY MUST HAVE SOMEONE
WHO IS CPR CERTIFIED AT SUCH
EVENTS AT ALL TIMES IT ALSO
REQUIRES CPR TRAINING TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE IN ALL SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING TEACHERS
ADMINISTRATORS AND OFFICE
ASSISTANCE I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS AYE BATES AYE BILL BY
BURGESS AYE BRADFORD AYE
CAMBIADO. CHIANG. DALY AYE DODD
AYE THE RUSSELL GALGIANI GLAZER
AYE GONZALEZ BY GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
HI TITLE I JACKSON HI JONES BY
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL.
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK I'M REAL.
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO. SKINNER
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR
CASKEY I WINNER. WILK HI
SENATOR MOVES A CALL WE'RE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
THREE SENATOR MANI. PASS ON
FILE TWO FIFTY FOUR PASS ON
FILE TWO FIFTY FIVE SENATOR
NIELSEN VERY GOOD MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL ELEVEN TWENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAO AND ACT
REALLY INTO PRIVACY SENATOR
NIELSEN LADY ASIAN GENERAL THE
SENATE. ASSEMBLYMAN CHAU BILL.
I DON'T WANT TO SAY PLEDGES
LOOPHOLE BUT SOMETHING THAT HAS
EVOLVED VERY QUICKLY. AND TO A
DEGREE DANGEROUSLY WHICH IS
WHAT THIS BILL RELATED TO
ELECTRONIC DEVICES OR
PARTICULARLY DRAWL. HELP NOW
ALLOWED THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
INDIVIDUAL PRIVACY TO BE
INVADED BY THESE ELECTRONIC
MEETS AGAIN PROTECTING THE DRAW.
THE DRONE NOW THERE IS
STATUTORY PROHIBITION OF OR
UTILIZING A DRONE AROUND A
CORRECTIONAL FACILITY. AROUND
IN AREAS WHERE THEY WOULD BE
RESPONDING HOW ARE THE
EMERGENCY THAT WOULD INTERFERE
WITH THE EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
BUT FOR THE INDIVIDUAL THEIR
PRIVACY IS NOT PROTECTED FROM
THE INTERVENTION. OF DRONES
RATHER SUCH ELECTRONIC DEVICES.
THERE ARE NO OF STATUTES. THAT
APPLICABLE A MAKE THIS ILLEGAL.
THIS PROTECTS THE VICTIMS NOW
THEN FROM THIS TECHNOLOGY. BY
ADDING THIS DRONE. OUR
ELECTRONIC DEVICE TO THE LIST
OF INSTRUMENTS WHICH MAY NOT BE
USED. TO SURVEIL. AND HARASS.
OR INVADE THE PRIVACY. OF
ANOTHER INDIVIDUAL. THE TIME
HAS COME NOW LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN AND THESE. DEVICES.
AND THIS TECHNOLOGY IS SO
INCREDIBLY INVASIVE. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN MEMBERS IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR JACKSON IS VERY BRIEFLY
I ALSO STAND IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL THIS CONTINUES AN EFFORT
THAT OF THE SOME OF US HAVE
BEEN PURSUING FOR QUITE SOME
TIME TO TRY TO PROTECT OUR
PRIVACY RIGHTS WITH SOME OF
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY AND DRONES
OF COURSE WE KNOW CAN FLY OVER
PEOPLE'S PROPERTY. AND RIGHT
NOW THERE REALLY ISN'T MUCH
THAT WE CAN DO TO PROTECT
AGAINST THAT THIS IS A GOOD
BILL THAT WILL UPDATE THE CRIME
OF INVASION OF PRIVACY TO
RECOGNIZE THE INVASION THE
INVASION AND THE POTENTIAL OF
DRONES AGAIN AND A GOOD
TECHNOLOGY IN MANY INSTANCES
BUT IT NEEDS SOME PARAMETERS
THIS IS A GOOD ONE AND WITH
THAT I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
DEAL SO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
LIGHTED TO JOIN ASSEMBLY TO
THAN MY COLLEAGUES IN SANTA
BARBARA. IN TAKING CARE OF THIS
UNATTENDED TO PROBLEM. THAT IS
OF GROWING SIGNIFICANCE I ASK
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
NIELSEN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS. AYE BATES.
AYE BILL. BY BURGESS. I
BRADFORD. I CAMBIADO I CHIANG.
DALY AYE DODD EITHER ALSO.
GALGIANI HI GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE
HUESO. HIGHER TITLE I JACKSON
BY JONES. BY LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. HI MONNING I'M
MORE LOCK TIME RAIL AYE NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. SKINNER AYE STERN
AYE STONE AYE AMBERG OUR CASSIE
I WIENER. WILK BY. MEMBER MOVES
THE CALL WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TWO FIFTY SIX SENATOR
GALGIANI. FARM TO FIFTY SIX.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINE ANY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER NAZARIAN AN ACT
RELATING TO HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE THERE GALGIANI THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
NINE NINE BE REQUIRES A HEALTH
PLAN OR AN INDIVIDUAL INSURANCE
PLAN TO PERMIT AN HIV
SPECIALIST TO BE AN ELIGIBLE
PRIMARY CARE PROVIDER IF THE
SPECIALIST REQUEST PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER STATUS AND MEETS THE
HEALTH CARE SERVICE PLANS
ELIGIBILITY CRITERIA. THIS BILL
IS DESIGNED TO HELP PATIENTS
SEEKING TO ACCESS THEIR
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH CARE
THROUGH THEIR HIV SPECIALIST
WHEN THEY'RE HAVING DIFFICULTY
DOING SO IN A TIMELY MANNER
PATIENTS OFTEN HAVE TO GO BACK
AND FORTH BETWEEN THEIR HIV
SPECIALIST AND PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER BECAUSE THE TREATMENT
PLAN ADOPTED AT THE BEGINNING
OF THE TREATMENT IS NO LONGER
RELEVANT AS THE DISEASE
ADVANCES NEW MESS
MANIFESTATIONS OF THE DISEASE
MATERIALIZE AND NEW APPROACHES
AND TREATMENT ARE NEEDED HAVING
A SPECIALIST AS A PRIMARY CARE
PROVIDER FACILITATES BETTER AND
MORE ACCESS TO HEALTH. CARE FOR
A PATIENT WITH HIV AND GIVEN
THE SERIOUSNESS OFTHIS VIRUS
AND AS LONG TERM EFFECTS I'VE
DECIDED TO BRING THIS FOR THIS
BILL AGAIN IT'S ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT
AND HAS NOT RECEIVED ANY NO
VOTES I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
GALGIANI MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING THAT MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BELL. I BRIDGES I
BRADFORD I KELLY HERO I CHIANG.
DALY AYE DODD I DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER BY GONZALEZ
I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I HILL I
GROW BY WITH SO. I TITLE I
JACKSON AYE JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. MONEY.
MITCHELL AYE MONNING HI MORE
LOCK ARM RELL I NIELSEN. I PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY
RUBIO. SKINNER I STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG I LIKE OWSKI
AYE WIENER BY WILK. SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY SEVEN
SENATOR BRADFORD BUT TO TAKE A
PASS ON FILE TO FIT M. FILE
ITEM TWO FIFTY EIGHT SENATOR
STERN IS READY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FORTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN
AN ACTOR LEAN FARMS
THUNDERSTONE DISCERN SORRY.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS IN THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
THE LET THE LEGISLATURE
APPROPRIATED THREE MILLION
DOLLARS TO FIND ENFORCEMENT
EFFORTS RELATED A PROHIBITED
FIREARM POSSESSORS AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL IN A NUMBER OF COUNTIES
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THIS BILL
WOULD ADD A DATA COLLECTION
REQUIREMENTS IN THE SUBMISSION
OF REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND DOJ SO WE CAN LEARN HOW
THESE PROGRAMS ARE WORKING WHAT
CAN BE IMPROVED IN. HOW TO
FOSTER CONTINUED COLLABORATION
BETWEEN JURISDICTIONS
ESPECIALLY BETWEEN THE STATE
LEVEL AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT BOTH
OF WHOM ARE CRITICAL PARTNERS
FOR DEALING WITH PROHIBITED
FIREARM POSSESSION WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE THANK
YOU SENATOR STERN MEMBERS. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
NIELSEN. LAYS DOWN THE SENATE
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
OVER THE YEARS WE'VE BEEN
DEALING WITH IT EXTENSIVELY.
THERE WAS A PROBLEM THAT SAID
HE WELCOMED EVOLVED OVER
SEVERAL YEARS OF THE APPS
PROGRAM. AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S OFFICE WAS NOT
GETTING THE CONFISCATED GUNS
THAT THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE AND-
WE WORKED WITH THEM ON THE
BUDGET I THINK THEY'RE STILL A
BIT OF A BACKLOG BUT MUCH
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE. BUT ONE
OF THE AREAS WHERE WE DO NEED
HELP IS WITH THE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT WHERE AS WE ARE
GOING TO RELY MORE ON THEM. AND
THEN TO IS AN ASSET TO WORK
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE SO THAT THE GUNS THAT
ARE IN THE HANDS OF THOSE WHO
ARE PROHIBITED FROM HAVING THEM
BASED ON THEIR PRIOR HISTORY.
THOSE GUNSWILL BE CONFISCATED
VERY IMPORTANT BILL ARJUN IDLE.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE
THUNDERSTORMS LIKE CLOTHES YES
SIR MY COLLEAGUE FROM TO HIM IS
QUITE RIGHT THE APPS PROGRAM IS
A CRUCIAL SYSTEM THAT NEEDS TO
BE ENFORCED BOTH THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL MORE HOPING THE
STATE SHINE SOME LIGHT ON HOW
WE CAN DO A BETTER JOB AT OUR
JOB. THAT RESPECTFULLY AS PRIDE
BOTH THANK YOU CENTER STERN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS. AYE BATES. BY BILL.
I PURCHASED. BY BRADFORD. AYE
COMING GHETTO I CHIANG. DALY
AYE DODD. I DORADO HI GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO I
TITLE I JACKSON AYE JONES I
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL
MONEY. BY MORE LUCK I'M A REAL
AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. BY ROTH BY RUBIO.
SKINNER I STERN. AYE STONE AYE
AMBERG CASKEY HI WIENER HI WILK
HI SENATOR MUSICAL NUMBERS ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY
NINE SENATOR ARCHULETA. DO WE
CHANGE THE FOR MANAGER. YES
OKAY THE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. A PASS ON FILE
VERY GOOD FILE ITEM TO SIXTY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE YOU MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ FILE ITEM
TO SIXTY. ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
NINETY ONE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BONTA AND EXPLAIN TO THE GRANT
OF PUBLIC TRUST LANDS TO THE
CITY OF OAKLAND. CENTER RIGHT
HEALTHY MEN PRESENT AB ELEVEN
NINETY ONE WILL SUPPORT THE
MIXED USE DEVELOPMENT OF OUR
TERMINAL ONE OAKLAND WHICH
INCLUDE A NEW BASEBALL UP
BALLPARK FOR THE OAKLAND
ATHLETICS AS WELL AS MUCH
NEEDED HOUSING RETAIL AND
PUBLIC GREEN SPACE ON
WATERFRONT IT WILL GENERATE
APPROXIMATELY THREE THOUSAND
SIX HUNDRED. PERMANENT JOBS AB
ELEVEN NINETY ONE IS NECESSARY
BECAUSE THE HOWARD TERMINAL
SITE CONSIST OF A PATCHWORK OF
UNRESOLVED. TITLE IN LAMB LAND
BOUNDARY DISPUTES BETWEEN THE
STATE VIA THE PUBLIC TRUST THE
PORT OF OAKLAND AND THE
AUTHORITY GRANTED THE STATE
LANDS COMMISSION AND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY. CONSERVATION
DEVELOPMENT COMMISSION THIS
WILL HELP EVERYBODY SORTED OUT
SITE URCHIN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER RIGHT KELSEY MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. ATKINS HI
BATES HI BILL I BRIDGES. I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG
AYE DALY AYE DODD I DORADO.
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. BY HERTZBERG
BY. HILL AYE HUESO. I TADO I
JACKSON AYE JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MONEY. BY
MORE LUCK I'M REAL. I NIELSEN
AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH
AYE RUBIO. SKINNER. BY STERN
AYE STONE AYE AYE NUMBER. BY
COUNTY BY WINNER HI WILK HI
THEN REMOVE THE CALL MOVING TO
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY ONE SENATOR
JACKSON MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX TWENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AN
ACT RELATED CRIME VICTIMS AND
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE
SENATOR JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES ARE RISE
TO PRESENT THIS MEASURE ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY WOMAN
CHRISTY SMITH. THIS MEASURE IS
ALSO A WOMEN'S CAUCUS PRIORITY
BILL THERE WILL HELP VICTIMS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING REBUILD THEIR
LIVES AS WE BECOME AWARE MORE
AND MORE OF THIS. INCREDIBLE
EPIDEMIC OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
WE START RECOGNIZING THE
IMPACTS THAT THIS HOUSE ON THE
LIVES OF ITS VICTIMS WHILE THEY
LOSE THEIR FREEDOM THEY ALSO
LOSE THEIR ABILITY TO WORK A
REGULAR JOB. AND RECEIVE LEGAL.
AND AN APPROPRIATE WAGES AFTER
VICTIM HAS ESCAPED THIS
TERRIBLE TRAFFICKING SITUATION
THE JOURNEY BACK TOWARDS
NORMALCY IS ALSO INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULT. VICTIMS MUST GRAPPLE
WITH FINDING HOUSING AND OTHER
BASIC NECESSITIES ON TOP OF
SEEKING TREATMENT FOR MEDICAL
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. THEY
MAY FEEL ISOLATED IN BE
ISOLATED FROM FAMILY OR FRIENDS
THEY MAY HAVE HAD TO RESETTLE
FAR AWAY FROM WHERE THEY WERE
INITIALLY TRAFFICKED IN ORDER
TO FEEL SAFE. THE WAY CURRENT
REGULATIONS ARE WRITTEN DOES
NOT ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THESE VICTIMS IN
JUROR WHILE BEING TRAFFICKED
NOR THE CHALLENGES FACED IN
RECOVERY. THIS MEASURE OR I
SHOULD SAY THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS COMPENSATION PROGRAM
PROVIDES ASSISTANCE TO VICTIMS
WHO HAVE SUFFERED PHYSICAL
INJURY. OR THE THREAT OF
PHYSICAL INJURIES RESULTING
VIOLENT CRIME INCLUDING
COVERING UNFORESEEN EXPENSES
SUCH AS MEDICAL BILLS MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT FUNERAL AND
BURIAL EXPENSES. AS WELL AS
INCOME LOSS HOWEVER UNDER
TODAY'S LAWS HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS MAY NOT BE COMPENSATED
FOR INCOME LOSS. THIS MEASURE
WILL ALLOW THE CALIFORNIA
VICTIM COMPENSATION BOARD TO
COMPENSATE UMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS FOR ECONOMIC LOSSES
INCURRED AS A RESULT OF BEING
TRAFFICKED. NOW WE CERTAINLY
CAN'T UNDO THE HARM THAT EXISTS
IN IS CREATED BY HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. TO THESE VICTIMS
BUT WE CAN PROVIDE THEM WITH
ASSISTANCE RECOGNIZE THE
ADVERSITY THEY'VE UNDERGONE AND
HELP THEM TO BE ABLE TO MOVE ON
WITH THEIR LIVES SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
NIELSEN. THAT A PRESENT LADY'S
GENTLEMAN SENATE. SHORT OF.
DEATH AND- VERY SEVERE PHYSICAL
INJURY. THERE ARE FEW CRIMES
MORE HARMFUL. THEN THIS TRAFFIC.
IT IS IN FACT A LIFETIME
SENTENCE THE VICTIM. EVEN IF
THEY ARE NOT TO HARM PHYSICALLY.
EMOTIONALLY AND MENTALLY AND
IT'S A TOTALLY DESTRUCTIVE.
CRIME PERPETRATED ON MANY MANY
INNOCENT VICTIMS. IT'S KIND OF
A CRIME THAT IS NOT MUCH
NOTICED THERE BEEN SOME MOVIES
ABOUT IT IF YOU WATCH THE
MOVIES. THE KIND OF MOVIES YOU
DREAM ABOUT. AND YOU PRAY ABOUT
THAT NONE OF YOUR LOVED ONES
WHATEVER BE SUBJECTED TO SUCH
TRAGEDY. IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT ANYONE COULD DO SUCH
THINGS TO FELLOW HUMAN BEINGS.
BUT IT IS AN INCREASING PROBLEM.
WE NEED TO HELP THESE VICTIMS
TO THE DEGREE THAT WE CAN. THIS
IS ONLY TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS.
BUT IT IS A BREAKTHROUGH. THIS
WARNING OF A YES VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NO ANSWER JACK'S WHICH
LIKE CLOTHES YES AGAIN I
APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS FROM MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING
VICTIMS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
COMPENSATION. FOR LOST ARE
UNDERPAID WAGES LIKE ANY OTHER
VICTIM OF CRIME AND WITH THAT I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS AYE BATES HI BILL HI
BURGESS. HI BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO. AYE CHIANG I DALY I
DODD. HI THERE ALSO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH I HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO I TITLE I JACKSON BY
JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL MONNING I'M MORE LOCK
BY AMARILLO AYE NIELSEN AYE PAN.
I PORTANTINO BY ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
AYE HAMBURG IA CASKEY I WINNER
HI WILK HI. SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY TO SENATOR RUBIO. PASS ON
FILE OF FILE ITEM TO SIXTY
THREE SENATOR UMBERG MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL FIFTY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA AN ACT REALLY INTO
ELECTIONS SENATOR UMBERG. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
I'M PLEASE PRESENT AB FIFTY
NINE WHICH BUILDS ON OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO INCREASE
CIVIC ENGAGEMENT AND VTER
TURNOUT AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE.
WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS THIS
BILL SIMPLY AS THE LIST OF
CONSIDERATIONS AS TO WHERE VOTE
CENTER SHOULD BE PLACED. AS TO
THE THAT LIST COLLEGE CAMPUSES
MAKES ALL THE SENSE IN THE
WORLD THAT A VOTE SO SHOULD BE
A COLLEGE CAMPUS IF.
CALIFORNIA'S YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
LIKE MY CHILREN SOMETIMES THEY
FORGET THAT ELECTIONS COMING
SOMETIMES THEY LOSE THEIR
BALLOT SOMETIMES THAT THEY
DON'T PAY ATTENTION TO JUST
SHORTLY BEFORE THE ELECTION.
AND SO A COLLEGE CAMPUS IS AN
IDEAL LOCATION BUT THIS BILL
DOESN'T REQUIRE PLACE ON A
COLLEGE CAMPUS SIMPLY AS IT. AS
ONE OF THE MANY CONSIDERATIONS
AS TO WHERE VOTE CENTER SHOULD
BE PLACED AYE REGION I VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER OF BURKE
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR GORGEOUS. TO PULL MADAM
PRESENT FAQ COULD POSE A
QUESTION TO. THE AIRPORT
MANAGER. NUMBER WE TAKE A
QUESTION. I'M HAPPY AS CAN BE
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU SENATOR
BORDERS PLEASE PROCEED. THANK
YOU. UNDER CURRENT LAW ARE
THERE ANY RESTRICTIONS BY
COUNTY OFFICIALS ALLOWING
VOTING TO TAKE PLACE ON
UNIVERSITY THINGS RIGHT NOW.
I'M NOT AWARE OF ANY
PROHIBITION OF BOTH CENTERS
BEING LOCATED ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES BUT THE VOTE CENTER
CONCEPT IS A RELATIVELY NEW
CONCEPT IN TWO THOUSAND AND
TWENTY N. BEYOND COUNTIES WILL
BE MANY COUNTIES WILL BE HAVING
VOTE CENTERS VERSES VOTING
PRECINCTS. SO THIS IS A NEW
CONCEPT IN THIS SIMPLY
ENSHRINES IN LAW THAT AMONG THE
CONSIDERATIONS FOR THE REGISTER
VOTERS TO CONSIDER IS A BOTH
CENTER ON A COLLEGE CAMPUS AND
THAT'S IN THAT'S REALLY I THINK
MY CONCERN HERE IS THAT. ON ITS
FACE IT'S BUT NINE BUT THE
POWER ALREADY IS VESTED BY IN
THE COUNTY OFFICIALS TO CREATE
VOTING PLACES WHERE THERE ARE
CONGREGATIONS IN LARGE NUMBERS
OF PEOPLE SO. I'M TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE EFFICACY OF
THIS LEGISLATION REALLY IS.
THROUGH THE CHAIR I THINK IT'S
WITHOUT OBJECTION I THINK IT'S
TO SPECIFICALLY. ADVISE THE
COUNTY REGISTRARS THE THIS IS
AMONG THE CONSIDERATIONS ARE
MANY CONSIDERATIONS BUT SO THAT
THERE IS IT'S NOT AMBIGUOUS WAS
NOT LOST ON THEM THAT THIS IS
AMONG THE CONSIDERATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BOTH CENTER
HERTZBERG IF I CAN MADAM
PRESIDENT AS THE JOINT AUTHORED
WAS SENATOR ALLEN ON THIS
MEASURE SOME YEARS AGO THE
CRATE VOTE CENTERS LOOKING AT
COLORADO IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
THERE WERE AND HAVING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE NUMBER
OF THE VARIOUS REGISTRARS US
SOME QUESTIONS AND I THINK THAT
THIS LAW MAKES SENSE IN THE
SENSE THAT IT GIVES MORE
DIRECTION TO REGISTRARS VOTER
REGISTRARS OF FROM THIS
LEGISLTURE AS TO WHAT IT MEANT
BY THE LAW WAS AT THREE FIFTY I
CAN'T FOR THE BILL NUMBER WAS
BUT ANY EVENT THE BILL THAT WE
PUT TOGETHER AND I THINK IT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE AND SO I.
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS MEASURE.
THANK YOU CENTER HERTZBERG
MEMBERS IN THEIR- DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
MANSON OR HUMBER NUMBER WHICH I
TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THIS MAKES ALL THE
SENSE IN THE WORLD. THAT WE
SHOULD ADVISE REGISTRAR VOTERS
THAT AMONG THE PLACES THAT THEY
SHOULD CONSIDER OUR COLLEGE
CAMPUSES ARJUNA VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR UMBERG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
BILL I PURCHASED. BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I CHIANG BY DAILY.
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE BY JACKSON I JONES
NO LEYVA. I'M ACQUIRE MITCHELL
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK WELL NO
NIELSEN. PAN AYE PORTANTINO. I
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER. BY
STERN BY STONE NO NUMBER I
WOULD COUNTY AYE WIENER AYE
WILK. BY SENATOR MOVES A CALL
TO FILE ITEM TO SIXTY FOUR
SENATOR DOLLY MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES SAWYER AND
ACT REALLY DID YOU AND ALSO
MAKING A PREPARATION THEREFORE.
SENATOR DOLLY. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I'M JACKI THIS BILL
ON THE OP OF REGINALD JONES
SAWYER AB FOURTEEN FIFTY FOUR.
MAYES CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
U. THREE INVESTMENT GRANT
PROGRAM. THAT WAS A LEGISLATORS
FUNDED IN THE IT WAS LIVE
FOUNDED IN LAST YEAR'S BUDGET
AND THE LAST TWO YEARS BUDGET
ACTUALLY THIS BILL INCLUDES A
NUMBER OF TECHNICAL FIXES THAT
MAKE IT EASIER FOR
JURISDICTIONS. TO APPLY FOR
GRANTS AND ENSURE THAT THE
FUNDS ARE USED FOR SUCCESSFUL
YOU DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR
EXAMPLE THIS BILL WILL ALLOW
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS TO
APPLY FOR GRANTS AND INCREASES
THE MAXIMUM AWARD AMOUNT TO TWO
MILLION. THESE CHANGES ARE
IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT THESE
FUNDS REACH ALL PARTS OF THE
STATE. KEEPING YOU THOUGHT A
PRISON SYSTEM AND CONNECTING
THEM TO SUPPORTIVE SERVICES IS
NOT ONLY THE RIGHT THING TO DO
BUT IT ALSO REPRESENTS A HUGE
COST SAVINGS TO THE STATE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER DOLLY
MEMBERS ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES
BY BILL BY BURGESS BY BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CHIANG AYE DALY.
AYE DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW
I HERTZBERG. I HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TADO. I JACKSON I JONES.
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE SO. MONNING
HI MORE LUCK I AM A REAL.
NIELSEN HI PAN I PORTANTINO BY
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER I
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG AYE
AYE CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK.
HI CENTER MOVES A CALL MOVED TO
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY FIVE
SENATORS STERN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
OH BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AND
ACT REALLY NO FARMS CENTER
STERN. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. BACK LAST NOVEMBER.
THE BORDERLINE SHOOTING TOOK
TWELVE LIVES INNOCENT LIVES
FROM US IN THOUSAND OAKS. AB
TWELVE IS FOR THOSE TWELVE
PEOPLE. IT WILL NOT BRING THEM
BACK. THEY WILL NOT BRING
JUSTICE BECAUSE JUSTICE IS
FLEETING. WITH THE. ON STREETS
TRAGEDY LIKE WE HAD THERE. BUT
IT HOPEFULLY WILL HELP US TURN
THE PAGE AND START TO MAKE OUR
LAWS BETTER TO PREVENT THESE
KINDS OF TRAGEDIES IN THE
FUTURE. WE'VE WE'VE SEEN
IMPASSES REACHED WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE BEEN VISITED BY LAW
ENFORCEMENT IN. MAYBE NOT
SUBJECT TO A FIFTY ONE FIFTY OR
SOME KIND OF DETENTION BUT
BASED ON THEIR HISTORY I THEIR
ON THE APPS LIST OR- OR SOME
OTHER INCIDENT IN THIS CASE A
YOUNG MAN WHOSE PUNCHING HOLES
IN HIS WALLS. THREATENING HIS
MOTHER. AT HISTORY OF VIOLENCE
AND MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES AND
YET. WE LEFT HIM WITH HIS GUN.
THIS BILL WILL HOPEFULLY GIVE
THE COURTS ARE ROLE IN DEALING
WITH GUN VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDERS TO GIVE THEM SOME
DISCRETION EXTEND THE TIME
FRAME BETWEEN ONE AND FIVE
YEARS FOR A GUN VIOLENCE
RESTRAINING OVER ORDER AFTER
NOTICING HEARING. SO NOW THAT A
DENIAL OF DUE PROCESS RIGHTS.
BUT CERTAINLY WITH MORE
JUDICIAL DISCRETION THAT WE
HAVE RIGHT NOW. WE HOPE THIS
BILL WILL ALLEVIATE A BURDEN ON
COURTS AS WELL IN THE LAWN
FORCING THE BUREAUCRACY BUT
ALSO ON FAMILIES WHO HAVE TO
FACE. AN UNCERTAIN FUTURE.
HEALTHY BRING SOME COMFORT TO
THE VICTIMS. THIS BILL ALSO
MAKES THREE OTHER IMPORTANT
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO MAKE GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
MORE EFFICIENT AND EFFECTIVE.
BY ALLOWING AGENCIES TO FILE IN
LIEU OF NAMING INDIVIDUAL
OFFICERS BY ALLOWING A
REQUESTING OFFICER TO SERVE THE
ORDER. AND CLEAR FIND
ALLOWANCES FOR SALE AND
TRANSFER DO NOT APPLY IN
EMERGENCY CONTACTS. WE CAN
NEVER SAY THAT ONE LAW WOULD
HAVE STOPPED A PARTICULAR
SHOOTING. I THINK SOMETIMES IT
IS BEYOND US. BUT IT IS OUR
DUTY TO DO EVERYTHING WE HAVE
THE POWER TO DO UNDER OUR LAW.
SOME COMFORT. TO THE VICTIMS
AND SOME SAFETY. THOSE MILLION
THE SCHOOL KIDS AROUND THIS
COUNTRY WHO FEAR IT SOOTING
MORE THAN ANYTHING ELSE AND
YET. THE RISK OF THAT HAPPENING.
IS SO MINUTE. BUT IT DOMINATES
OUR PUBLIC PSYCHE RIGHT NOW. WE
HAVE TO MAKE CHANGES HERE TO
TURN THE PAGE ON THIS GUN
VIOLENCE DEBATE WE HOPE WITH
THE BI PARTISAN MOVE WE MADE
WITH AB TWELVE WE CAN START TO
TURN THAT PAGE AND BEGIN TO
HEAL. WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE THANK YOU CENTER
STERN DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR NIELSEN. NOT A
PRESIDENT LAYS DOWN THE SENATE
WHERE THIS IS STAND ALONE BILL.
I WOULD FIND SAMARITAN. BUT IT
IS NOT. IN FACT IRONICALLY IT
FLIES IN THE FACE OF THE CORE
ELEMENTS OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM THAT WE'RE IN THE THROES
OF NOW. INCLUDING DIMINISHING
THE CONSEQUENCES FOR ONE WHO
USES. A GUN IN THE COMMISSION
OF A CRIME. BECAUSE WE'RE NOT
TO BE IN TWO ENHANCEMENTS
ANYMORE. AND GETTING PEOPLE OUT
OF PRISON EARLIER IS THE GOAL.
NOT LATER. NOT ATER BECAUSE OF
ENHANCEMENTS LIKE USE A GUN GO
TO PRISON THAT THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA VOTED FOR A LONG
TIME AGO. PROVIDED TO YEAR
ENHANCEMENT THE USE A GUN.
PERIOD. THE EXTENDING THE
RESTRAINING ORDER. TWO FIVE
YEARS. WELL WOULD THAT HELP IN
SOME WAY I WOULD ASSUME IT
WOULD BUT AGAIN I'M ARGUING IN
THE CONTEXT OF ALL OF THE
OTHER. ATTEMPTS THAT HAVE BEEN
MADE. TO STOP GUN VIOLENCE.
CHICAGO FOR EXAMPLE MURDER
CAPITAL OF AMERICA. STRICTEST
GUN LAWS IN AMERICA. IN EVERY
DAY WERE COMING UP WITH NEW
IDEAS TO DIMINISH THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR CRIME
INCLUDING. WITH GUNS. AS I
NOTED A LITTLE BIT AGO. IT
HASN'T EVEN BEEN A PRIORITY. IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO TAKE
GUNS AWAY FROM THOSE WHO WERE
PROHIBITED FROM HAVING GUNS. A
BACKLOG WAS OVER TWENTY
THOUSAND GUNS NOW NOT GUTS.
THAT WOULD BE INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE PROHIBITED FROM HAVING
GUNS IN ALMOST EVERY ONE OF
THOSE WOULD HAVE MORE THAN ONE
GUN. YOU EXTRAPOLATE THE NUMBER
OF GUNS THAT HAVE NOT BEEN
CONFISCATED THAT BY LAW SHOULD
HAVE BEEN A LONG TIME AGO YEARS
AGO. SO THIS MAY BE FEEL GOOD.
BUT DON'T BE DECEIVED. TAKEN IN
CONTEXT THIS AIN'T GOING TO
HELP VERY MUCH. LIMA NOVO.
THANK YOU SENATOR NELSON
MEMBERS FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING NONE
CENTER STERN PLEASE CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WITH
WITH DUE RESPECT SOME. I DON'T
HAVE THE POWER TO REINVENT THE
STATE A CALIFORNIA LAW HERE
BEFORE YOU ON THE FLOOR TODAY.
BUT I THINK THIS DOES MORE THAN
A LITTLE BIT. THE KIND OF
DISCRETION GIVEN TO THE
JUDICIAL SYSTEM TO EXTEND THESE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT GUN
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDERS
WHICH WE'VE DENIED LAW
ENFORCEMENT THE TOOL OF USING
FOR FAR TOO LONG. WE THINK CAN
MAKE A MEANINGFUL DIFFERENCE IN
PEOPLE'S LIVES. AND SAVE MANY
OF THEM IN THE IN THE PROCESS
SO WITH THAT ARE RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR I'VE- THANK YOU CENTER
STERN MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. BY
ARCHULETA I ATKINS HI. BATES.
BELL FIVE LARGEST. OFFERED I
CABALLERO I CHIANG NO DALY.
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI BY
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
I TADO BY JACKSON I JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. MITCHELL.
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN NO PAN. BY
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
NOVEMBER TYLER CASKEY BY WIENER
HI WILK HI SENATOR MUSICAL
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TO SIXTY SIX SENATOR RUBIO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
AN ACT RELATING TO SCHOOL MEALS
SENATOR RUBIO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT TODAY I RISE TO
PRESENT AB THREE FIFTY FOUR ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK
SILVA. AB THREE FIFTY FOUR
REQUIRES SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THE NATIONAL
SCHOOL LUNCH PROGRAM OR THE
FEDERAL SCHOOL BREAKFAST
PROGRAM TO ANNUALLY REPORT AN
ALTERNATIVE MEAL PROGRAM TO
ENSURE STUDENTS THE NEEDS ARE
PROVIDED WITH ONE ADEQUATE AND
NUTRITIOUS MEALS EACH DAY. THIS
BILL ALSO ENSURES AT SCHOOL
SITES HAVE ADEQUATE SPACE FOR
STUDENTS TO CONSUME THOSE MEALS
ALL STUDENTS DESERVE EQUITABLE
ACCESS TO RESOURCES AND ENSURE
TO ENSURE THEIR SUCCESS
IMPROPER NUTRITION. IS ONE OF
THEM WHAT THIS BILL WE CAN MAKE
SURE THAT SCHOOLS THAT DO NOT
PARTICIPATE IN THESE PROGRAMS
ARE STILL PROVIDING ADEQUATE
MEALS FOR STUDENTS SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YA BOY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
RUBIO MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. FURTHERMORE LOCK. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS IS THE
SECOND YEAR NOW THAT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO GET ALL. OF THE AUDITED
FINANCIAL REPORTS FOR THE NINE
HUNDRED AND FORTY AUDITED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN. CALIFORNIA
AND WE SHOULD BE RELEASING THE
INFORMATION SOON BUT- THE BAD
NEWS IS THAT THERE. A MIND
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT HAS
GROWN 40% IN THE LAST YEAR. SO
WE HAVE TO PAY REAL CLOSE
ATTENTION TO THE FINANCIAL
VIABILITY. OF OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS BUT I WAS DOING A
LITTLE ANALYSIS OF THE
POPULATION OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS A HUNDRED NINETEEN.
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA
REPRESENT POPULATIONS OF LESS
THAN A THOUSAND PEOPLE. BETWEEN
ONE THOUSAND AND TEN THOUSAND
IT'S TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND THEN
BETWEEN TEN THOUSAND ONE IN
ELEVEN THOUSAND IT'S A FIFTEEN
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. BETWEEN
ELEVEN THOUSAND ONE IN TWENTY
THOUSAND IT'S NINETY NINE
SCHOOL DISTRICT SO. FOR JUST
POPULATIONS THAT SMALL THE
REPRESENTS 55% OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CALIFORNIA. I CAN
GIVE YOU THE BREAKDOWN OF THE
REST BUT THERE ARE SO FEW THAT
REPRESENT MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PUPILS YOU
HAVE THE BIG THE BIG BOYS LIKE
KERN HIGH WHICH HAS SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND. SAN
FRANCISCO UNIFIED EIGHT HUNDRED
EIGHTY FOUR THOUSAND. SAN DIEGO
UNIFIED ONE MILLION NINETY
FIVE. AND THEN L. A. U. S. T.
FOUR MILLION SEVEN HUNDRED ONE.
BUT LA UNIFIED JUST LET THIS
YEAR ALONE IS HAD TO RAISE
THEIR LIABILITIES BY FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS WHICH
REPRESENTS PROBABLY THE- BOOK
OF THE INCREASE. IN THE
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICITS SO
I'LL YOU LOOK AT. THIS BIG BODY
OF DATA AND YOU REALIZE THAT
SMALL DISTRICTS RENDERMAN. AND
LARGE DISTRICTS AROUND THE
FINANCIAL BRINK SACRAMENTO CITY
WHICH SERVES THREE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND STUDENTS. WILL
BE OUT OF CASH IN TWO MONTHS.
AND WE ACT LIKE EVERYTHING IS
FINE AND THAT WE CAN ADD TO
THEIR BURKE. INSTEAD OF
LIGHTNING THEIR LOAD. SO
COLLEAGUES I'M BEWILDERED DOES
A CPA I'M LOOKING AT THE DATA
AND I'M REALLY GETTING VERY
CONCERNED WE HAVE SERIOUS
SYSTEMIC ISSUES TO RESOLVE IN
OUR SCHOOL SYSTEMS AND WE'RE
DEALING WITH MEAL PROGRAM
REPORTING. KIND OF BRINGS TO
MIND THE OLD COMMERCIAL WORKERS
THE BEEF. I RECOMMEND A NO VOTE
ON A. B. THREE FIVE FOUR THANK
YOU BETTER PRESIDENT THANK YOU
CENTER MORLOCK MEMBERS FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING AND
HEARING NONE CENTER RUBIO WHICH
I TO CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YEAH Và THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES.
NOBEL. BOARD BELLI BURGESS. NO
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I CHIANG.
DALY NO DOT HI DORADO. GALGIANI
HI GLAZER. I GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TITLE I JACKSON I JONES.
NO LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE MITCHELL
MONNING I'M MORE LUCK NUMBER
REAL. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO HI HI ROTH HI RUBIO
BY SKINNER I STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER HI WHAT COUNTY I
WINNER. HI WILK HI SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MOVING TO FILE
ITEM TO SIXTY EIGHT SENATOR
JACKSON MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY
NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE AND ACT REALLY TO
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SENATE
JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THIS IS A
MEASURE OF WHICH WILL REQUIRE A
MOBILE DATA SERVICE PROVIDER.
VIED UNRESTRICTED MOBILE DADDY
USED TO A FIRST RESPONSE AGENCY
WHEN RESPONDING TO AN
EMERGENCY. THAT MAY SEEM LIKE A
NO BRAINER BUT IN RECENT IN THE
RECENTLY DURING THE SANTA FE
SANTA CLARA. MENDOCINO COMPLEX
FIRE THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
FIRE OFFICIALS. ATTEMPTED TO
GET INFORMATION OUT ON ITS
COMMUNICATIONS EQUIPMENT. AND
IN FACT THAT EQUIPMENT TO THE
ENDED UP CRAWLING THE
INFORMATION THEY CONTACTED
THEIR PROVIDERS CUSTOMER
SERVICE DEPARTMENT YOU CAN
IMAGINE YOU'RE RESPONDING TO A
MAJOR FIRE YOU'VE GOT TO CALL
CUSTOMER SERVICE. IN ATTEMPT TO
RESOLVE THE ISSUE THAT THEY
COULDN'T GET THIS INFORMATION
OUT. THEY WERE MET WITH AN
OFFER TO UPGRADE THEIR EXISTING
PLAN. IN ORDER TO LIFT THE
RESTRICTIONS. AS NOTED BYTHE
COUNTY'S FIRE CHIEF THE
THROTTLING HAD A SIGNIFICANT
IMPACT ON THEIR ABILITY TO
PROVIDE EMERGENCY SERVICES AND
IMPEDED THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE
CRISIS RESPONSE AN ESSENTIAL
EMERGENCY SERVICES IF ANY OF
YOU HAD TO GO HAVE HAD TO GO
ONLINE TO DEAL WITH THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE FOLKS WHETHER
IT'S TO INCREASE YOUR SERVICE
PAY A BILL ASK WHY X. Y. IN SHE
IS HAPPENING IT'S THE LAST
THING YOU WANT TO DO DURING AN
EMERGENCY WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
GET INFORMATION OUT. TO THE
PEOPLE YOU SERVE UNDER THOSE
CIRCUMSTANCES. EVERY DAY FIRST
RESPONDERS LAY THEIR LIVES ON
THE LINE WHEN RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCIES I THINK IT IS.
AGREED OR SHOULD BE AGREED AS A
STATE AND LEGISLATURE THAT WE
NEED TO ENSURE. THAT THESE
FIRST RESPONDERS ARE PROVIDED
THE TOOLS NECESSARY TO DO THEIR
JOB IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THIS
BILL HAS SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
IPHONE. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I WOULD
CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
JOINING WITH MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SANTA BARBARA. I LOOK UPON THIS
MUCH LIKE THE EMERGENCY
BROADCAST SYSTEM. WHERE
EVERYONE MUST PARTICIPATE IN
THE EVENT OF AN EMERGENCY THE
IDEA THAT THERE MGHT BE DELAYS
IN INTERNET CONNECTION OR DATA
USAGE. IS UNACCEPTABLE SO I AM
PROUD TO SUPPORT MY COLLEAGUE
AND ASSEMBLYMAN NOW LIVING IN
THIS IN HIS LEGISLATION THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR BORCHERS
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING NONE CENTER JACKSON
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE THANK YOU
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA.
ATKINS HI BATES HI BILL. I
PURCHASED. BY BRADFORD. I CAN
BE AT ALL. I CHIANG. AYE DALY
AYE DODD. AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. I HERTZBERG.
HILL HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE.
WITH SO HI FOR TITLE I JACKSON
BY JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE.
MITCHELL. MONNING I'M MORE LOCK
HI WELL HI NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. HI ROTH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE. I
AMBERG ABA CASSIE I WIENER AYE
WILK HI. DINNER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS REMOVING A FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTY SENATOR ROTH MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTEEN OH SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO AN
ACT RELATING TO STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID SENATE ROTH THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT THIS BILL
IMPLEMENTS A FUNDING FORMULA
BASED CAL GRANT AWARD FOR
STUDENTS ATTENDING PRIVATE NON
PROFIT UNIVERSITIES. UNLIKE THE
AWARDS FOR YOU SEE AND SEE
ISSUE THAT ARE ADJUSTED BASED
ON CHANGES IN TUITION THE
AWARDS FOR PRIVATE NON PRIVATE
UNIVERSITIES ARE STATIC. THIS
BILL WILL JUST CALDERON AWARDS
FOR STUDENTS AT PRIVATE
NONPROFIT INSTITUTIONS BY
LINKING THEM AS A PERCENTAGE OF
CAL GRANT ALLOCATIONS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
STUDENTS. THE BILL HAS ENJOYED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT IT'S SUPPORT
SUPPORT IN HERE AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE. THANK YOU SENATOR
ROTH MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING THAT
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. HI BILL BY
BURGESS. BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO.
HI CHIANG BY DAILY. DODD BY THE
RAZA HI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER HI
GONZALEZ HI GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
AYE HILL AYE HUESO AYE TITLE HI
JACKSON I JONES BY LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONEY BY MORE
LUCK I AM A REAL BY NELSON. I
PAN AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY
RUBIO. HI SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE AYE AMBERG. HI MY COUNTY
I WINNER BY WILK. BY SENATOR
MOVES THE CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY
ONE SENATOR HILL IS ALWAYS
READY MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL FIVE FIFTY
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA AN ACT
RELATING TO VETERANS THEIR HILL
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT HERE
2% EIGHTY FIVE FIFTY WHICH
WOULD ESTABLISH THE MEDICAL
FOSTER HOME PILOT PROGRAM THIS
BILL HAS RECEIVED SUPPORT FROM
MANY CARE AND VETERANS GROUPS
INCLUDING A A. R. P. AND AM
VETS AND HAS NO OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK DR COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
SENATOR HILL MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. HI BILL BY BURGESS.
BRADFORD. FOR JUST BY BRADFORD.
HI KEVIN ZERO HI CHIANG AYE
DALY AYE DODD AYE DORADO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG. HI
I WAS SO. HIGHER TITLE HI
JACKSON AYE JONES. I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MONNING AYE
MOORLACH AYE MORRELL AYE
NIELSEN AYE PAN AYE PORTANTINO
AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO BY SKINNER.
I STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG
IOWA KELSEY. BY WIENER AYE WILK
HI UNDER MOVES A CALL MEMBERS
MOVING TO FILE ITEM TO SEVENTY
THREE SENATOR DORADO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SMITH AN ACT
RELATING TO SCHOOL
ACCOUNTABILITY CENTER TORONTO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
COLLEAGUES AB NINE SIXTY SEVEN.
INCLUDES ALL LOCAL EIGHT
EDUCATION AGENCYCOMMUNITIES IN
THE EL CAP PROCESS AND SUPPORTS
THE LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR'S
GOAL OF ALIGNING CHARTER SCHOOL
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCOUNTABILITY
WITH THAT OF ALL STATE ELEAZAR.
FOR FIVE YEARS CALIFORNIA
SCHOOLS HAVE BEEN TASKED WITH
DEVELOPING DATA DRIVEN AND
RIGOROUS LOCAL ENGAGEMENT AND
MEANINGFUL STAKEHOLDER
ENGAGEMENT PROCESSES IN THE EL
CAP DEVELOPMENT AND DELIVERY.
THE LOCAL CONTROL FUNDING
FORMULA REQUIRES THAT ALLEY ETS
CONSULT WITH PARENTS STUDENTS
AND COMMUNITY AS THEY DEVELOP
THEIR AL CAPS AND STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN. THAT SCHOOLS WHO HAVE
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT WITH
THEIR COMMUNITIES HAVE BEEN THE
MOST SUCCESSFUL AT ELIMINATING
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS. THIS IS A
PROCESS THAT ALL PUBLICLY
FUNDED SCHOOLS NEED TO HAVE TO
BE ABLE TO BEST SERVE THEIR
PARENT AND STUDENT POPULATION.
UNFORTUNATELY AT PRESENT NOT
ALL PARENTS AND STUDENTS HAVE
THE ABILITY IN THE MEANS TO
ACCESS TO SCHOOL BOARDS AND
PARTICIPATE IN THE EL CAP
PROCESS AND NOT ALL SCHOOL
BOARDS HOWEVER A BUS PROCESS.
AB NINE SIX SEVEN RINGS CHARTER
SCHOOLS INTO ALIGNMENT WITH ALL
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
PROVIDES THE AL CAPP. AS A
UNIFORM AND STANDARD BASIS FOR
COMPARISON TO MONITOR STUDENT
OUTCOMES ACROSS THE EIGHT STATE
PRIORITIES AND THE TARGETED
SUBGROUPS ACROSS ALL PUBLIC
SCHOOLS COLLEAGUES ASK FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION AND THEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DRAWS
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
NIELSEN. BETTER PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE THIS MAY BE WELL
INTENDED. ORAL INTENDED
INADVERTENTLY OR ADVERSELY
PLACE BEFORE US TAKEN IN
CONTEXT THOUGH I HAVE TO FEEL
THAT IT'S NOT WELL INTENDED.
WHAT WE'RE DOING HERE IS
SOMETHING THAT'S BEEN IN
PROCESS FOR MANY MANY YEARS.
EVEN DECADES. AS CHARTER
SCHOOLS. RULES. PARENTS HAVE
SEEN FIT TO ROLLER YOUTH IN
CHARTER SCHOOLS. PARTICULARLY.
IN AREAS WHERE THERE ARE
CHALLENGES FOR THE FAMILIES.
AND FOR THE STUDENTS IN FACT
THERE'S BEEN A HUGE GROWTH. OF
THOSE FAMILY SAYING NO. PUBLIC
EDUCATION IS LET US DOWN IN OUR
CHILDREN DOWN. WE'RE GOING TO
PUT THEM IN THE CHARTER SCHOOLS
THE CHARTER SCHOOLS OF GROWN.
OUR CHILDREN WHICH PROSPERED.
NOW WE DON'T TO DO TESTING
ANYMORE BECAUSE PUBLIC
EDUCATION WAS TOO EMBARRASSED.
CONTINUED BOTTOM RATINGS WE
WERE RECEIVING. BUT IT
CERTAINLY WAS SOMETHING THAT
PARENTS HAVE BEEN AWARE OF THAT
THEIR CHILDREN DID BETTER. IN
OTHER SETTINGS. AND WHAT THESE
MINI SERIES OF BILLS OVER THE
YEARS HAVE DONE. IS TO OPPOSE
AS THIS ONE SPECIFICALLY DOES
IMPOSE ON CHARTER SCHOOLS THE
VERY SAME FACT DOORS THAT HAVE
MADE OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
ESTABLISHMENT MEDIOCRE. IS THAT
OUR HIGHEST STANDARD AND HOPE
FOR OUR CHILDREN MEDIOCRITY. I
THINK NOT. LET'S GIVE THESE
PARENTS A CHOICE. THIS
TRANSPARENCY. IS ACTUALLY MORE
OF A COVER. FOR THE FAILURES OF
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. THAT IT IS A
NEED TO BE IMPOSED ON CHARTER
SCHOOLS I URGE A NO VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER NIELSEN FURTHER
DISCUSSION AND DEBATE SENATOR
PORCHES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
HAD RAISE SOME VERY IMPORTANT
AND SERIOUS POINTS. I THINK THE
FACT THAT WE NEED CHARTER
SCHOOLS BELIES THE FACT THAT
MANY OF OUR PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS
HAVE NOT BEEN PERFORMING UP TO
PAR AND I COME FROM AN AND A
FAMILY OF EDUCATORS AND I
MYSELF WAS AN EDUCATOR IN MY
PREVIOUS CAPACITY. THIS IDEA
THAT HOLDING. OUR CHARTER
SCHOOLS JUNE EL CAP OR OTHER
CRITERIA IN THE INTEREST OF
DISCLOSURE I DON'T THINK IS
PROPERLY REPRESENTING THE FAX.
I'LL BE THE FIRST TO TELL YOU
THAT I'VE VOTE AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO MAKE CERTAIN THAT
CHARTER SCHOOLS BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE BY THE BROWN ACT. I
DON'T BELIEVE THAT A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION SHOULD CONDUCT
ITSELF IN PRIVATE IN THAT
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PARENTS
AND THOSE IN THE COMMUNITY. AND
I EXPRESS THAT. I WANT TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT ARE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE HELD ACCOUNTABLE BY
THE BROWN ACT. AND THERE'S A
NUMBER OF OTHER INSTANCES LIKE
THAT WHERE WE NEED TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE BROUGHT UP TO PAR IN TERMS
OF TRANSPARENCY IN MANDATORY
DISCLOSURES. THAT WE HOLD TO
OTHER INSTITUTIONS. BUT THE
REASON WHY CHARTER SCHOOLS
EXIST IS BECAUSE MANY OF OUR
PRIVATE OR PUBLIC AGE
INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT PERFORMING
PROPERLY IN THIS IS A SAFETY
GAP. THIS IS A SAFETY VALVE
THAT HELPS OUR COMMUNITY I
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A WAY THAT
WE CAN SELF CORRECT NOT ONLY
THROUGH CHARTER SCHOOLS WITH A
LEARN THE LESSONS LEARNED. FROM
THEIR EXPERIENCE INTO THE
PUBLIC SETTING. SO THE IDEA
THAT THIS IS ABOUT
ACCOUNTABILITY IN THIS IS ABOUT
MAKING CERTAIN THAT PARENTS ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROCESS.
I'LL BE THE FIRST TO TELL YOU
THAT IN MY BACKYARD I WAS A
PART OF AN ORGANIZATION THAT
WANT TO CREATE A CHARTER SCHOOL
THAT EVEN PROMOTED THE IDEA OF
MAKING CERTAIN THAT UNION.
FACULTY UNITES FACULTY WERE
PART OF THIS NEW CHARTER ENTITY.
THIS GOES FAR BEYOND THAT. I
DON'T CARE HOW YOU GHOST
THROUGH WITH BENIGN LANGUAGE.
THIS IS A DID THIS IS A DESIRE
BY FOLKS WHO OPPOSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS. TO ME TO BRING IT DOWN
PERFORMANCE WITH INTRUSIVE AND
OVERLY BURDENSOME REGULATIONS.
TO CREATE A PLAYING FIELD THAT
IS COMMENSURATE WITH THE
BUREAUCRACY THAT WE SEE IN
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS I THINK
THAT'S- THAT'S A TRAVESTY IN MY
OPINION. I WOULD ENCOURAGE MY
CALL IS COLLEAGUES TO SEE THIS
AS IT IS. A MEASURE TO BRING
BACK BRING DOWN CHARTER SCHOOLS
TO A POINT WHERE THERE IS NO.
DISPARITY IN PERFORMANCE
OUTCOMES AS WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
PAST. THANK YOU SENATOR BORDERS
FOR THE DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
CENTER GLAZER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS YOU KNOW IN
JANUARY WE HAD A DISCUSSION ON
THE FLOOR ABOUT THE BROWN ACTON
OPEN MEETINGS AND LA OUT OF THE
EARLY DAYS OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
YEAR WITH. A COMPROMISE WAS
FORGED BETWEEN THE PUBLIC
CHARTER COMMUNITY PUBLIC SCHOOL
COMMUNITY AND LEGISLATIVE IN
STATE LEADERS TO FIND COMMON
GROUND AND PLACES WHERE WE
COULD CUT AND THE WAR AND TRY
TO COME TOGETHER AND TOGETHER
WE DID PASS LEGISLATION. TO PUT
THOSE REQUIREMENTS ON PUBLIC
CHARTER SCHOOLS IN WHEN. WE HAD
THE DEBATE ON THIS FLOOR I
TALKED ABOUT I HOPE THAT THIS
WAS AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
FIND PLACES WE CAN COME
TOGETHER. AND NOT CONTINUE THIS
PERPETUAL WAR BETWEEN THESE
DIFFERENT INTEREST GROUPS AND
YET NOW WE HAVE THIS BILL
BEFORE US. AND WHAT STRIKES ME
MORE THAN ANYTHING ABOUT
LEGISLATION LIKE THIS IS THAT.
IN CALIFORNIA TODAY WE HAVE
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT ARE ONSIDERED
FAILING SCHOOLS IN OUR STATE
OVER SEVEN HUNDRED. AND THE AND
THE NUMBER OF SCHOOLS IN LOW
INCOME AREAS IN OUR STATE THAT
ARE FAILING IT X. IT. EQUALS
ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FIVE HUNDRED PUBLIC
SCHOOLS IN CALIFORNIA IN LOW
INCOME AREAS ARE FAILING. AND
HOW MANY OF THOSE ARE CHARTER
SCHOOLS PUBLIC CHARTER SCHOOLS
HOW MANY. LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE.
LESS THAN TWENTY FIVE SO HERE
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT ANOTHER
BURDEN ON PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS THAT GO AGAINST THE
FOUNDING PRINCIPLES OF OUR
CHARTER SCHOOL COMMUNITY AND
WE'RE SITTING HERE DEBATING AN
OBLIGATION ON PUBLIC CHARTERS
AND IGNORING THE BIG PICTURE IN
OUR STATE WHICH IS THAT WE HAVE
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF PUBLIC
SCHOOLS THAT ARE FAILING IN OUR
STATE AND WHERE IS THE DEBATE.
WHERE IS THE CONVERSATION.
ABOUT THAT. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE ANY HEARINGS ABOUT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE ANY FLOOR
DEBATES ABOUT THOSE HUNDREDS OF
FAILING SCHOOLS NO WE DON'T
HAVE THAT WE HAVE THE SHINY Là
OBJECTS IN BILLS LIKE THIS THAT
SAY LET'S PUT MORE BURDEN ON
THE PUBLIC CHARTERS SOMEHOW
THAT'S THE PROBLEM. THAT OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS ARE FACING IN
OUR STATE. AND IT IS NOT. A
FAIR OBSERVATION ABOUT WHAT
MATTERS TO OUR OUR SCHOOL
COMMUNITY TODAY. IT'S THE SHINY
OBJECT THAT SOMEHOW LET'S SAY
HERE'S A PROBLEM LET'S TRY TO
FIX IT WITH MORE BURDENS ON
PUBLIC CHARTERS THAT'S NOT OUR
OUR EDUCATIONAL PROBLEM IN OUR
STATE TODAY AND WHERE IS THE
DEBATE. ON THAT ISSUE. AND I
SAID YOU COLLEAGUES WE DON'T
HAVE A DEBATE ON THAT ISSUE WHY.
TOO BIG TOO HURTFUL TO
EMBARRASSING TO TALK ABOUT. ON
THE FLOOR OF THIS LEGISLATURE
IT SHOULDN'T BE THE REASON. AND
YET WE HAVE A BILL LIKE THIS.
WITH GOOD INTENTIONS BUT GOES
AGAINST EVERYTHING WE TRIED TO
ESTABLISH IN THE PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOL MOVEMENT TO GIVE SOME
FLEXIBILITY. TO GET SOME CHOICE
THE PARENTS TO SEE THEIR KIDS
IN FAILING SCHOOLS AND SAY WHAT
CAN I DO WHAT CHOICES DO I
HAVE. AND THOSE PARENTS HAVE
CHOICES TODAY YOU KNOW WHAT
THAT CHOICES THE CHOICES TO GET
UP EXTRA EARLY IN THE MORNING
TO DRIVE THEIR KIDS TO A SCHOOL
THAT MAY NOT BEING IN THEIR
NEIGHBORHOOD. TO TAKE THEM OUT
OF THEIR PEER GROUP BECAUSE
THEY WANT TO GIVE THERE'S CHILD
THAT ONE CHANCE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL IN THIS WORLD A GOOD
EDUCATION. AND IT'S NOT
HAPPENING TODAY AND SO THEY
HAVE TO GET UP EARLY THEY HAVE
TO HAVE AG ALOT ANGST IN THEIR
LIFE. BECAUSE OF THE IMPACT OF
MOVING THEIR CHILD OUT OF A
PUBLIC SCHOOL IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD THAT'S NOT WORKING
FOR THEIR CHILD. AND WHAT WE DO
HERE LEGISLATION LIKE THIS WE
GIVE THE MORE OPPORTUNITIES.
MORE OVERSIGHT MORE SCRUTINY
NOW. WE GIVE THEM MORE
COMPLEXITY MORE BURDENS. AND I
SUGGEST TO YOU THAT THAT REALLY
ISN'T SERVING OUR SCHOOLS. AND
OUR STUDENTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND THAT IS WHY. WITH THE BEST
OF INTENTIONS I KNOW BY THE
AUTHOR. I WILL CERTAINLY BE A
NO VOTE ON THIS BILL. THANK YOU
CENTER GLAZER MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SEEING AND HEARING NONE SENATOR
DRAWS YOU MAY CLOSE. YES SOME.
I THINK THIS IS VERY SIMPLE.
VERY SHORT SIMPLE POINT LET'S
BRING SOME ACCOUNTABILITY WHY
WOULD ANYBODY BE OPPOSED TO
ACCOUNTABILITY FROM ALL CHARTER
SCHOOLS THEIR PUBLIC SCHOOLS
THERE ARE RESPONSIBILITY AT ALL
THE OTHER ISSUES HAVE BEEN
BROUGHT UP NOTHING HOLDS YOU
BACK FROM BRING UP THOSE
ISSUES. AND DOING SOMETHING
ABOUT THOSE ISSUES THAT YOU'VE
SHOWN SO MUCH PASSION FOR SO
LET'S JUST STICK TO WHAT'S
INVOLVED IN THIS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION AND URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR DRAW SO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE
BATES NOBEL BY BURGESS NO
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CHIANG NO
DELHI NO DODD. THERE ALSO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER NO GONZALEZ HI
GROWTH NO HERTZBERG I HILL.
WESSEL BY TITLE BY JACKSON I
JONES NO LEYVA. I AM A CHOIR.
MITCHELL MONNING I'M MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE
RUBIO. SKINNER AYE STERN AYE
STONE NO NUMBER. IOWA CASKEY
AYE WIENER AYE WILK NO SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTY FIVE SENATOR HER TADO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL EIGHT NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE AN
ACT RELATING TO FOSTER CARE.
SENATOR HER TADO. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE TO
PRESENT AB EIGHTEEN NINETY
EIGHT NINETEEN WHICH BUILT UPON
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORMS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS BEEN
WORKING ON FOR THE PAST FIVE
YEARS WITH THE GOAL OF MOVING
AWAY FROM THE USE OF LONG TERM
GROUP HOMES FOR YOUTH IN FOSTER
CARE. THIS BILL ENSURES THAT WE
CONFORM TO FEDERAL LAW AND WE
CAN CONTINUE TO CLAIM FEDERAL
FUNDS FOR CAN GAP. AND FINALLY
THE BILL WILL EXTEND THE DATA
FINAL PLANTATION OF THE C. C.
R. RATE. STRUCTURE NOW IN THE
FIFTH YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION
THE CONTINUUM OF CARE REFORMS
ARE ALREADY INCREASING YOUTH
PLACEMENT IN FAMILY SETTINGS.
AND TRANSFORMING EXISTING GROUP
HOMES IN TWO PLACES WHERE
YOUTH. WHO ARE NOT ALREADY UP
READY TO LIVE WITH FAMILIES CAN
RECEIVE SHORT TERM INTENSIVE
THERAPY AND SERVICES. AB EIGHT
NINETEEN WILL CONTINUE THESE
EFFORTS TO MAKE SURE THAT ALL
YOUTH LIVING IN FOSTER CARE
CAN. HAVE THEIR NEEDS MET SO
THEY CAN EXPERIENCE SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOMES AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR NAY VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HURTADO MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA I
ATKINS BY BATES BY BILL I
BRIDGES. I BRADFORD I CABALLERO
HI CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD.
DODD DURAZO. GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW AYE
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO
AYE OR TACO. I JACKSON AYE
JONES I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE. HI
MITCHELL. HI HI MONEY BY MORE
LUCK. MORRELL HI NIELSEN. NO IN
HI PORTANTINO. I ROTH AYE RUBIO
I SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE I WOULD COUNTY AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. HI PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. DODD. HI
DORADO. DRAWS OF. MORE LOCK.
MORE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME OR LIKE I
THERE ALSO. HI NIELSEN NOTIFY.
HIGHS FORTY KNOWS ZERO MEMBERS
JUST SO YOU KNOW WE NOW HAVE A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ESTABLISHED
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TO
SEVENTY SIX SENATOR ALAN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE FIFTY FOUR
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AN ACTOR LINDA
BOBCATS. SENATOR ALLEN THE TIME
AND PRESIDENT THIS BILL PLACES
A MORATORIUM ON THE TROPHY
HUNTING A BOBCATS UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE. THE MORE TORRENT
DOES ALLOW FOR EXEMPTIONS TO
PROTECT HUMAN SAFETY PUBLIC
PROPERTY AND LIVESTOCK. BUT
CATS ARE NOT CLASSIFIED AS A
GAME SPECIES BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE AND ARE
NOT KILLED FOR HUMAN
CONSUMPTION. SINCE THE TRAPPING
BAN IS NOW LAW BOBCATS ME ONLY
BE HUNTED AS A TROPHY ANIMAL
HUNTED FOR SPORT AND DISPLAYS
SO THAT'S LIKE THE LAST
STATEWIDE BOBCAT POPULATION
SUSSMAN IS MORE THAN THIRTY
YEARS OLD THIS BILL I SUPPORT
THE NATIONAL WILDLIFE
MANAGEMENT THREE BEST BASED
UPON THE BEST AVAILABLE SCIENCE
RATHER THAN RUN RELIABLE DATA
SOURCES INCLUDING. SELF
REPORTED HUNTER SURVEYS. THE
IDEA IS THAT AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE UPON APPROPRIATION
BY THE LEGISLATURE THE FISH AND
GAME COMMISSION IS PERMITTED
UNDER THE BILL TO REOPEN THE
BOBCAT HUNTING SEASON UPON
DEVELOPING A BOBCAT MANAGEMENT
PLAN THE USES CREDIBLE SCIENCE
AN ECOSYSTEM BASED APPROACH TO
INFORM DECISIONS REGARDING
BOBCAT POPULATIONS INCLUDING A
FAX ON THEIR PREY. DISEASE
ABATEMENT AND BENEFITS TO
FARMERS INCLUDING THE CONTROL
OF INVASIVE SPECIES THE LA
TIMES RECENTLY REPORTED THAT
SCIENTIFIC STUDY SUGGESTS AN
ALMOST ONE IN FOUR CHANCE THAT
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA MOUNTAIN
LIONS CAN BECOME EXTINCT IN
SANTA MONICA AND SANTA ANA
MOUNTAINS WITHIN FIFTY YEARS WE
MUST ENSURE THE BOBCATS A
SIMILAR SPECIES ARE NOT.
DESTINED TO MEET A SIMILAR FATE
CALIFORNIA WILD CATS. ARE MUCH
MORE VALUABLE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ALIVE RATHER THAN DAD.
IN OUR SUCCESSFUL. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN MEMBERS
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BELL I PORGES. NO
BRADFORD BY COMING HERO I
CHIANG I DALY NO DODD. DRAWS A
I GALGIANI. BY GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROW. HERTZBERG AYE
HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE I
JACKSON AYE JONES. LEYVA HI I'M
ACQUIRE. HI MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO MORALE
NO NIELSEN. NO PAN. AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI STERN AYE STONE. NO
NUMBER OUR CASKEY I WINNER BY
WILK BY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES DODD. GROW DOT I.
GROWTH JONES NO. I CITY ONE NO
SEVENTH THE MEASURE PASSES
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING BACK TO
FILE ITEM TWO ZERO FIVE SENATOR
HERTZBERG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
SIXTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON AND
ACTUALLY INTO RECIDIVISM.
CENTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT THIS
MEASURE REQUIRES THE DEPARTMENT
OF CORRECTION CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION TO CONTRACT WITH
AN EXTERNAL RESEARCHER TO
ANALYZE THE EFFECTIVENESS OF
THE PARTNERS SHE'S ME
DEPARTMENTS REHABILITATION
PROGRAM AND REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE THE RESULTS OF THAT
ANALYSIS. RESPONSE TO AN AUDIT
REPORT ISSUED EARLIER THAT A
VALUE WITH THE AFFECTED THIS IS
CD SEE OURS IN PRISON
REHABILITATIVE PROGRAMS THE
FINDINGS WERE TROUBLING I ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
MEASURE. THANK YOU SENATOR
HERTZBERG MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE MEMBERS THIS
IS A CANDIDATE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL SEEING AND HEARING
NONE AYE AYES FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES. BEAR WITH US
FOR ONE MOMENT
. OKAY MEMBERS
WERE GONNA TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER
TWO SIXTEEN. SENATOR LEYVA
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA AN ACT
REALLY INTO EMPLOYMENT. UNDER
LEYVA THE FLORIDA THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD EVENING
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY FIVE WHICH
WOULD IMPROVE HEALTH PUBLIC
HEALTH OFFICIALS ARE MADE AWARE
OF AND HANDLE CASES OF LEAD
POISONING AMONG WORKERS IN
CALIFORNIA THIS IMPORTANT BILL
WILL ALSO HELP PREVENT REPEATED
OR PROLONGED INCIDENTS. OF LEAD
POISONING IN WORKPLACES
SUSTAINED AND REPEATED CASES OF
LEAD POISONING ARE ENTIRELY
PREVENTABLE BUT THE PROTOCOLS
IN PLACE CURRENTLY DO NOT WORK
AT THIS TIME THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH HAS DISCRETION ON
WIN OR WHETHER IT SHOULD REFER
CASES OF LEAD POISONING TO CAL
OSHA. AS A RESULT MANY
EMPLOYEES CAN REMAIN VULNERABLE
TO REPEATED LEAD EXPOSURE FOR
UNDETERMINED AMOUNT OF TIME
BEFORE THE ISSUE IS PROPERLY
ADDRESSED AB THIRTY FIVE IS A
COMMON SENSE MEASURE TO HELP
INSURE THE PROPER
NOTIFICATIONS. AND FOLLOW UP
BETWEEN DPH AND CAL OSHA ARE
MADE IN ORDER TO PROTECT
PRESENT AND FUTURE WORKERS AND
THEIR FAMILIES THIS BILL WILL
SIMPLY REQUIRE CAL OSHA TO
INVESTIGATE WORK SITES THAT
HAVE WORKERS WITH ELEVATED
BLOOD LEVEL. BLOOD LEAD LEVELS
UPON RECEIVING SUCH REPORTS
FROM THE PH WORKER SAFETY
SHOULD BE PARAMOUNT TO NOT JUST
BUSINESSES BUT THE TWO AGENCIES
TASKED WITH PROTECTING THESE
WORKERS MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. IS THERE
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM. SING NINE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ALLEN
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
NOBEL HI PORGES NO BRADFORD. I
CAMBIADO. CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DODD HI THERE ALSO. GALGIANI.
HI GLAZER. GONZALES HI GROWTH
NO HERTZBERG I HILL AYE HUESO.
I TACO. I JACKSON. BY JONES NO
LEYVA I'M ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL
HI MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORRELL NO NIELSEN. NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO. ROTH. BUT YOU KNOW
I ROTH RUBIO I SKINNER. HI
STERN. I STONE. NOVEMBER OUR
CASKEY I WIENER AYE WILK NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN HI. CABALLERO NO NO
DORADO. I GLAZER BY ROTH. THE
ICE TWENTY SEVEN NO TWELVE THE
MEASURE PASSES. MOVING ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTY TWO. AT
AM I THINK WE'RE DOING TWO
FIFTY FOUR. WE'LL TAKE A MOMENT
HERE FOR. WILL TAKE UP ITEM
NUMBER TWO FIFTY FOUR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ ASSEMBLY
BILL EIGHT OH THREE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GIPSON AN ACT RELATING
TO PUBLIC SAFETY. CENTER LEYVA
THE FOUR ACRES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT GOOD EVENING MEMBERS
I RISE AGAIN 2% AB EIGHT OH
THREE WHICH SEEKS TO IMPROVE
THE OVERALL MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIA'S
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS AS THEY
TAKE ON THE STRESSES OF LIFE
AND WORK IN STATE PRISON
FACILITIES CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS
EXPERIENCE A VARIETY OF MENTAL
AND PHYSICAL TRAUMAS AS A
RESULT OF THEIR CAREERS.
ACCORDING TO THE TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN CORRECTIONAL
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL
OFFICERS SURVEY 28% OF
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS REPORTED
FEELING DEPRESSED AND 10% HAVE
EVEN CONSIDERED SUICIDE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS ALSO FACE
HIGHER INCIDENCES OF HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE AND DIABETES AMONG THE
AVERAGE AMERICAN. BECAUSE OF
THIS WELLNESS PROGRAMS ARE
NECESSARY IN ORDER TO INSURE
THEIR HEALTH AND SAFETY
CURRENTLY CDC ARE PROVIDES
RESOURCES FOR OFFICERS BUT
THERE'S NO REQUIREMENT THAT
INPUT FROM OFFICERS BE
SOLICITED AND TAKE IT INTO
CONSIDERATION THIS GAP IN
EXISTING LAW HAS LED TO A
PATCHWORK OF POLICIES RESULTING
IN MANY OFFICES BEING RELUCTANT
TO UTILIZE SUPPORT SERVICES. AB
EIGHT OH THREE WOULD ESTABLISH
WITHIN CDC ARE A PEER SUPPORT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COMMITTEE
TASKED WITH CRAFTING AND
UPDATING A STANDARDIZED STATE
WHAT POLICY FOR THE DEPARTMENTS
PEER SUPPORT PROGRAM MEMBERS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THERE ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
ARCHULETA. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND DIED LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD THE CALIFORNIA
CORRECTIONAL PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL PEACE
OFFICERS THEMSELVES EVERY
SINGLE DAY DEAL WITH LIFE AND
DEATH SITUATION WE HAVE TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE CARE THAT THEY
GIVE THOSE WERE INCARCERATED
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY THE FACT
THAT THERE WRE IN SO MANY HATS
SOCIAL WORKERS SOMETIMES EVEN A
BIG BROTHER'S LITTLE SISTERS
WHATEVER IT MIGHT BE TO TALK TO
THESE INMATES AND THEIR JOBS
RIGHT NOW ARE IN JEOPARDY EVERY
SINGLE DAY. WITH THE THINGS
THAT THEY HAVE TO DEAL WITH
BECAUSE OF THE FACT THAT THERE
IS VIOLENCE WITHIN THAT THE
JAILS THERE IS VIOLENCE WITHIN
THE PRISONS AND THESE MEN AND
WOMEN ARE FACING WITH IT EVERY
SINGLE DAY WE'VE GOT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT THEY GO
THROUGH AND ANY SUPPORT GROUP
ANYTHING THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP
AND SUPPORT THEM I THINK WE
NEED TO FOLLOW SO WHY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE BOAT. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE AT CENTER
LEYVA YOU MAY CONCLUDE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN WITH THEIR HI IT IS
EXCUSE ME MEMBERS THIS IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL IF THERE'S NO OBJECTION
THERE IS AN OBJECTION MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. WE TRY
ARCHULETA. ATKINS ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES HI BILL I
PURCHASED. HI BRADFORD I COVER
EURO I CHIANG AYE DALY AYE DODD
I DORADO I GALGIANI. I GLAZER
BY GONZALEZ I GROWTH HERTZBERG
HI. HILL AYE HUESO AYE OR TITLE.
HI JACKSON BY JONES I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK MORALE BY
NELSON. PAN AYE PORTANTINO.
ROTH AYE RUBIO AYE SKINNER I
STERN AYE STONE AYE AMBERG ABA
CASKEY BY WIENER. I WILK HI.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ALLEN HI. GROVE MOORLACH
NIELSEN HI. ICE THIRTY EIGHT NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO SEVENTY
TWO. MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN OH
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL ENACT WILLING TO
CHARTER SCHOOLS. SENATOR LEYVA
THE FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD EVENING AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE REFORMS THE
CHARTER SCHOOL AUTHORIZATION
OVERSIGHT APPEAL AND RENEWAL
PROCESSES THIS BILL REPRESENTS
AN AGREEMENT BETWEEN THE AUTHOR
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE THE LABOR
COMMUNITY AND THE CHARTER
SCHOOL ASSOCIATION. AB FIFTEEN
OH FIVE ACCOMPLISHES
COMPREHENSIVE CHARTER SCHOOL
REFORM BY ADDRESSING SEVERAL
KEY ISSUES THE FIRST IS
COMMUNITY IMPACT LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARDS AND ADMINISTRATORS NO
THERE DISTRICTS AND STUDENTS
BEST AND SHOULD HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DETERMINE WHICH
CHARTERS CAN BEST SERVE THEIR
STUDENTS. THIS BILL GIVES
DISTRICTS GREATER FLEXIBILITY
TO CONSIDER HOW A CHARTER%
SCHOOL WILL IMPACT COMMUNITY
AND TO DETERMINE WHETHER A
PROPOSED CHARTER SCHOOL WILL
SUBSTANTIALLY UNDERMINE
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND SERVICES
STUDENTS AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
ALSO ADDRESSES THE APPEAL
PROCESS. IT CONTINUESTO ALLOW
A FULL APPEAL TO THE COUNTY
BOARD OF EDUCATION AND REFORMS
THE APPEAL PROCESS AT THE STATE
LEVEL ON THE ISSUE OF TEACHER
CREDENTIALS IT ENSURES THAT
CHARTER TEACHERS ARE QUALIFIED.
THE BILL CLARIFIES THAT ALL
TEACHERS IN CHARTER SCHOOLS
MUST HOLD THE RECORD CREDENTIAL
FOR THEIR ASSIGNMENT WITH A
TRANSITION PERIOD VIRTUAL
SCHOOLS HAVE ALSO BEEN
ADDRESSED THIS BILL ESTABLISHES
A TWO YEAR MORATORIUM ON NON
CLASSROOM BASS CHARTERS WITH A
COMMITMENT TO ADDRESS NEEDED
REFORMS FOR THESE SCHOOLS
DURING THAT TWO YEAR PERIOD.
FINALLY THERE IS THE ISSUE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY THE BILL
REQUIRES CHARTER AUTHORIZES TO
USE THE STATE ACCOUNTABILITY
SYSTEM FOR THE BASIS OF CHARTER
RENEW ALL HIGH PERFORMING
CHARTERS WILL RECEIVE UP TO A
SEVEN YEAR RENEWAL WELL LOW
PERFORMING CHARTERS WILL
EITHER. CLOSE OR RECEIVE A TWO
YEAR RENEWAL. MIDDLE PERFORMING
SCHOOLS WILL CONTINUE TO
RECEIVE A FIVE YEAR RENEWAL
PERIOD. AB FIFTY NO FIVE IS A
PRODUCT OF COUNTLESS HOURS AND
COMPROMISE IT IS AN IMPORTANT
STEP IN ENSURING THAT WE HAVE A
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT
SERVES THE NEEDS OF EVERY
STUDENT. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON FIFTEEN OH
FIVE. SENATOR JONES. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE
TONIGHT'S TO OPPOSE AB FIFTEEN
OH FIVE. THIS BILL IS JUST
ANOTHER ATTACK OF THE MANY THIS
YEAR ON CHARTER SCHOOLS. I
GUESS THE THEME OF TODAY'S US
SENATE SESSION IS LET'S JUST
TAKE AWAY PEOPLE'S LIBERTY.
THIS BILL EFFECTIVELY IMPOSES A
MORATORIUM ON CHARTER SCHOOLS
NO IT IS NOT WIDE TO MEDIA
COVERAGE ON THE ISSUE SAYS THAT
THERE HAS BEEN A TRUCE BETWEEN
CTA. AND THE CHARTER SCHOOLS.
HOWEVER I URGE YOU TO READ THE
LIST OF REGISTERED OPPOSITION
AND SEE HOW MANY CHARTER
SCHOOLS IN YOUR OWN DISTRICTS.
ARE STILL OPPOSE AND ADAMANTLY
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
HALTS THEIR ABILITY TO EDUCATE
STUDENTS. OFTENTIMES STUDENTS
THAT NO ONE ELSE IS WILLING TO
EDUCATE MEMBERS I ASK FOR A NO
VOTE ON A. B. FIFTEEN OH FIVE.
SENATOR STONE. THINK ABOUT A
PRESIDENT. HE DOES OFTEN
MENTION ON THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE THAT WE HAVE THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY. IN THE WORLD.
AND ONE THING THAT. WE NEED TO
DO IF WE'RE GOING TO MAINTAIN.
OUR SUCCESS AS A. DEMOCRACY IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THRIVE AS A STATE IS HAVING A
WELL EDUCATED WORK FORCE. I WAS
VERY PLEASED WITH THE SENATOR
FROM MERENDA. WHO BROUGHT
FORWARD A SUBJECT THAT IS
RARELY TALK ABOUT ON THIS FLOOR.
AND THAT IS OUR FEELING PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM. IN RESPONSE TO
OUR FAILING PUBLIC SCHOOL
SYSTEM. WE HAVE HAD A CHARTER
SCHOOL. MOMENTOUS THIS
EXPANSION ASPECT HATED I CAN
TELL YOU IN THE TWENTY SENATE
DISTRICT WE HAVE A NUMBER OF
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHERE THERE IS.
FOUR DIGIT. WAITING LISTS FOR
KIDS TO GET INTO THESE SCHOOLS.
BECAUSE THEY ARE PERFORM THEIR
PUBLIC SCHOOL COUNTERPARTS. BY
A LARGE MAGNITUDE A LOT OF
THOSE KIDS ARE GRADUATING FROM
HIGH SCHOOL AND GOING TO FIRST
CLASS UNIVERSITIES AND COLLEGES
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES. YOU
KNOW I'VE MENTIONED ON MORE
THAN ONE OCCASION ON THIS FLOOR
THAT. WE HAVE A CAUCUS CITIZEN
OFFICIALLY RECOGNIZED ON A CALL
OF THE LABOR CAUCUS. I THINK
IT'S APPROPRIATE THAT THE
SPOKESPERSON FOR THE LABOR
CAUCUS IS ONE WHO CALLED
HERSELF LABOR HERSELF. AND I
THINK IT'S VERY FORTUNATE WHEN
WE ALLOW. UNIONS TO DICTATE.
HOW WE ARE GOING TO RUN OUR
SCHOOL SYSTEMS HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
HAS IMMENSE POWER. AND THEY
LIKE TO EXERT THAT POWER. IN
ITS WELL OBSERVED ON THE FLOOR
OF THE SENATE HERE TODAY. AND
THE U. INFLUENCE OF UNIONS
WELL DEMONSTRATED IN THE FINAL
WEEKS OF THE SESSION TO THE
DETRIMENT. OF SO MANY PEOPLE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IF
WE REALLY CARE ABOUT THE
QUALITY OF PUBLIC EDUCATION. WE
SHOULD LEARN SOMETHING BY THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS AND LEARN WHAT
THEY'RE DOING RIGHT. AND FIGURE
OUT WHAT WE'RE DOING WRONG IN
OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM. MAYBE
TOO MUCH GERRYMANDERING. BY
UNIONS LOOKING OUT FOR THE BEST
INTEREST OF TEACHERS AND
ENSURING THAT THERE'S TENURE
FOR TEACHERS THAT DON'T DESERVE
TO BE TEACHING BECAUSE OUR
LOUSY TEACHERS. NOT TO MENTION
THE 90% OF TEACHERS THAT ARE
OUT THERE THEY'RE GREAT THEY'RE
REALLY WANT TO DO THE JOB MANY
OF WHOM ARE REPUBLICANS AND
REALLY. WOULD LIKE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE
UNCONSTRAINED. AND THEY HAVE
THE ABILITY TO USE OUR TALENTS
TO TEACH OUR STUDENTS. THE WAY
I RECEIVED A PUBLIC EDUCATION
WHEN I WAS GOING TO SCHOOL.
THIS AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IS NOTHING MORE THAN ATTACK ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS. A MAJORITY
WHICH HAVE HAD TREMENDOUS
SUCCESS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. FOR THOSE REASONS I
URGE A NO VOTE ON AB FIFTY NO
FIVE. IF YOU'RE PART OF THE
LABOR CAUCUS WILL BE LOOKING
FOR YOUR YES VOTE ON AB FIFTY
NO FIVE. BETTER NIELSEN. THAT
ARE PRESENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE I'M JUST
GOING TO. REFER TO THE. AND I
USUALLY READ THE BILLS BUT HERE
I DON'T NEED TO GO ANY FURTHER
THAN THE ANALYSIS. CERTAINLY
VALIDATES THE THINGS I SAID A
FEW MINUTES AGO. END OF THE
DIVERT DAYS OF CHARTER SCHOOLSARE ADVOCATES THERE FOR OR FOR.
WHO SAY THEY BUY INTO THIS. I
WOULD OFFER SOME ADVICE.
THEY'LL COME AROUND AND TALK TO
ME. ELECTED USE HYPOCRITES. IT
DON'T COMPLAIN. AND ONE OF THE
ACTIONS AROUND HERE IS STILL A
MAN AND A BAD DEAL. I CAN
ENVISION MEETINGS WITH SOME OF
THESE INDIVIDUALS MORE THEY
NEGOTIATED TO AMEND THE BILL.
SO WHAT WOULD BE ONE OF THE
AMENDMENTS. THE RENEWALS IT
WOULD BE ALTERED FROM FIVE.
YEARS TO SEVEN. NOW THAT MEANS.
FIVE IT DOESN'T MEAN FIVE TO
SEVEN. THAT IS NOT HOW IT'S
GONNA WORK OUT. HERE'S ONE THAT
THEY SHOULD BE HUGELY
EMBARRASSED IF THEY'VE MADE A
DEAL. ELIMINATES ACADEMIC
IMPROVEMENT AS THE MOST
IMPORTANT CONSIDERATION WHEN
REVIEWING A CHARTER SCHOOL.
THAT IS NOT THE MOST IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION. IF THAT IS NOT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN WHAT IN
THE WORLD IS. IT ALLOWS THE. OR
PROHIBITS THE APPROVAL OF A
PETITION. FOR A NEW NON
CLASSROOM. BASED CHARTER SCHOOL.
FROM JANUARY. TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWO TO TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY TWO END QUOTE MOST
CIRCUMSTANCE. SO NOW WE'RE
GONNA PUT A CAP THE STOCK.
BASED ON WHAT EVIDENCE NOW THAT
MAY HAVE COME UP IN COMMITTEE I
WOULD HOPE THAT SOMEONE. IN THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE HAD ASKED
THE QUESTION. WHAT DOES THIS DO
WHAT DOES IT ACCOMPLISH. I'D
LIKE TO KNOW. THAT I LIKE SOME
OF THOSE CHARTER FOLKS WHO
BOUGHT INTO THIS DEAL COMING
EXPLAINED TO ME. WHAT THIS DOES.
NO. THIS IS ANOTHER SLIPPERY
SLOPE NOW THIS IS JUMPING OVER
THE CLIFF. I CLOSE WITH
ELIMINATES ACADEMIC IMPROVEMENT
AS THE MOST IMPORTANT
CONSIDERATION WHEN REVIEWING A
CHARTER SCHOOL. NEED I OR
ANYONE SAY MORE. CENTER SKINNER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I STAND IN SUPPORT OF
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE. I'M THERE
WAS A INDEPENDENT STUDY
COMMISSION TO EXAMINE THE
FINANCIAL IMPACT OF THE GROWTH
OF CHARTER SCHOOLS IN MY
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT OAKLAND
UNIFIED. THAT STUDY SHOWED THAT
OVER THE PAST FIVE YEARS
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY NINE POINT
TWO MILLION. IN REVENUE THAT
OTHERWISE WOULD HAVE GONE TO
UST. WAS DIVERTED DUE TO THE
GROWTH OF CHARTER SCHOOLS NO
OAKLAND UST HAS FORTY FIVE
CHARTER SCHOOLS THE HIGHEST
PROPORTION OF ANY LARGE SCHOOL
DISTRICT IN THE STATE. A
SIMILAR FINANCIAL IMPACT WAS
ALSO IDENTIFIED ON MY SECOND
LARGEST SCHOOL DISTRICT WEST
CONTRA COSTA UNIFIED. BOTH OF
THESE SCHOOL DISTRICTS GET A
VERY SIGNIFICANT FUNDING FOR
OUR AREA DOES OF THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA BECAUSE
OF OUR HIGH PERCENT OF CHILDREN
ON FREE AND REDUCED LUNCH
CHILDREN WITH ENGLISH AS A
SECOND LANGUAGE AND A VARIETY
OF OTHER CRITERIA THAT MAKES
ONE ELIGIBLE FOR THE LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING FORMULA. NOW
INTERESTINGLY ENOUGH. BOTH
OAKLAND UNIFIED IN WEST CONTRA
COSTA HAVE BEEN STRUCTURING
STRUGGLING SIGNAL. WITH THE
GREAT FINANCIAL BURDEN. NOW
THEIR COSTS ARE HIGHER WHY.
BECAUSE OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS OR
NON CHARTER SCHOOLS AND I
REALIZE OUR CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
ALSO PUBLIC BUT ARE NON CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE NOT REQUIRED TO
HAVE CREDENTIALED TEACHERS WERE
ES. MY SCHOOLS IN OAKLAND
UNIFIED IN WEST CONTRA COSTA
THEY MUST HAVE CREDENTIALED
TEACHERS SO. THAT MAY BE ONE OF
THE REASONS WHY. I'VE YET TO
FIND A STUDY THAT DEMONSTRATES
THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS PROVIDE A
DOCUMENTED BETTER EDUCATION
THAN TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
I THINK THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
I'M GLAD THERE WAS NEGOTIATIONS
THAT CAME TO A PLACE WHERE MORE
PEOPLE WERE ABLE TO GET IN
SUPPORT. BUT I THINK THAT OUR
CHILDREN DESERVE TO HAVE
CREDENTIALED TEACHERS AND- OUR
TWO SCHOOLS SYSTEMS THAT ARE
SUPPORTED BY OUR PUBLIC FUNDS
DESERTED ME HVE TO MEET THE
SAME STANDARDS AND WITH THAT I
ASKED FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
SENATOR STERN. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND I'LL BE BRIEF I
JUST WANT TO THANK. THE AUTHOR
AND ESPECIALLY THE GOVERNOR FOR.
STEPPING IN AND PLAYING A
CRITICAL ROLE IN. CRAFTING A
FRAMEWORK THAT I THINK IS
HISTORIC. NOTE POLITICAL
RHETORIC ASIDE. I AM PROUD TO
STAND WITH TEACHERS ANY DAY OF
THE WEEK. BUT THIS BILL IS NOT
ABOUT BEING ANTI CHARTER PRO
CHARTER PRO UNION OR ANTI UNION.
THIS IS A FRAMEWORK THAT SAYS
IF YOU'RE A HIGH QUALITY WELL
PERFORMING SCHOOL. AND YOU OF
YOUR KIDS IN THAT SCHOOL WHEN
YOU'RE A PARENT THERE YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE SOME CERTAINTY
THAT SCHOOL WILL CONTINUE TO
GET TO DO ITS WORK. WE HAVE IN
MY DISTRICT LAUSD WHICH IS
SIMILARLY SITUATED. DISTRICT IN
TERMS OF THE FINANCIAL BURDENS
TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY.
WE HAVE AN INCREDIBLY HIGH
INCIDENCE OF PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS. THAT ARE WITHIN LAUSD
THAT ARE RUN BY. TEACHERS WHO
ARE UNION. BUT WHOSE PARENTS
WERE UNCERTAIN AND ANXIOUS WHEN
THE FIRST VERSION IS BILL CAME
FORWARD AS TO WHAT. KIND OF
HOOPS THEY WOULD HAVE TO JUMP
FRUIT THROUGH TO MAKE SURE
THEIR KIDS CAN KEEP GOING TO
SCHOOL GET THAT QUALITY
EDUCATION WE TALK ABOUT. I
THINK THIS IS A DURABLE AND
HISTORIC FRAMEWORK THAT WE CAN
BUILD ON AND SOME DAY. MAYBE
BREAK THIS IMPASSE WE CAN GET
THE POLITICS OUT OF OUR SCHOOL
SYSTEM AND JUST START
EMPOWERING TEACHERS AND
STUDENTS TO DO WHAT THEY DO
BEST WHICH IS TEACHING LEARNED
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. SENATOR GROWTH. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
OPPOSITION OF AB FIFTEEN OH
FIVE YOU KNOW CHARTER SCHOOLS
AND THEIR FAMILIES HAVE A VERY
VITAL ROLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED SIXTY THOUSAND A
STUDENTS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THAT IT TEN CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
GIVE PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICT
MORE AUTHORITY SO IT'S
COMPARABLE TO ST WALMART AND
YOU WILL APPROVE IF TARGET CAN
COME IN AND BE NEXT TO YOU TO
COMPETE. AND WALMART CAN SAY
THAT INTERFERES WITH MY ABILITY
TO MAKE MONEY AND SO THAT'S
KIND OF THE SAME THING SO
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WILL BE ABLE TO
SAY NO CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN'T
COME IN BECAUSE IT AFFECTS MY
ABILITY TO RETAIN MONEY MY
COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY AND MY
COLLEAGUE FROM THOUSAND OAKS
AVENTURA YOU MADE THE COMMEN
ABOUT. MORE CHARTER SCHOOLS ARE
GETTING MORE STUDENTS AWAY FROM
PUBLIC SCHOOLS WHICH IS
CREATING A FINANCIAL IMPACT
WELL IF THE PUBLIC SCHOOLS WERE
DOING AND SRVING THOSE
STUDENTS BETTER THAN THE
CHARTER SCHOOLS WHICH IS
COMPETITION THEN THOSE PARENTS
WOULDN'T CHOOSE TO SEND THEIR
CHILDREN TO THOSE CHARTER
SCHOOLS SO I ASK YOU TO THINK
ABOUT THAT WE HAVE TWO CHARTER
SCHOOL MAIN CHARTER SCHOOLS IN
OUR DISTRICT WE HAVE GRAHAM WAY
COUNTY ME AND WE HAVE PARAMOUNT
BARRED. THE MAINLY SERVICE
SHAFTER ARVIN LAMONT AND WASCO
WHICH IS A MAJORITY MINORITY
DISTRICT AND FARMING
COMMUNITIES THOSE SCHOOLS HAVE
BOTH BEEN LABEL DISTINGUISH
MOST DISTINGUISHED SCHOOLS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THOSE
STUDENTS THAT WERE FAILING IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM IN THE
TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS HAVE NOW
BEEN EXCELLING IN THOSE SCHOOLS
AND THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOING ON
TO COLLEGE BECAUSE THE STUDENTS
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ATTEND A CHARTERSCHOOL THEY'VE
WITH CHANGING THEIR SCHEDULE
FOR INSTANCE LIKE FROM
KINDERGARTEN OR FIRST GRADE
THROUGH EIGHTH GRADE DATE
CHANGE EVERY FIFTEEN DID EVERY
TWENTY MINUTES VERSES EVERY
HOUR AND A HALF. THE KIDS. MORE
OF AN ATTENTION SPAN TEACHERS
TEACH ON SUBJECT MATTER ONLY SO
THERE THE EXPERT IN THAT
SUBJECT MATTER WHICH GETS THE
KIDS THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE
TO LEARN THAT SUBJECT MATTER
BETTER. AND WITH THE HIGHER
QUALITY OF EDUCATION THEY HAVE
A LEARNING LAB WHERE THE
STUDENTS HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SELECT AND TOUR COLLEGES AT
EIGHTH GRADE IN EVEN A FRESHMAN
IN HIGH SCHOOL. AND MORE
STUDENTS THAT ATTEND THESE
CHARTER SCHOOLS GO OFF TO
COLLEGE THAN IN THE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOL SETTING. YOU HAVE
STUDENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
DELINQUENT OR STUDENTS THAT
HAVE NOT PARTICIPATED OR NOT
I'M GOING TO THE TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BUT WHEN YOU PUT
A MINUTE. CHARTER SCHOOL
SETTING THEY TEND TO EXCEL AND
ATTEND CLASSES SO THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS ARE VITALLY IMPORTANT
AND ALLOW OUR STUDENTS TO BE
GAINFULLY. BE MORE ENGAGED IN
SCHOOL AND TO SAY THAT THEY
HAVE TO GET APPROVAL FROM AN
ORDER MISSION SCHOOL DISTRICT
THAT IS OPPOSED TO. OR BASED ON
A FINANCIAL INCENTIVE FOR A
FINANCIAL BURDEN. IT'S JUST
SIMPLE TO SAY JUST LIKE I SAID
WITH WALMART TARGET WALMART CAN
SAY TARGET NO YOU'RE GONNA
AFFECT MY FINANCES SO THEREFORE
YOU CAN'T COME IN. THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND SAY YOU'RE GONNA
AFFECT MY FINANCES SO THEY'RE
FOR CHARTER SCHOOLS CAN BE
RENEWED. I JUST ASK YOU TO VOTE
NO AND THINK ABOUT THE STUDENTS
THAT ARE AFFECTED BY THIS BILL.
SENATOR ALLEN. WELL IT'S TRUE
THAT IS A SCHOOL DISTRICT CAN
MAKE A DECISION BASED ON
FINANCES TO SOME EXTENT BUT YET
REMEMBER THAT'S WHY THE
APPROVED AND KEPT THE APPEAL
RIGHT NOW IS ONE OF THE ISSUES
I KNOW THAT WAS IT WAS A REAL
PROBLEM FOR THE C. CSA WHEN THE
BILL WAS OVER ON THE ASSEMBLY
SIDE BUT THE FACT IS IF THERE
IS AN OVERLY POLITICIZED
DECISION MADE AT THE SCHOOL
BOARD LEVEL THEY CAN BE
APPEALED. TO THE COUNTY AND THE
COUNTY WOULD HAS ABSOLUTE DO
NOVO REVIEW WHICH MEANS THAT
THEY CAN LOOK AT THE AT THE
APPLICATION WITHOUT REGARD FOR
ANY FINDING MADE BY THE LOCAL
SCHOOL BOARD AND THEN BY THE
WAY IF THERE'S ANY ABUSE OF
DISCRETION IN EITHER OF THE
LOCAL OR THE COUNTY LEVELS
THERE'S ALSO APPEAL RIGHTS AT
THE STATE LEVEL SO THOSE ARE
ALL AND REALLY IMPORTANT I
THINK YOU WOULD YOU CREATE
THESE BOARDS OF DIFFERENT
EDUCATION POLICYMAKERS. AND WE
TRUST THEM WITH THE DISCRETION
TO MAKE DECISIONS A THINKER IN
THE BEST INTEREST OF THE
STUDENTS IN THAT THEIR
COMMUNITY SO I HAVE TO SAY I'M
I THINK THIS IS A STORE
COMPROMISE THIS IS A BATTLE
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS
AND YEARS ANYBODY WHO'S BEEN
AROUND HERE KNOWS THAT THAT WAS
ABOUT IT WAS NOT GOING TO GO
AWAY UNTIL THERE WAS SOME FORM
OF A DEAL STRUCK AND I ACTUALLY
THINK THAT THEY STRUCK. THE
RIGHT BALANCE AND I WILL SAY TO
MY FRIENDS WERE CONCERNED.
CHARTER SCHOOLS FIGHT IT THIS
THIS THIS DEAL DOES A FIRM THAT
IF YOU ARE. AN EXISTING HIGH
QUALITY CHARTER SCHOOL THAT IS
YOU KNOW THAT IS PLAYING BY THE
RULES YOU ARE HERE TO STAY.
THAT WAS UP FOR QUESTION BEFORE
IT ALSO SAYS THAT IT FOR
EXISTING AND NEW CHARTER
SCHOOLS A LIKE A DIFFERENCE OF
CHARTERS ACTUALLY HAVE A REALLY
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY. IN
CLOSING ARGUMENT GAPS SO I
THINK DID YOU. DO DID YOU CAN
NOW THERE'S A BIG DEAL AND
THERE'S A LOT OF THINGS IN
THERE WE CAN WE CAN WE CAN
PARSE APART. BUT I THINK WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO THREAD A VERY
DIFFICULT DEAL HERE WITH THE
STEEL AND I COMMEND THE FOLKS.
WHO WERE INVOLVED IN IN
<c.green>RAFTING THIS. I THINK WE'VE</c>
WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE WE'VE STRUCK
A BALANCE BETWEEN PROVIDING
IMPORTANT AMOUNT OF DISCRETION
TO THE FOLKS THAT WE ENTRUST.
WITH RUNNING OUR SCHOOL SYSTEM
BOTH OF THE LOCAL AND COUNTY
LEVELS WERE ALSO CUT COUNTING
FOR THE FACT. THAT SOMETIMES
DECISIONS TO GET OVERLY
POLITICIZED AND I'M AND IN
ALLOWING AS A RESULT FOR AND
PRESERVING. THOSE APPEAL
RIGHTS. AND WITH THAT I'LL BE
VOTING AYE. SENATOR BURGESS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT. THIS
IS A HOT BUTTON TOPIC IN MY
HOUSEHOLD. MY MOTHER WAS A LONG
TERM FACULTY MEMBER IN PUBLIC
IN AT A PUBLIC INSTITUTION. AND
I REMEMBER CHATTING WITH HER
ABOUT THE MERITS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS VERSUS TRADITIONAL
PUBLIC SCHOOLS. AND. SHE
BROUGHT UP SOME VERY IMPRESSIVE
POINTS. AND I DID MY BEST TO
BRING OUT WHAT I BILL LAW WHAT
WHAT I BELIEVED WERE IMPRESSIVE
POINTS AS WELL. AND THEN I
CAN'T CAME UPON THIS ISSUE OF.
WHAT IF THE ROLES WERE REVERSED.
WHAT IF PUBLIC SCHOOLS
TRADITIONAL PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
NEEDED TO GO THROUGH
AUTHORIZATION. THE WAY. THAT WE
IMPOSED UPON CHARTER SCHOOLS.
WELL SHOULD INDIVIDUALS WOULD
CERTAINLY OBJECT TO THAT. AND
WHAT HAPPENS IF WE HAD A FIVE
YEAR PROVE UP PERIOD. IF WE HAD
A FIVE YEAR PROVE UP PERIOD FOR
THAT INSTITUTION TO DEMONSTRATE
ITS ACADEMIC EXCELLENCE. BUT
WAIT LET'S MAKE IT TWO TO
SEVEN. HOW WOULD A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION TO RESPOND TO THAT.
PROBABLY NOT FAVORABLY HOW
ABOUT A PUBLIC INSTITUTION THAT
WOULD BE FORCED TO CLOSE IF IT
WAS NOT PERFORMING ADEQUATELY
WITH THAT HAPPENED IN FRESNO
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN MY
NECK OF THE WOODS WHICH IS ONE
THE LARGEST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN THE ANSWER WOULD
BE NO. THEY WOULD NOT CLOSE
DOWN. SO THIS IDEA THAT.
THERE'S A LEVEL PLAYING FEAR
FIELD BY SOME OF THE FOLKS THAT
HAVE COMMENTED EARLIER AND ONE
OF THEM FROM MORE MY ONE OF MY
FRIENDS FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA IS THAT IF YOU WERE
HIGH PERFORMING YOU ARE HERE TO
STAY. WOMAN TO THROW THAT RIGHT
BACK. IF YOU'RE A PUBLIC
INSTITUTION IN YOUR HIGH
PERFORMING YOU ARE HERE TO STAY.
A CHARTER SCHOOL WOULD NOT BE
NEEDED IF THE SCHOOLS WERE HIGH
PERFORMING IN HERE TO STAY BUT
THAT'S JUST ME THAT THAT IS
JUST NOT THE CASE. AND SO I
KNOW THAT THIS IS THE SECOND
TIME OR MORE THAN WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT CHARTER SCHOOLS AND WHAT
IT MEANS FOR FUTURE. BUT I HAVE
TWO LITTLE BOYS WERE EIGHT AND
SIX IN THIS IS KITCHEN. OUR
DINING TABLE DISCUSSION THAT I
HAVE WITH MY WIFE ALL THE TIME.
SHE DOESN'T NECESSARILY CARE
NOR DO Y. NOR DO MY CHILDREN
ABOUT FACULTY TENURE. THEY
DON'T NECESSARILY CARE ABOUT
THESE OTHER TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OF EMPLOYMENT WE
CARE ABOUT. ALL OF THE
EDUCATION THAT WILL ALLOW THEM
UPWARD MOBILITY IN A LFESTYLE
THAT WE'VE TAKEN FOR GRANTED
HILL. WE ARE NOT BETTER OFF
THAN OUR PARENTS IS CERTAINLY
NOT BETTER OFF THAN OUR
GRANDPARENTS. BUT I LOSE
PATIENCE WITH THIS IDEA THAT.
THAT THIS IS LEVELING THE
PLAYING FIELD. THIS ISN'T
LEVELING THE PLAYING FIELD.
THIS IS FORCIBLY GETTING ONE
PARTY TO CRY UNCLE. SO WHEN WE
CALL THIS A COMPROMISE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IT MEANS ONE PARTY
SIMPLY DOESN'T HAVE THE
POLITICAL MUSCLE TO GO UP
AGAINST OTHERS AND THEY ARE
CRYING UNCLE IN WILL RESORT TO
COMPROMISE TO STATE IN
EXISTENCE. AND I KNOW THAT WE
MAY HAVE PHILOSOPHICAL
DIFFERENT DISAGREEMENTS ON ON
THIS ISSUE. BUT IF I GO BACK IN
FLIP THE FLIP THE TABLE ON THIS
IN OPPOSED TO SAME REQUIREMENTS
ON TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS THAT WE HAVE ON
CHARTER SCHOOLS. THIS WOULD NOT
EXIST AS A DEBATE TODAY. IT
WOULD NOT AT ALL AND I WOULD
ASK MY COLLEAGUES. IF THIS IS
TRULY ABOUT EDUCATING OUR
CHILDREN. THEN LET THE MERITS
OF THIS INDUSTRY SIX FEET. OR
FAIL ON ON ITS OWN WEIGHT. THAT
IS THE BEAUTY OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS THE RIGHTS OR FEEL ON
THEIR OWN MERITS BUT WE DON'T
WANT TO GIVE THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOSE
INSTITUTIONS TO RISE IN THAT IS
WHERE I HAVE PROBLEMS AS A
FATHER. AS A PARENT AS A
HUSBAND IT'S JUST NOT RIGHT. I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK MY
COLLEAGUES TO RECOGNIZE THIS
FOR WHAT IT IS. IN VOTE THIS
PIECE OF LEGISLATION DOWN.
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU WELL
FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD TO IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WE TALK ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AND AS AN ELEMENTARY
SCHOOL TEACHER IN THE PUBLIC
SCHOOLS FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS I
DO RISE TO SUPPORT THIS BILL
THERE ARE MANY REASONS TO DO SO
BUT TO IN PARTICULAR STAND OUT
WELL FIRST IT MAKES A
SIGNIFICANT STEPS TOWARDS
HELPING THE FINANCIAL STABILITY
OF OUR PUBLIC SCHOOL DISTRICTS
WALLET KNOWLEDGE GENE THAT WE
DO NEED. HIGH QUALITY CHARTER
SCHOOLS AS PART OF THE
EDUCATION OPPORTUNITIES FOR OUR
STUDENTS SECONDLY AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY. BY SETTLING THIS
DISCUSSION I HOPE THAT WE CAN
NOW MOVED AND TACKLE THE BIGGER
ISSUES FACING OUR PUBLIC
SCHOOLS. EDUCATION IS ONE OF MY
TOP PRIORITIES AND I FEEL VERY
STRONGLY ABOUT THIS I DON'T
WANT US TO HAVE US FALL SENSE
THAT THIS IS A FIX AND THIS IS
GOING TO SOLVE OUR ISSUES IN
THE PUBLIC SCHOOL. SECTOR. I
WOULD LIKE US TO CONTINUE TO
HAVE A DISCUSSION. ASKED TO
IMPACTS DIRECTLY IN OUR
CLASSROOMS FOR EXAMPLE WE NEED
TO TALK ABOUT CLASS SIZE
REDUCTION. WE NEED TO BREAK
BACK HARD MUSIC PROGRAMS IN OUR
SCHOOLS WHICH AND RE IN RICH
AND BOOST THE LEARNING
EXPERIENCES OF OUR STUDENTS
STUDENTS LEARN DIFFERENTLY AND
MANY NEED TO EXPRESS THEMSELVES
NOT JUST ACADEMICALLY. WE NEED
TO PROPERTY EQUIP OUR
CLASSROOMS WITH TECHNOLOGY AND
ENSURE THAT EACH AND EVERY
STUDENT HOUSE THE TECHNOLOGY
THEY NEED TO SUCCEED WHICH WE
CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE. WE NEED
TO PROPERLY FUND NURSES IN OUR
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL MIDDLE
SCHOOLS AND HIGH SCHOOLS. PHIL
TEACHERS DON'T HAVE TO PLAY
NURSE DURING TEACHING TIME WE
NEED TO ENGAGE IN VIGOROUS
DISCUSSIONS ON UPDATING
ANTIQUATED TEACHING PREPARATION
PROGRAMS ND TASKS FOR STUDENTS
AND ART TEACHERS. AS WELL AS
MANY OTHER ISSUES THAT ARE SO
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO SUPPORT
OUR TEACHERS OUR STUDENTS AND
OUR STAFFS I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE ALL
OF YOU ON ALL THESE CRITICAL
ISSUES THAT WILL HELP OUR
PUBLIC SCHOOLS BECOME BETTER
AND WITH THAT I ALSO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL
THANK YOU. SENATOR MOORLACH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT WE
ARE HAVING A DEBATE ON PUBLIC
SCHOOL SO THANK YOU VERYMUCH I
WANT TO DISCLOSE THAT MY ONE OF
MY BROTHERS IS A SCHOOL TEACHER
WITH ANAHEIM UNION HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND MY OTHER BROTHER I
HAVE TWO BROTHERS HIS WIFE WAS
A TEACHER AT SANTA ANA UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE. ONE
DISCLOSE THAT. SO SCHOOLS ARE
IMPORTANT TO ME AND SO WHEN WE
GRABBED ALL THE FINANCIAL
STATEMENTS FOR THE NINE HUNDRED
AND FORTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS LAST
YEAR WHICH WAS NOT AN EASY JOB
COLLEAGUES TO GET ALL THAT DATA
BECAUSE THERE'S NO. REPOSITORY
FOR THOSE REPORTS. BUT WHEN WE
WERE DONE WITH THE- LOOKING AT
THE FINANCIAL REPORTS THE
AUDITS AS OF JUNE THIRTY.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN I LITERALLY
GOT DEPRESSED AT HOW. SOBERING
THE NUMBERS WERE SO YOU TAKE
ASSETS LESS LIABILITIES EQUALS
THE NET ASSETS ARE OWNERS
EQUITY OR WHATEVER RETAIN
EARNINGS WHATEVER TERM YOU WANT
TO USE FROM YOUR ACCOUNTING
CLASSES. AND THEN YOU YOU TAKE
THAT NET ASSET IN YOUR REDUCE
IT BY A MONEY. I'M OUT THAT
THAT IS YOURS THAT SHOWS THAT
YOU HAVE SOME NETWORK SOME
pNUMBERS ARE STAGGERING WHEN WE
ADDED ALL NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY. THE NUMBER FOR THE NET
UNRESTRICTED NET DEFICIT. WAS
FIFTY POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS.
WE DID IT AGAIN THIS YEAR ADD
IT ALL UP FOR THE- SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ALL NINE HUNDRED AND
FORTY. AND THE NUMBER WAS
SEVENTY POINT EIGHT BILLION IT
WENT UP TWENTY POINT TWO
BILLION DOLLARS ONLY NINETY
FIVE SCHOOLS ARE HAVE A NET
UNRESTRICTED. ASSETS OF ZERO OR
HIGHER JUST 10% SO I THINK WE
NEED TO HAVE A DISCUSSION ON
PUBLIC SCHOOLS IN OUR
PRELIMINARY ANALYSIS AND WE'RE
STILL YOU KNOW DATA DIVING. BUT
WE AREN'T WE'RE NOT SEEING AN
INDICATION THAT CHARTER SCHOOLS
ARE THE FISCAL PROBLEM. NOT
EVEN CLOSE. SO I WOULD LOVE TO
GET THE REPORTS AND STUDIES
FROM MY COLLEAGUE FROM BERKELEY
THAT WOULD HELP BECAUSE WE'RE
WE'RE COMING UP WITH A
DIFFERENT CONCLUSION SO FAR.
BUT SEVENTY POINT EIGHT BILLION
DOLLARS. WOULD YOU MAKE AN
INDEPENDENT OBSERVER CONCLUDE
THAT PERHAPS OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE MISMANAGED OR
SOMETHING IS WRONG WE GOT TO
LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICTS SUCH A
PERSON BUT ALSO SEE CHARTER
SCHOOLS PERHAPS AS DELIVERING A
MUCH BETTER PRODUCT. BUT
HOUSTON WE HAVE A BIG BIG
PROBLEM. BUT IT HAS BEEN
MISDIAGNOSED. AND AB FIFTY NO
FIVE IS THE ABSOLUTE WRONG YOUR-
I THINK THE ANALOGY USED
EARLIER THIS EVENING ABOUT A
SHINY OBJECT THIS IS ANY
OBJECTS SYNDROME IS REALLY SPOT
ON FROM THE SENATOR FOR MARANDA
BUT I WOULD CHALLENGE OUR
EDUCATION COMMITTEE CHAIR. I
WOULD CHALLENGE THE BUDGET AND
FISCAL REVIEWS SUB ONE CHAIR
THE YOU HAVE BIG JOBS YOU HAVE
BIG JOBS YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT
WHAT'S GOING ON HAVE TO WORK
WITH MIKE FINE FROM MATT DID
THESE ALREADY COME INTO
SACRAMENTO CITY. IN A COUPLE
WEEKS WE HAVE A BIG JOB SO
COLLEAGUES THIS BREAK REST UP
WE'VE GOT TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO
FIX OUR SCHOOLS DO YOURSELF ONE
FAVOR. VOTE NO. ON A. B.
FIFTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE MIKE UP SENATOR LEYVA
YOU MAY CONCLUDE. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT AS A PROUD
CHAIR OF SENATE EDUCATION AND
AS THE PROUD CHAIR OF THE
FICTITIOUS LABOR CAUCUS. I HAVE
A FEW THINGS THAT I WOULD LIKE
TO ADDRESS. MANY PEOPLE WHO
SPOKE IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL ACTUALLY HAVE NO IDEA HOW
MANY HOURS WITH INTO CRAFTING
THIS DEAL. THAT ALL SIDES MET
ALL SIDES WERE HEARD. MANY
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW THAT
COMPROMISE IS NOT CAPITULATION.
WE TALK A LOT ABOUT DYSFUNCTION
BETWEEN PARTIES AND WE SAY WHY
DON'T PEOPLE WORK TOGETHER AND
COMPROMISE THIS DEAL IS A
PRODUCT OF COMPROMISE THE
EASIEST THING TO DO IN THE
WORLD IS TO PICK WINNERS AND
LOSERS. THIS BILL DOES NOT PICK
WINNERS AND LOSERS THIS BILL
DOES WHAT TRUE NEGOTIATORS TO.
EVERYONE IS WALKING AWAY A
LITTLE BIT HAPPY. AND A LITTLE
BIT UNHAPPY. THAT'S TRUE
COMPROMISE THAT'S HOW WE GET
OUR JOB DONE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA HI ATKINS. HI
BATES NO BELL HI PORGES NO.
EFFORT I CABALLERO HI. CHIANG
NO DALLY NO DOT. HI DORADO I
GALGIANI. GLAZER. YEAH GONZALEZ
HI GROWTH NO HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO HIGHER TADO. HI
JACKSON ITUNES NOTE LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MERRELL. NO NIELSEN NO PAN. HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY RUBIO
AYE SKINNER AYE STERN AYE STONE
NOVEMBER OUR CASKEY AYE WIENER
AYE WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS GALGIANI. GLAZER.
BY TWENTY SEVEN DOES ELEVENTH
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS SENATOR HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT THERE IS A RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK. REQUESTING TO
SPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE. AND
JOINT RULE SIXTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF ALLOWING AMENDMENT
ALLOWING ASSEMBLY BILLS. FIFTY
FOUR EIGHTY ONE ONE ZERO EIGHT
SIX AND TWELVE NINETY TO BE
HEARD AND REPORTED.
WEST'S HAVE BEEN APPROVED BY
THE RULES COMMITTEE. AS FOR AN
AYE VOTE. SIR HURTS BRUCE WAS
BE ONE EIGHTY ONE RATHER THAN
EIGHTY ONE IS IT OKAY IF I'M
SORRY I AM SO SORRY ONE EIGHTY
ONE. A OKAY I AS A GET NO.
MISTER SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ THE RESOLUTION. RESULT THE
JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE AND SIXTY
TO BE DISPENSED WITH TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY BILL. FIFTY FOUR ONE
EIGHTY ONE TEN EIGHTY SIX AND
ASSEMBLY BILL TWELVE NINETY TO
BE HEARD AND REPORTED AFTER THE
DEADLINES AS REQUESTED. MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARE SO THAT A AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES. BILL. I
PURCHASED NO BRADFORD. I COME A
YEAR AGO I CHIANG. NO DALY NO
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI I
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO HI
TITLE I JACKSON. HI JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL
AYE MONNING I'M MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN AYE
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH BY RUBIO I
SKINNER AYE STERN. AYE STONE.
NO BURKE. CASKEY I WIENER AYE
WILK. EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS
EIGHT THE JOINT RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. SENATOR GROW FOR YOU
AND VOTE. THANK YOU GROVE NO
EYES TWENTY NINE KNOWS NINE THE
JOINT RULES HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED.
CENTER HERTZBERG THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT MEMBERS THERE
IS A NOTHER RESOLUTION AT THE
DESK REQUESTING PERMISSION TO
SUSPEND JOINT RULE SIXTY ONE
FOR THE PURPOSE OF ALLOWING THE
FOLLOWING ASSEMBLY BILLS BUT TO
BE AMENDED AFTER THE DEADLINE
ASSEMBLY BILL SIXTY EIGHT. SIX
FIFTY ONE SEVEN NINETY TWO
EIGHT EIGHTY ONE. ELEVEN
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN AGAIN THESE REQUESTS HAVE
BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE I ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE READ
THE RESOLUTION RESULT THE JOY
RULE SIXTY ONE BE DISPENSED
WITH TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY BILL.
686-517-9280 ONE ELEVEN SIXTEEN
AND ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN
FORTY SEVEN TO BE AMENDED AFTER
THE DEADLINE AS REQUESTED.
MEMBERS IS THERE ANY OBJECTION
TO APPLYING THE LAST ROLL CALL
VOTE OF TWENTY NINE TO NINE. IT
IS WE SHALL CALL THE ROLL AGAIN
MISTER SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ALLEN. I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS AYE BATES BILL. HI
PORGES. NO BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO AYE CHIANG. DALY NO
DODD I DORADO I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROW.
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO I
TADO. HI JACKSON AYE JONES NO
LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCKED NO
MORALE. NO NIELSEN NO PAN. HI
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. I STERN AYE STONE NO
NUMBER FIVE A COUNTY BY WINNER
HI WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS BATES. CHANGE GROWTH.
WILK. FIVE TWENTY NINE NO SEVEN
THE JOINT ROLES HAVE BEEN
SUSPENDED. SENATOR HERTZBERG. I
MOVE TO SUSPEND THE SENATE
RULES FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT FOR THE FOLLOWING
MEASURES AB ONE OR NINE A. B.
ELEVEN THIS IS ME AB ONE ONE
TWO THROUGH ONE TWENTY ONE. AND
A. B. TEN EIGHTY. YOUR
SECRETARY PLEASE WITH THE
RESOLUTION. SORRY NO RESOLUTION.
WE RESERVE JACKSON TO APPLYING
THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE EYES TWENTY
NINE NO SEVEN THE JOINT RULES
BEEN SUSPENDED. SENATOR
HERTZBERG TO MORE. BUSH THERE'S
A LETTER AT THE DESK REQUESTING
WITHDRAWAL OF ASSEMBLY BILL
FORTY EIGHT OF FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND ORDERING THE
MEASURE TO THE SECOND READING
PASSED FOR THAT WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO APPLYING THE PLEA
PREVIOUS ROLL CALL VOTE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE EYES TWENTY
NINE OH SEVEN AND THE SENATE
RULES HAVE BEEN SUSPENDED ONE
MORE. THE BILL'S WITH JOHN
EXCUSE ME CENTER HERTZBERG ONE
MORE AND IF THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR PLEASE PULL FILE ITEM
THREE TWENTY ONE AB FIFTEEN
FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA
FROM THE SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. THE DESK WILL NOTE
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING
RESOLUTIONS WE PLACE ON TODAY'S
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR ACR
SIXTY ONE ACR ONE OH NINE ACR
ONE FOURTEEN ACR ONE SEVENTEEN
ACR ONE EIGHTEEN ACR ONE TWENTY
ONE. ACR ONE TWENTY THREE ACR
ONE TWENTY SIX ACR ONE TWENTY
NINE ACR ONE THIRTY ONE ACR ONE
THIRTY TWO IS HRE ONE THIRTY
THREE ACR ONE THIRTY FOUR AND
ACR ONE THIRTY FIVE. SENATOR
DOLLY. THE MAN PRESIDENT LIKE
TO REMOVE AB SIX FIFTY EIGHT
FILE ITEM TO NINETY FOUR FROM
THE SPECIAL CONSENT. FOR ROLL
CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR
THE DESK WILL NOTE CENTER
WIENER. PRESIDENT PRESIDENT I'D
REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR PLEASE.
MOVE FILE ITEM SEVENTY THREE AB
ONE SIXTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY TO
THE NOT TO FILE THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER WIENER THE DESK
WILL NOTE SENATOR HOLLY
MITCHELL UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS BETTER PRESIDENT
PLEASE PROCEED. THANK YOU AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR I'D
LIKE TO REMOVE FILE ITEM ONE
FOUR NINE ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE TO THE INACTIVE
FILE. ITEM ONE FOUR NINE THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL THE DESK
WILL NOTE. SENATOR BILL. THE
PRESIDENT THERE ON MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR PLEASE MOVE AB
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE FILE ONE
EIGHT ONE TWO THE INACTIVE FILE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
BILL THE DESK WILL NOTE.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO LIFT
CALLS SO THIS WOULD BE THE
RIGHT TIME TO BE IN YOUR SEAT
AND MAKE SURE YOU WERE VOTED ON
EVERYTHING. WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BY
CABALLERO HI MITCHELL. I ROTH.
SIZE TWENTY SEVEN DOES TWELVE
THE MEASURE CARRIES FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI
GORGEOUS HI CABALLERO HI DOLLY.
GROWTH. MORE LOCK NO WILK. I
WAS THIRTY NO SEVEN THE MOTION
CARE MAJOR KERRY'S FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BY
CABALLERO AYE AYES FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE KEEP PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BY BATES BY BURGESS. THE
RAZA HI HILL AYE MERRELL. I
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONCE THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU.
ATKINS HI DORADO HI HERTZBERG.
HI HILL HI MCGUIRE. HI NIELSEN
AYE STERN AYE AYES FORTY NO
ZERO ON THE URGENCY AYE AYES
FORTY KNOWS ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN. ATKINS BY DODD.
BY DORADO HI GALGIANI. HI ALAN
HI GLAZER HI GROWTH. RUBIO. I
STERN HI NUMBER. BY BY BY
TWENTY NINE NEWS ELEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI
CARRIER BY DODD. DORADO AYE
GALGIANI. GLAZER AYE HUESO. I
AM A REAL. NO RUBIO AYE AYES
TWENTY DODD I DOUBT GALGIANI
ARE. EYES TWENTY EIGHT NEWS
TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS AYE BATES.
BURGESS. CHIANG BY DORADO. I
GALGIANI HI JACKSON BY MORE
LOCK. RUBIO I WILK. HI I THIRTY
ONE NO SIX THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ONE SEVENTY SEVEN EXCUSE ME.
ARCHULETA. I ATKINS I DORADO HI
GROWTH. NO JACKSON HI. FIVE
THIRTY TWO NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES THOSE EIGHT. THIRTY TWO
EXCUSE ME FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
TWO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS HI JANE. HI
DOLLY NO DORADO HI GROWTH.
HERTZBERG. BY TADO. HI JACKSON
HI. I CITY ONE NOTE EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES FIVE ONE EIGHTY
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS. HI BRADFORD HI
DODD. HI GROWTH. JACKSON HI
GROVE NO. EYES THIRTY KNOWS TEN
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS BY
BURGESS. DELHI GROW. GORGEOUS
HI DOLLY. GROVE HI JACKSON I AM
MCGUIRE HI. DALY AYE EYES FORTY
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM ONE EIGHTY SIX PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS FILE ITEM.
ONE NINETY ONE. ONE NINETY ONE
SORRY GUYS. ATKINS HI CABALLERO.
I DALY. GROWTH. NO JACKSON I
MORE LOCK. I THIRTY FOUR KNOWS
FOR THE MEASURE CAN'T PASSES
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBER.
ATKINS. HI GUYS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
TWO ZERO SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ATKINS HI
MCGUIRE I AM A REAL. BY NELSON.
HI ROTH HI EYES FORTY NEW ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
ELEVEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS AYE BATES HI
GROVE I HUESO BY MCGUIRE. FIVE
ROTH BY EYES FORTY NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
TWELVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS AYE BATES ARE A
GROWTH HI MCGUIRE. I ROTH AYE
RUBIO AYE AYES FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
THIRTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS HI GROWTH. HI
MCGUIRE AYE ROTH AYE AYES FORTY
NEW ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
FILE ITEM TO THIRTEEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. TO
FOURTEEN I'M SORRY WHAT I SAY.
CLEARLY I'M GETTING TIRED FILE
ITEM TO FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ATKINS HI
ROTH HI. I THIRTY NINE NO ZERO
EYES FOR HE WAS THERE FOR THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
FIFTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ATKINS HI ROTH HI GUYS
FORTY NEW ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO SEVENTEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS HI IN. HI ROTH IRA RUBIO
I WAS FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO NINETEEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS HI. PAN HI ROSS BY ICE
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO TWENTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS BY PAN. ARE A ROTH AYE
AYES FORTY NEW ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO THIRTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS HI GORGEOUS BY CHIANG.
DELHI GROVE JONES. MORE LOCK
MORRELL NIELSEN STONE WILK. BY
THIRTY ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO FORTY NINE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA HI BATES. HI BILL I
BURGESS. HI BRADFORD. BY
CABALLERO I CHIANG. BY DAILY HI
DORADO I GALGIANI AYE GLAZER
AYE GROW BY HUESO. I'M MORE
LOCK. I'M A REAL. I RUBIO I
SKINNER BY WIENER. HI AS FOR
JUST WE HAVE AS A THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY TWO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. HI COVER EURO I
CHIANG HI THERE ALSO AYE
GALGIANI AYE GROWTH TIME
ACQUIRE HI MITCHELL HIGH MORALE
BY RUBIO I SKINNER. HI WIENER
AYE AYES FORTY NEW ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE TO FIFTY
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. CHIANG HI DORADO I
GROWTH I RUBIO. I WIENER. AYE
AYES FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TWO FIFTY SIX
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHIANG I RUBIO BY ICE FORTY NO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
FOLLOWED HIM TO FIFTY EIGHT
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
CHIANG ARE A GROVE. MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI RUBIO I GROW BY.
ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO SIXTY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ARCHULETA. HI DORADO BY MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL. I RUBIO HI NUMBER.
HI ICE FORTY NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY ONE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL HI. AS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TO
SIXTY THREE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BATES GORGEOUS.
DALLY. GROWTH NO MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL BY MORE LOCK NO
NIELSEN NO. DALLY NO. BATES NO.
FOR JUST. EYES THIRTY ONE KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM TO SIXTY FOUR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. I MERRELL. FIVE
THIRTY NINE NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
BATES GORGEOUS. DALY NO MCGUIRE
HI MITCHELL. HI ICE THIRTY
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY SIX PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. CHIANG
I DORADO HI. GROWTH NO MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL AYE AYES THIRTY
ONE NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM TO SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. I'M
SORRY THIRTY ONE NINE. TWO
SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS TO SIXTY EIGHT.
ARCHULETA. HI MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. HI GUYS FORTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
TWO SEVENTY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FOR JUST. HI
CABALLERO. HI DOLLY I AM A
CHOIR HI MITCHELL. AYE AYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TWO SEVENTY
ONE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GROVE MCGUIRE. GROW BY
MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL. HI. EYES
FORTY NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM TO SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN HI THIRD.
CABALLERO DODD. GALGIANI HILL.
MCGUIRE HI. MITCHELL I RUBIO.
HILL AYE BRADFORD AYE RUBIO AYE.
GOOD PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WERE MORE TIME CARRIER.
I DODD GALGIANI HI EYES TWENTY
SEVEN KNOWS TWELVE THE MEASURE
PASSES
. MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO THE SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR
DOES ANYONE HAVE ANYTHING THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO HAVE REMOVED
FROM THE SPECIAL CONSENT TELL
CALENDAR. ALL RIGHT WE'RE ALL
GOOD MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ALL ITEMS ON THE CALENDAR.
ASSEMBLY BILL. TWENTY EIGHT ONE
THIRTY THREE ONE SIXTY FOUR TWO
A FOUR TWO SEVENTY ONE THREE OR
432-357-3724 006-417-4095.
FORTY THREE SIX FOURTEEN SIX
SIXTY TWO SIX EIGHTY FOUR SEVEN
FIFTEEN. 257-337-4087 FIFTY TO
A FIFTY TWO NINE FORTY SEVEN
AND 541-033-1070 529-297-1120.
SEVEN ELEVEN THIRTY TO ELEVEN
EIGHTY TWELVE TWENTY SEVEN
TWELVE THIRTY THREE TWELVE
901-382-1450. TO FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX FIFTEEN ELEVEN FIFTEEN
TWENTY TWO FIFTEEN TWENTY THREE
SIXTEE BILL SEVENTEEN
FIFTY FOUR ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION. SIXTY ONE ONE OH
NINE ONE FOURTEEN ONE SEVENTY
ONE EIGHTY ONE TWENTY ONE ONE
TWENTY
ONE TWENTY NINE ONE THIRTY ONE
ONE THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY THREE
ONE THIRTY FOUR ASSEMB ONE
THIRTY FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO USING OUR
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE AYE AYES FORTY
KNOWS ZERO CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
BEEN ADOPTED. DO WE HAVE ANY
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
HER TADO. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE IN A FOR
PURPOSES OF ANNOUNCEMENTS AND
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEE WILL
BE MEETING IN ROOM THIRTY ONE
ANYONE IMMEDIATELY UPON THE END
OF SESSION THANK YOU CENTER HER
TAUGHT SENATOR MITCHELL
REMINDER COLLEAGUES THAT SENATE
BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW WILL MEET
TOMORROW MORNING AT EIGHT
THIRTY FORTY TWO OR THREE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS SENATOR ACTIONS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. AND PRESIDENT
THANK YOU BYE ALL I CAN SAY IS
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUES FOR
AN INCREDIBLE DAY. A VERY HARD
WORK I ALSO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND SAY THANK YOU TO OUR
STAFFS. I'M NOT SURE WE
EXPECTED THE STATE A KICK OFF
SO. IN THE MANNER THAT IT DID
BUT WE MANAGED TO GET A GREAT
DEAL OF WORK DONE THANKS TO THE
FLOOR TEAM WE GOT WELL OVER A
HUNDRED WE GOT A HUNDRED
FIFTEEN BILLS DONE TODAY. FIVE
GRANTED A LOT WAS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR BUT YOU HAD TO
AGREE TO THAT SO THANK YOU. TO
OUR STAFF TO THE SERGEANTS TO
EVERYONE THAT HELPED US GET
THROUGH THE STATE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE WILL SEE YOU TOMORROW.
AT TEN AM TUESDAY SEPTEMBER
TENTH THANK YOU. MR MAJORITY
LEADER SAYS SHARP. TEN AM SHARP
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES THANK YOU
MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS THE
SENATE IS ADJOURNED TO SEE YOU
TOMORROW MORNING